COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WHO
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING TODAY HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO DON'T
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HERE
IN THE CAPITAL SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. FOR THE
RECORD WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
ACID THE CONTROL THE CALL THE
ROLL. EGGMAN HERE MELENDEZ. PAN
HEAR ABOUT THE DEATH SENATORS
PAN AM EGGMAN ARE PARTICIPATING
TODAY IN THE CAPITAL THOSE
PARTICIPATING PART PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR A REMOTE BECAUSE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING AN
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND I ASKED
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO RECOGNIZE
IT YEARS RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR. ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO AND MUTE PLEASE
SELECT THE ME BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSON I WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE
DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME.
AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC. WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS.
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. BRAWL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARCH PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL REMOVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR DAHLE
ONE THEN ZERO. PROCESS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
MUCH RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL BE MEETING DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE PROMOTE MEETING SERVICE AND
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS. MUTED
TODAY'S HEARING WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
SEVERAL PROGRAMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THIS PROGRAM. PROGRAMS INCLUDE
THE STATE HEARINGS DIVISION AND
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES. AND CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT. BEFORE WE
BEGIN CENTER PAN ANY OPENING
COMMENTS FROM YOU. OKAY AND THEN
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION ON STATE HEARINGS
WITH DIRECTOR KIM JOHNSON FIRST
OFF. THE MORNING DIRECTOR GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR-
AND MEMBERS THAT CAN JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
WILL INTRODUCE THE COMMITTEES TO
CHIEF MCCAULEY WHO AGAINST YOUR
QUESTIONS IN THE GENDER RATIO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THERE
WAS- ONE QUESTION I WILL ASK
WHICH WAS TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF I REQUEST HERE AND SO I WILL
THE REQUESTED LOVE TWO PARTS THE
STATE HEARINGS THE VISION PEACE
OF MIND AS THE LEGAL PIECE WHICH
I WILL TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ACCELERATION WILL. ALSO
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE STATE
ESTATE TEARING THE VISION AND
THE LEGAL IVISION OF THE C. B.
S. S. PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT
WITH THE NECESSARY REYES I
JUDICIAL AND LEGAL RESOURCES
NECESSARY OPERA COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND WOOD GROWING
WORKLOAD DEMANDS AND COMPLEXITY
ADDITIONAL STAFF I NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE ONGOING OPERATIONS
SO- REGARDING THE EIGHTEEN
STATES HEARINGS THE VISION
ASPECT THAT WERE REQUESTED ARE
THESE ARE IS THE REQUEST FOR
PERMANENT RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
HEARING ON OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
ENSURING THE CONTINUED
EFFICIENCY OF THE STATE'S
CURRENT PROCESS. AND TO SUPPORT
THE NEW WORKLOAD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT- REHABILITATION
THE SIX SIXTEEN OF THOSE HEARING
POSITIONS I NEEDED TO MAINTAIN-
GET EFFICIENCIES IN THE STATE
HEARING PROCESS THAT WE HAVE
GAINED ABOUT THE LAST TWO YEARS
I THINK CITIZENS HAS NOT
RECEIVED ANY SUPPORT POSITIONS
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN TO SUPPORT
THE HEARING PROCESS LEADING TO
AN INCREASING LACK RELY AND SOME
REDIRECTED. AND TEMPORARY. YEAH
WORK FOR. AND TO HELP US TO
HANDLE THE LOADS TO OPERATE. THE
J. FROM THE CASE. ARE THESE WERE
. RESOURCE WILL PROBABLY AND SO
WE ARE. THAT WOULD BE SWEET. THE
SS S. H. WILL BE ABLE TO ASSIST.
IMPROVE THE BILL OF YOUR PROCESS
VULNERABLE BENEFIT. OF THE
SERVICE OUT SERVICE. ARE TO
DRIVE RE CASE PROCESSING TIMES
THAT IMPROVE THE- OF THAT IS
THE- ARE WITH EXPECT TO CONTINUE
TO AVOID. CASE PENALTY BY MEANT
READ OUR- OF LESS THAN 1% OF
WHAT OUR PENALTIES WHERE AS OF
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY- WHICH
RESULT IN OF COURSE THAT
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE
GENERAL FUND- AND THEN ALSO THE-
CDSS HAS ENTERED INTO AN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
NOT TO CONDUCT HEARINGS FOR THE
DISABLED CALIFORNIANS AND WE'RE
REQUESTING TO S. AS THE AGENT
CARE POSITIONS TO HELP WITH THAT
WORKLOAD- THE SECOND PIECE OF
THE PIECE BCP HAS INDICATED IS
THE LEGAL PIECE I'LL TURN THAT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE I TORSIONAL
. WITH SOME INFORMATION GEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO GOOD
. THIS IS TORY SCHWAB AND THE
CHIEF CAN FOR THE- DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES. THE LEGAL
DIVISION IS REQUESTING FUNDING
AND AUTHORITY FOR ELEVEN AND A
HALF POSITIONS AND POSITION OF
AUTHORITY ONLY FOR THREE
POSITIONS TO MAINTAIN OUR
PERMANENT WORKLOAD. THE
POSITIONS ARE A MIX OF ATTORNEY
SUPERVISOR AND SUPPORT STAFF. TO
THE GROWTH OF NEW AND EXPANDED
PROGRAMS AND IMPROVE USE OF DATA
THE LEGAL DIVISION WORKLOAD OF
REVIEWING AND ADVISING ON
CONTRACTS GRANTS DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS AND MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING HAVE INCREASED TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PERCENT. OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD. FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY REQUESTED
FISCAL YEAR 200-018-1926 HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE REQUESTED FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
ONE. GETTING INTO THE SENATE
POSITIONS WERE REQUESTING WE'RE
ASKING FOR ONE AND A HALF
POSITIONS RELATED TO THE INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT. NOTICE WHICH
PROVIDES CONSULTATION FOR CDS
USCIS OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS
AND ASSIST WITH DRAFTING
NEGOTIATING AMENDING AND
IMPLEMENTING EXISTING AND NEW
TITLE II FORTY FEDERAL FUNDING
AGREEMENTS. THE ONE ATTORNEY
POSITION AND HALFTIME LEGAL
SECRETARY POSITIONS WERE
ORIGINALLY APPROVED IS LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS THAT EXPIRED IN
JAN THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THIS IS AN ONGOING PERMANENT
WORKLOAD SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
HAVE THOSE POSITIONS ARE
RESTORED AS PERMANENT POSITIONS
- THE LEGAL DIVISION IS ALSO
REQUESTING SEVEN ATTORNEYS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
OUR AND OUR ENFORCEMENT BRANCH
IT SUPPORTS THE COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING PROGRAMS THE KEY
POSITION REQUESTS RELATED TO
KEEPING UP WITH THE GROWTH IN
ADDITION OF NEW PROGRAMS AND
INCREASED COMPLEXITY IN AREAS
SUCH AS THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL HOMES SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
FACILITIES AND HOME CARE
SERVICES CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT. THESE POSITIONS ENSURE AN
ADEQUATE LEVEL OF EXPERTISE IN
LEGAL CONSULTATION TRAINING
MANAGEMENT AND SUPERVISION TO
SUPPORT THE PARALLEL
IMPROVEMENTS IN CCL SERVICE
DELIVERY. AND ENSURE BETER
OUTCOMES THE PERSON SERVED IN
LICENSE TO SOLICIT APPROVED
HOMES. LEGAL DIVISION ALSO
REQUESTING CONFORMING GROSS IN
OUR SUPPORT BRANCH WHICH WE CALL
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LEGAL
SERVICES BRANCH THE LEGAL
DIVISION HAS SIX OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO BE IN
CLOSE POXIMITY AND PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT TO OUR COMMUNICATOR
LICENSING OFFICES AND LICENSING
HEARINGS. AND FINALLY THE LEGAL
DIVISION IS REQUESTING A
ARGUMENTATION OF ITS OPERATIONAL
BUDGET TO ADDRESS A SHORTFALL IN
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED
COSTS FROM THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS- AB DE
CONDUCTOR ADMINISTRATIVE
LICENSING CASES INCREASES A
BILLING CHARGES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND INTERPRETER COSTS. THANK YOU
IS ANY QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER THEM OTHERWISE I RETURN
IT TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF ANYTHING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OUR
QUESTION DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
NOTICE ALL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
BUT HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU L. A. O. JACQUELINE
BRAZIL WOULD BE ALEJO NO MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME- BUT HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH THE SUB COMMITTEE AS WE
LEARN MORE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
COMMITMENT TO CALL YOUR SWAP CAN
YOU I MEAN JUST. SO YOU HAVEN'T
HAD AN INCREASE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN- IS THE INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD. JUST VOLUME OR IS IT
ALSO COMPLEXITY AND WHAT KINDS
OF CHANGES IN CASES HAVE YOU
SEEN FROM TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
UNTIL NOW. IT IS BOTH WE'VE HD
INCREASING VOLUME AND
COMPLEXITY- WE'VE HAD A CASE
CASE LOADS IN DIFFERENT AREAS
THAT HAVE INCREASED OVER TIME
AND OF COURSE THE COMPLEXITY OF
THESE CASES CONTINUE TO GROW. AS
WE HAVE- DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT I
INTRODUCED HIM TO THE STAGE
HEARINGS OUT PROCESS I'LL GIVE A
RECENT EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THAT
WE'VE HAD- HE SAYS IN THE-
CALIFORNIA CHILD- CCS CASES THAT
THE- CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
SERVICES CASES THAT HAVE BEEN
ADDED TRUCKEE'S NOTES. OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND THE SEVERAL
OF THE PROGRAMS AS WELL THAT WE
CAN SHARE WITH YOU AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT
MORE- DON'T YOU ALSO HAVE A
SECOND QUESTION FOR US REGARDING
THE DEAL OUR CASE LIMITED IF YOU
WANT ME TO ADDRESS THAT NOW
WE'LL JUST WAIT TILL. YES PLEASE
OKAY THANK YOU REGARDING THAT
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
ADDITIONALLY REAL COMPLEXITY
THAT HAS BEEN ADDED TO THE-
SHARING STAYS LOW WE HAD TO AND
AGREE INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT NOW
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION THAT HAS BEEN
FINALIZED THEM DOWN. TO THE IS
THE STARTED TO RECEIVE DEAL ARE
CASES AS OF FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND ACTIVISM IS
ADJUSTING WELL TO THAT AND THAT
THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENCES IN
THAT CASE THOSE ARE COMPARED TO
WHAT WE NORMALLY DO IN THAT
BILLS THAT THE DEAL ARGUES THAT
HAVE A TWO STEP HEARING AND
MEDIATION. A PROCESS THAT'S
REQUIRED AND SO THOSE
DIFFERENCES HAVE BEEN WORKED%
INTO THE STATE HEARINGS THAT
PROCESS INCLUDING ALL NECESSARY
CUSTOMIZATIONS TO OUR- APPEALS
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT'S
ALREADY CMS SYSTEM THAT WE USE-
CASE MANAGEMENT- WE HAVE A
DEDICATED GROUP OF JUDGES WHO
WILL HEAR THOSE CASES THEN THE
BALL COMPLETED MANDATORY
MEDIATION TRAINING CERTIFICATION
THAT WAS IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. I AND THEIR- OF THE
ABILITY TO HEAR THOSE CASES HAVE
BEEN CERTIFIED BY THE STATE
REHABILITATION COUNCIL AND SO WE
STARTED TO ALL THEIR SUBSTANTIVE
TRAINING HAS ALSO BEEN COMPLETED
AND WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THEY'RE
READY TO ASSUME THIS WORKLOAD AT
THIS TIME- IN ADDITION WE
PROVIDED A HUNDRED- HEARINGS ONE
ON ONE TRAINING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
STAFF AND REPRESENTATIVES I THAT
WAS IN. OF TWENTY TWO AND
RESTRICT. FEEDBACK ON THAT TRAIN
- CDS ALSO. A LOT OF MY- AND ON
ON I'M MORE. WE WOULD CALL OUT
OF THE- IN TRYING TO GET MY-
WHICH- ENABLES ACCURATE. TO VERY
NEXT. TO FAMILY AND UP. OF
PUBLIC SOCIAL SO. I AM SO GOING
TO GET TO COME. THAT PRACTICE OF
ENCOURAGE. OUT HEARING.
RESOLUTION WITH A PARTY'S. TO
ENSURE A OUT SO I LANDS IN THE
PROCESS THEM NOW THIS PRODUCT
SYSTEM IN CONJUNCTION WITH
DIVERSITY INCLUSION TRAINING THE
WOULD DUMP. OF OUR TEAMS. ARE
HAS THAT THE- A STAFF US IT'S IN
THE INVOLVED HANDLE. THE THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US. I INCLUDING THIS
NEW DEAL CSE THE- AS WELL. AND
ALSO IN A QUESTION YOU HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU YOUR. YOU'RE
SAYING THE- PEOPLE ARE HAVING UP
EXPERIENCE IN YOUR DAY ON ALL AS
WELL FOR THE BUDGET OKAY IN THE
AND X. OKAY YES WE DO. THANK
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
INTERESTING I THE PRESENT WILL
MOVE ON ISSUE NOT TWO OFFICE OF
EQUITY- OVERVIEW. THANK YOU
TERRY I'M GOING TO TURN OVER I
THINK TO ME CAPT WHO WILL GET
STARTED FOR THE SIX THANK YOU
MUCH. WELL GOOD AFTERNOON. ARE
YOU HEARING ME I'M SORRY.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
EGGMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MAUREEN
CASPER AND I AM THE CHIEF OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACCEPTABILITY AND
RACIAL EQUITY OR CARE OFFICE
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF EQUITY. AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AFTER THE INTRODUCTION
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE. SOME
INFORMATION WITH YOU TODAY ON
INVESTMENTS AN CDSS OFFICE OF
EQUITY PROGRAMS. THE BACKGROUND
MATERIALS FOR THE HEARING
INCLUDED INFORMATION ON THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL FOR
OFFICE OF EQUITY STAFFING. TO
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT'S FEDERAL
CIVIL RIGHTS COMPLIANCE.
OVERSIGHT AND COMPLAINT HANDLING
MANDATES. SO IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU ALL MOVE INTO THE TO
PROGRAM SPECIFIC INVESTMENTS
ADDED TO PROVIDE UPDATES. AT ALL
TODAY. AND I'M HAPPY TO FIELD
ANY QUESTIONS. ABOUT ANY OF
THESE INVESTMENTS. THE FIRST
PROGRAM I WANTED TO MENTION IS
THAT CRISES ACT. ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE EIGHTEEN. WHICH AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT TO ADMINISTER THE
COMMUNITY RESPONSE INITIATIVE TO
STRENGTHEN EMERGENCY SYSTEMS OR
CRISES GRANT PILOT PROGRAM. THIS
IS NOT A NEW INVESTMENT THIS
FISCAL YEAR BUT IS ON GOING FROM
THAT. FROM THE CURRENT YEAR-
IT'S A TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
KILEY PROGRAM FOR GRANT MAKING
TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. TO LESSEN
RELIANCE ONLINE FORSMAN AGENCIES
AS FIRST RESPONDERS IN CRISIS
SITUATIONS. CDSS HAS BEEN IN
CONSULTATION WITH A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. WHO WORK TO
DEVELOP THE CRAZY BACK
LEGISLATION- AND I CAN PROVIDE
SOME UPDATES ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION STATUS TO DATE-
WE ISSUED AN RFI. OR
CONSULTANTS- TO ENGAGE IN
SPECIALIST HE OF THE- MANDATED
STATE WORK. AND AS WELL AS ITS
VALUE. ANTI IS. FOR THE GRANT
PILOT PROGRAMS- THAT ARE S. I.
WAS ISSUED IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- WE ARE EXPECTING TO
AWARD IT CONTRACTS ONE OR MORE
CONTRACTS UNDER THAT REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION- SOMETIME THIS
SPRING. WE HAVE ALSO BEEN
WORKING AS A SAID INFORMALLY AND
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. TO DEVELOP AN
APPLICATION PROCESS AT FOUR
MEMBERS OF THE FORMAL
STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUP- WHICH WE
WILL BE PUBLICIZING IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND WE HOPE TO.
LAUNCH THE AT THE STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUPS OPERATIONS ALSO IN
THE SPRING OF THIS YEAR- WE
ANTICIPATE ISSUING A REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS FOR PILOT PROJECTS
IN THE FALL OF THIS YEAR AND
EXPECT TO HAVE A WORDS ISSUED BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD- AGAIN THIS
IS A TEN MILLION DOLLAR PILOT
PROGRAM- AND- WE EXPECT THE
FUNDS TO BE AWARDED. AT BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR. THAT'S THE
STATUS CURRENTLY OF THE CRISIS
ACT- I WILL MOVE INTO UPDATES ON
THAT HEAT INCIDENTS PROGRAM- AND
AGAIN HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
ABOUT BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS. IF
THERE ARE ANY- THE HATE
INCIDENTS SURVIVOR AND PREVENT
SERVE PRO. IS OF A HUNDRED AND
TEN MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
OVER THREE YEARS TO. SUPPORT
COMMUNITY BASED BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND PROVIDING
SERVICES TO VICTIMS OF HATE
INCIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
TO ENGAGE IN PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES. PROGRAM IS BEING
ADMINISTERED BY CDSS IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE COMMISSION
ON ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN AFFAIRS- CDSS AND THE
COMMISSION JOINTLY HELD A SERIES
OF LISTENING SESSIONS IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHERE
WE HAD PARTICIPATION FROM OVER A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS AND
STAKEHOLDERS AT PROVIDING INPUT
ON. THE NEEDS GAPS AND
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE AREA OF
ANTI HEAT SERVICES AND
PREVENTION. THERE WERE NEEDS
IDENTIFIED IN AREAS OF
CULTURALLY COMPETENT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES LEGAL SERVICES
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND
ALTERNATIVES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AS WELL AS USE DEVELOPMENT
SENIOR SAFETY AND A LARGE NUMBER
OF OTHER AREAS AND SO WITH THAT
INFORMATION I GATHER FROM THOSE
LISTENING SESSIONS IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE CDSS ISSUED
AN RSA FOR THE STOP THE HEAT
PROGRAM. FOR UP TO TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND AGAIN
INCORPORATING INPUT FROM THE
COMMISSION AND FROM THESE
LISTENING SESSIONS- WE ARE
CURRENTLY REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS- UNDER THE STOP THE
HATE RSA AND WE ANTICIPATE
MAKING AWARDS AT IN APRIL OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WE ARE ALSO.
RUNNING HELLO. FOR A TRANS
FORMATIVE GRANT AWARD. WHICH
WERE BE MADE IN. TO
ORGANIZATIONS WITH A
DEMONSTRATED CAPACITY TO
ADMINISTER LARGE SCALE ANTI HEAT
SERVICE AND PREVENTION PROGRAMS
AND WE ALSO EXPECT TO ANNOUNCE
THOSE AWARDS THIS SPRING. AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE SO- I CAN TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE ELIANA
CAME AWAY TO ADDRESS THE OTHER
ITEMS IN ISSUE TWO. THANK YOU.
WELCOME IS GONE WHAT. I GET UP
AT YOUR ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ELIANA CAME
WITH MY AND THE IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION BRANCH CHIEF AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU HERE TODAY- THE
BACKGROUND MATERIALS FOR THE
HEARING INCLUDE INFORMATION ON
THE REFUGEE CASH ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT SERVICES AS WELL AS AN
OVERVIEW OF THE IMMIGRANT INTO
GEAR INTEGRATION PROGRAMS WE
ADMINISTER AND BACKGROUND
INFORMATION PROVIDED IN JANUARY
ON AFGHAN ARRIVALS. SO WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I WILL MOVE ST TO
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS POSED IN
THE AGENDA THAT'S FINE. THE
FIRST WAS REGARDS TO THE ONE
MALE. HOW THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION. AS YOU KNOW LAST
SUMMER THE BUDGET ACT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALLOCATED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS THE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
IMMIGRATION SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE. SINCE THEN CDSS WITH AN
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND
IMMIGRATION SERVICES GIVEN THE
POSSIBILITY OF FEDERAL
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD CREATE
NEW IMMIGRATION BENEFITS FOR
CERTAIN GROUPS. DURING THE FALL
OF LAST YEAR CONGRESS WAS
CONSIDERING SEVERAL LARGE PIECES
OF FEDERAL LEGISLATION- THAT
COULD HAVE BROUGHT SOME FORM OF
IMMIGRATION REFORM OR POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS TO LEGAL LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENCY OR
CITIZENSHIP FOR CERTAIN GROUPS-
THIS TYPE OF EXPANSION OF
BENEFITS WOULD REQUIRE A QUICK
EXPANSION OF IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES CAPACITY. TO MEET THE
DEMAND FOR SUPPORT IN APPLYING
FOR ANY BENEFIT. IN OUR BEST
GIVEN THE LIMITATIONS OF
EXISTING LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS
INCLUDING THE SMALL NUMBER OF
IMMIGRATION LAWYERS IN
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE CONSIDERING
USING THE APPLICATION AND
FUNDING TO SUPPORT AN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR CREDITED
REPRESENTATIVES. WORK FOR TRAIN
TO NAVIGATE IMMIGRATION LAW
PROCESS NEEDS TO HELP IMMIGRANTS
THROUGH THE IMMIGRATION BENEFITS
APPLICATION PROCESS. THE ONE
TIME FUNDS WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT SUPPLEMENT THREE KEY
AREAS OF SERVICE OUR REGION
EDUCATION LEGAL SERVICES AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. CONCEPTS
ARE CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED
WITH THE PROJECTED TIMELINE OF
ANNOUNCING FUNDING AWARDS BY
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THIS
YEAR. THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA WAS- I REQUEST YOU
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE WORK
AT THE COMPANY DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORTING RECENT
AFGHAN ARRIVALS. LET ME BEGIN
WITH SOME UPDATE AND BACKGROUND
TO PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT AROUND
THE WORK THE DEPARTMENT TO
SUPPORT RECENT ARRIVALS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SINCE AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA HAS NOW RESETTLED
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
AFGHANS. AFTER NEWCOMERS OF
SEVERAL PRIMARILY IN NINE
COUNTIES WITH THE LARGEST
NUMBERS ARRIVING IN SACRAMENTO
SAN DIEGO AND LAST AND THE LAST
COUNT. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERED WITH TWENTY FOUR LOCAL
RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INITIAL
RESETTLEMENT OF THESE NEWCOMERS
. OUR AFTERNOON PERMISSIVE
EXPERIENCED SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN THE RESETTLEMENT
PROCESS INCLUDING DELAYS IN THE
RECEIPT OF FEDERAL DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
CARDS AN EMPLOYMENT
AUTHORIZATION DOCUMENT. LIMITED
RESETTLEMENT AGENCY AND
COMMUNITY PARTNER CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE RESETTLEMENT SERVICES.
AND NO DIRECT PATHWAY TO LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENCY IS EXPECTED
TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM. THAT'S THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
ACCESSING AFFORDABL HOUSING. AT
THE DEPARTMENT WE ARE
CONTINUOUSLY WORKING TO ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES. WITH REGARDS
TO THE FEDERAL DOCUMENTATION
CHALLENGE CDSS IS. ELEVATING THE
DIFFICULTIES CREATED BY THE LACK
OF DOCUMENTATION TO OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS AT THE U. S.
CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES AND THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
WORKING WITH OUR COUNTY PARTNERS
TO FIND WORKAROUNDS AND
STREAMLINE ACCESS TO PUBLIC
BENEFITS. THE DRESS THE
CHALLENGES OF LIMITED AGENCY IN
COMMUNITY PARTNER CAPACITY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN COORDINATING
THE ASSIGNMENT OF SHORT TERM
FEDERAL STAFFING. AND SUPPORTING
CONNECTIONS OF VOLUNTEER GROUPS
IN ADDITION NEXT MONTH-
DEPARTMENT WILL ANNOUNCE THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR STATE GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENT. INCREASE
SERVICES AT RESETTLEMENT
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS
FOR ACT ARRIVALS. TO ENSURE
CONTINUED ACCESS TO CASE
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER SUPPORT
SERVICES. OKAY ACCESS TO
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES FOR
AFGHAN NEWCOMERS WERE CURRENTLY
EXPECTED TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM AS
A PATHWAY TO LEGAL PERMANENT
RESIDENCY THE DEPARTMENT IS
LEVERAGING THE IMMIGRATION
SERVICES FUNDING PROGRAMS TO
INCREASE CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. AND ALSO EXPLORING
WAYS TO INCREASE PRO BONO.
PRIVATE ATTORNEY INVOLVEMENT AND
WE EXPECT TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR THE EXPANSION OF THE
SERVICES. PROGRESS THE HOUSING
CHALLENGE AT THE DEPARTMENT'S
BEEN WORKING WITH THE DISASTER
HOUSING CONSULTANT AND THIS
MONTH WE ARE LAUNCHING A HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT WILL
SUPPORT THE TRANSITION OF AFGHAN
RIVALS FROM HOUSING. MANY AFGHAN
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
CURRENTLY. IN FEDERALLY OR
PRIVATELY FUNDED HOTELS OR OTHER
SHORT TERM HOUSING FACILITIES AS
THE RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES FIND
THEM LONG TERM HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITY. THE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS INTENDED
TO SUPPORT RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES
IN IDENTIFYING AVAILABLE UNITS
AS WELL AS PROVIDING DIRECT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS. CDSS WILL BE
INVESTING THIRTY EIGHT POINT TWO
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
AFGHAN HOUSING ASSISTANCE. THIS
FUNDING AS PART OF THE FEDERAL
SEVENTY NINE MILLION REFUGEE
SUPPORT SERVICES THE WARD
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL OFFICE
OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED TO DATE
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT AFGHAN
NEWCOMERS. WE MAY STILL RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL- ARE FUNDING FOR THIS
POPULATION. REMAINING FUNDING
MAY BE USED TO EXPAND EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES INCREASE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE OR PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR AFGHAN YOU
COME. THE DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO
BE AWARDING OVER SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR ACTIVITIES
THAT LEAD TO THE EFFECTIVE
INTEGRATION AND EDUCATION OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. AND
PROVIDING ABOUT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REFUGEE HEALTH PROMOTION TO
PROMOTE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
NEWCOMERS. AS I NOTED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS MADE
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE WORK ACT AND ARRIVALS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS WORKING WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
REGION'S RESETTLING THE MOST
AFGHAN. SETTLEMENT AGENCIES AND
OTHER NONPROFITS TO IDENTIFY
THOSE IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND THE
MECHANISMS TO MOST EFFECTIVELY
STARVATION PROGRAM. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALSO INCREASED
FUNDING FOR ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS
AFGHANS AND OTHER REFUGEES ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR SUCH AS REFUGEE
CASH ASSISTANCE. THESE FUNDING
AUGMENTATIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
FLOW THROUGH COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES WHO ADMINISTER
THE SAFETY NET PROGRAM. WITH ALL
OUR INVESTMENTS YES THAT'S WILL
CONTINUE PARTNERING WITH
RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES COMMUNITY
PARTNERS COUNTIES. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO SUPPORT THE SUCCESSFUL
INTEGRATION OF AFGHAN NEWCOMERS
INTO CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO STAND
READY TO CONTINUE WELCOMING
OTHER SEEKING. REFUGE FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY LET'S
GO TO THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
CARSON DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
HELLO. AFTERNOON SCHEDULE SHORT
WITH THE L. A. L. JUST A QUICK
COMMENT REGARDING THE REQUEST
FOR THE- RESOURCES FOR
COMPLIANCE REVIEWS AND
COMPLAINTS OBLIGATIONS- WE'VE
REVIEWED THAT BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL AND HAVE NO CONCERNS AT
THIS TIME- AND NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS THAT AT THE MOMENT
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- FOR THE FOR THE CRISIS
PROGRAM IT WAS A HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE ARE
GETTING READY TO STEP ABOARD
TWENTY. I NEED TO BE SPENT OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD AS I
UNDERSTAND IT AND SO. NEXT YEAR
IN THE FOLLOWING YEAR THE
ALLOCATION THAT WE GIVE OUT WILL
BE BIGGER OR- HOW GOOD ON ALL.
YOURS FREE TODAY HATE INCIDENTS
PROGRAM YES I'M SORRY YES. YES
SO THAT IS THE INITIAL RSA THAT
WE ISSUED FOR THAT THIS YEAR IS
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AT THE WE
WERE ALLOCATED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CURRENT YEAR AND
THEN FORTY EACH IN THE NEXT TWO
YEARS- AS I SAID. IT RSA FOR THE
STOP HE PROGRAM WAS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. WE HAVE ANOTHER
TEN MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
AND THAT WILL BE ALLOCATED FOR
THE TRANSFORMATIVE BRANDS THAT I
MENTIONED THAT ARE BY INVITATION
BETWEEN THOSE TWO PROCESSES WILL
WE WILL ANTICIPATE ALLOCATING
THE FULL THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR. THEN IN
ENDING IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS WE
WILL HAVE FORTY MILLION AND
FORTY MILLION. TO DISTRIBUTE-
AND SO THE IDEA IS VERY LIKELY
TO CONTINUE. WITH RENEWALS ARE
AUGMENTATIONS I AM LOOKING AT
FILLING GAPS WITH ADDITIONAL-
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
WHERE ADDITIONAL NEEDS ARE
IDENTIFIED- SO WE DO ANTICIPATE
BEING ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE THOSE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AMOUNTS AND
IN COMING YEARS. OKAY THANK YOU
ANNA AND ALL OF THIS ALL THESE
NEW PROGRAMS AND NEW ATTENTION
IS- IS BEING DONE AGAINST THE
BACKDROP OF THE NOON NEW NINE
EIGHT EIGHT SYSTEM SO. I WOULD
JUST THINK THAT WE JUST WE NEED
TO BE MINDFUL ABOUT HOW ALL
THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO
INTEGRATE TOGETHER AND LOOP BACK
AROUND SO WE DON'T HAVE-
REDUNDANCY OR POINTING PEOPLE
AND IN WRONG DIRECTIONS- ON THE
ON THE ONE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM-
WITH FUNDING MORE CREDENTIALED-
IMMIGRATION- M. CALPERS IF YOU
WELL. HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM ABUSE
SINCE WE KNOW THAT THIS
DEMOGRAPHIC OFTEN IS ABUSED MORE
THAN ANY OTHER BY- PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT QUALIFIED TO BE
PROVIDING ADVICE AND OFTENTIMES
TAKE A LOT OF MONEY FOR FOLKS.
SO AS WE'RE AND WE ARE TRYING TO
GET MORE CREDENTIAL PEOPLE OUT
THERE. DO WE ALSO HAVE A PAYROLL
PLAN TO MAKE SURE. THOSE AND
CREDENTIALED ARE NOT- USING ANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO PREY UPON
PEOPLE. EGGMAN THAT QUESTION I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT IS ONE OF
THE EFFORTS OF OUR EDUCATION OUT
REACH FUNDING TO REALLY GOING.
TO FOR AN ACTUAL STATE LICENSE
ATTORNEY AND OR UNDER CREDIT
REPRESENTATIVE AND WHAT THE
REPUTABLE ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN
ANY GIVEN REGION- THAT YOU
SHOULD BE TURNING TO HER
ASSISTANCE SO A LOT OF THE
EDUCATION OUTREACH WORK IS
FUNDED TO DO JUST THAT RIGHT
PEOPLE TO THE PLACES WHERE THEY
CAN GET HIGH QUALITY
REPRESENTATION AND WE KNOW ALSO
THAT IN THE SPACES WE ARE NOT
THE ONLY PARTNERS PHILANTHROPY
IS ALSO. ENGAGING ENTITIES
COMEDIAN EDUCATION OUT REACH
EFFORTS OF THE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND KNOW
WHEN THERE IS AN ACTUAL BENEFIT
TO APPLY FOR BECAUSE OF COURSE
THAT MISINFORMATION CAN BE
RAMPANT IN THE SPACE. THANK YOU
CAN I GUESS JUST ON THE- THE
NOTE OF OUR- AFGHANISTAN
REFUGEES THAT WERE ALL FIGHTING
FOR THE SAME WORK FORCE OF THE
SAME HOUSING. GOING TO GET THERE
OKAY THANK YOU PAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION- A FEW QUESTIONS
YOUR FIRST OF ALL I DO WANT TO
THANK THE PART OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR YOUR WORK ON- THE-
SHE ROUND THE UP. HELP
SUPPORTING VICTIMS OF HATE THAT
CAME OUT OF THE S. R. EIGHTY S.
A. P. I. CAUCUS- EQUITY BUDGET
AND- BECAUSE WE ARE DEALING WITH
THE CRISIS AND- ASIAN HATE-
RISING OUT. WITH CO THE FORTUNE
WAS THERE BEFORE BUT IT
DEFINITELY ROSE WITH CODED. AND-
UNFORTUNATELY OF SOME SOME
LEADERS NATIONALLY WHO WHO PUT A
TARGET ON APR WITH WORDS LIKE
CHINA VIRUS AND- CONFLUENCE SO
FORTH. AND FORTY WE ARE STILL
SUFFERING FROM THIS. I GUESS IT
IN AGAIN APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH COMMISSION AND THE CAUCUS-
CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO IN TERMS
OF- HOW MANY- SO YOU TALKED
ABOUT IT HOPEFULLY IN APRIL
TWENTY SECOND SO I KNOW IT TAKES
TIME TO STAND UP THESE PROGRAMS-
THAT WE GET SOME INITIAL MONEY
OUT AND THEN YOU'RE GONNA DO THE
TRANSFORMATION WORK AND- CENTS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THIS.
SPRING HE SPEAK TO THE SIZE OF
THE TRANSFORMATION FUNDS THAT
YOU'RE PLANNING TO DISTRIBUTE
SO- IN IN THE SPRING BUT WHAT'S
WHAT'S WHAT'S THAT OUR FATE ON
THE LOOKING LIKE. YEAH THANK YOU
FOR THAT BECAUSE THE QUESTION
CENTER CAN. DAY THAT TRANSFORMED
OF GRANT FUNDING THAT IS IT IT
IS NOT GOING TO BE DISTRIBUTED
BY. RSA IT'S AN INVITATION
PROCESS- BASED ON AN ASSESSMENT
OF THE POOL OF APPLICANTS IN
PART. WHO OUTSIDE FOR THE STOP
THE HATE GRANT PROGRAMS- AND
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN FROM
THE FIELD AROUND THE ABILITY TO
CAPACITY TO ABSORB ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- SO ED. THESE ARE
INVITATION ONLY GRANTS- THEY
WILL BE AWARDED IN AMOUNTS OF A
MINIMUM OF A MILLION DOLLARS-
AND SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
BETWEEN. THE POOL AND STOP THE
HATE AND THE POOL OF
TRANSFORMATIVE GRANTEES BEING
ABLE TO ALLOCATE THE TOTAL
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR OKAY EXCELLENT AND-
IN EVERYONE THE CHALLENGES FOR
THE API COMMUNITIES OF COURSE
WE'VE BEEN TREMENDOUSLY
UNDERFUNDED BOTH EITHER BY
GOVERNMENT. OR BY PHILANTHROPY-
THERE IS SOME THE FUNDING-
THAT'S BEING DISTRIBUTED ARE YOU
SURPRISED I ASSUME IT'S GONNA BE
MORE TRANSFORMATION GRANT. IS
GONNA IS IN TERMS OF CAPACITY
BUILDING BECAUSE I THINK PART OF
THE REASON WE'RE HAVING THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE FACING.
IS THAT AGAIN WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY UNDERFUNDED
COMMUNITY. AND L. TWO OFF AND
YEAH API GET LEFT OUT WHEN
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT COMMUNITIES OR
DISADVANTAGED AND SO FORTH EVEN
THOUGH YOU KNOW THE DATA SHOW
THAT'S NOT TRUE- SO I JUST. WANT
IS IT HAS BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT
CAPACITY BUILDING AND COMMUNITY
HOW HOW DO WE GET HOW TO BUILD
THAT CAPACITY BECAUSE HE SAID I
AGREE WITH YOU YOU CAN'T YOU
DON'T GIVE PEOPLE MORE MONEY
THEY CAN USE OR HANDLE RIGHT WE
DON'T WASTE WE DON'T WANT. AN
APPROPRIATE USE OF FUNDS WHICH-
BUT WE IS A HIGHLY BILL THAT
CAPACITY IN IT IN THE API
COMMUNITY- SO THAT- SO WE CAN
DELIVER MORE. SERVICES AND
SUPPORT TO THE COMMUNITY.
ABSOLUTELY DANGER AND JUST
CAPACITY BUILDING HAS COME UP A
LOT IN THE IN THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD THE LISTENING
SESSIONS- WITH. WITH AS
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AS OUR WORK WITH THE
COMMISSION. WE ARE REALLY
ENVISIONING THESE TRANSFORMATIVE
FRANCE AS AS A MEANS TOWARD
BUILDING THAT CAPACITY. FUNDING
YOU KNOW THE SPECIFIC ANTI HATE
SERVICES ANTI HE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES BUT ALSO IN THE
PROCESS BUILDING IN TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- FOR ORGANIZATIONS TO
BE ABLE TO SCALE UP THEIR
OPERATIONS- YOU KNOW- ALLOCATING
THE FUNDING OVER A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME SO THAT THERE IS SOME
RAMP UP- AND CHAT. SO THE
TRANSFORMATIVE FRANCE WILL
ACTUALLY BE OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD A MINIMUM OF A MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS TO
ALLOW FOR SOME OF THAT AT SOME
OF THAT GROWTH WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATION. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
REALLY. HEARTENED TO SEE THE
INTERESTING COLLABORATIONS IN
THE INTEREST IN SOME OF THESE
LARGER MORE ESTABLISHED
ORGANIZATIONS AND WORKING WITH.
YOUR GROUPS THAT ARE SMALLER
GROUPS THAT HAS YOU KNOW.
LARGELY VOLUNTEER BASED. RATHER
THAN A LOT OF PERMANENT
EMPLOYEES AND REALLY WORKING TO
BRING THOSE ORGANIZATIONS A
LAUNCH AND AS COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERS I SUB GRANTEES- AND SO
WE REALLY ARE EXPECTING THIS
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO BE THIRTY
YEARS TO BUILD SOME OF THAT
CAPACITY. THAT ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT IS SO
NEEDED IN THE SPACE. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN I GUESS
FINALLY RELATION TO THIS- BY
MORE COMMENT THAN A QUESTION IS
THAT OF COURSE WE ALSO NEED TO
BUILD LANGUAGE CAPACITY NOW A
LOT OF A COMMUNICATIONS HAVE
THAT LANGUAGE CAPACITY BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT- IS. NO THIS
FUNDING IS USED TO HELP BRIDGE
TOWARD- GREAT INVESTMENTS WE'RE
MAKING HERE AT ST WHICH WE TALK
ABOUT LIKE A MENTAL HEALTH AND
OTHER TYPES OF. SOCIAL SERVICES
ETCETERA. I THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIG BARRIERS IS LANGUAGE AND- IS
SO. AND US YOU KNOW THE API
COMMITTEE SPEAKS MANY MANY
LANGUAGES SO IT'S NOT LIKE YOU
CAN JUST HAVE SPANISH AND YOU'RE
DONE- ALTHOUGH I DO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S VARIOUS DIALECTS IN
THE LATINO COMMUNITY SO IT'S- AS
WELL SO THAT- BUT I THINK FOR
THE PARTICULAR FOR THE API
COMMUTERS MANY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES SO WE- WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT. WHEN YOU KNOW
BUILDING LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND
LANGUAGE CASSIDY IN THE STATE
ITSELF IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT AND- SO I THINK AS WE
LOOK AT- INVESTMENTS IN THAT
REGARD THAT DOES LINK UP TO IS
WE'RE BUILDING PASSING
COMMUNITIES FOR THE COMMUNITIES
AND REFER PEOPLE FOR STATE
SERVICES- AND WHETHER TO
COUNTIES ARE DIRECTLY THE STATE
WE NEED TO HAVE THE LANGUAGE
CAPACITY- THE- TERMS OF. ONE
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE OF- THE H. I. COCCUS
IN THIS PART OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS AND ADVOCATING FOR ONE
CALIFORNIA AGAIN I GUESS THERE'S
A CAPACITY ISSUE WHICH I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT- THINGS WE SHOULD BE DOING
TO SO IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING.
THAT YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND AND
SUPPORT OF- WHAT'S BEING
SUGGESTED IN TERMS OF BUILDING A
CASTING AND DOJ. BUT YOU KNOW IT
IS A SOMEONE LOOKING AT THE FACT
THAT- WE TRY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS OUT.
THERE- AND THAT'S FOR THE REASON
YOU. YEAH ONLY SO MANY SOME YOU
CAN FIND OUT THERE BUT THEN
ALSO- THINKING ABOUT- ADDITION
TO. HOW DO YOU GROW THAT
PIPELINE- WHAT IS THE DEMAND
SELECTION MAYBE HIS SPEECH ALSO
WHAT'S OF THE MAN FROM ONE
CALIFORNIA SERVICES THAT THIS
THE AGENCY HAS SEEN SO- AND-
BASICALLY HOW MUCH. HOW FAR
BEHIND- IN TRYING TO MEET THAT-
THAT NEED. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION A GOOD MAN I THINK
THAT- THAT THEY NEED ONCE WE
SOMETIMES A TO CHANGES IN
FEDERAL POLICY. THAT YOU KNOW AS
WE HAVE SEEN DIFFERENT TIMES
WHEN THERE'S BEEN NEED FOR
REMOVAL DEFENSE THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN- PERHAPS NATURALIZATION
APPLICATIONS AND OTHER YOU KNOW
RIGHTS DACA BENEFITS THAT THAT
HAVE. BEEN IN DEMAND AT
DIFFERENT TIMES SO I THINK THAT
THE TYPE OF CAPACITY WOULD BUILD
OUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE DO
HAVE A LEGAL FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
OKAY DEPARTMENT GETS FUNDING.
FOR MOBILE DEFENSE IN PARTICULAR
AND THIS IDEA OF EXPANDING THE
CAPACITY THROUGH- VA ACCREDITED-
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE ACCREDITED
REPRESENTATIVES IT IS THAT IDEA
THAT PERHAPS YOU KNOW WE DON'T
CONTROL THAT THE PIPELINE FOR
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS BUT WE CAN
HELP TRAIN ADDITIONAL- STAFF
THAT CAN. YOU KNOW THEY CAN HAVE
THAT AT THE GENERAL
UNDERSTANDING OF IMMIGRATION
LAWS AND THE ETHICS TRAININGS IN
ALL OF THE OTHER REQUIRED HE
SAYS. TO REALLY PROVIDE-
CLEARING. ON ON THE PATH THREE.
BENEFITS SO THAT WE IS SOMETHING
FOR JUST BEHIND THE THING OF A
SUPPORTING THOSE TYPE OF A
CREDIT EUROPE. BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
YEARS OF LAW SCHOOL OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TRAINING. AND WE CAN
HOPEFULLY BRING AND- YOU KNOW
I'M MORE MULTI LINGUAL
WORKFORCE- AND- EXPAND CAPACITY
ARE THROUGH THAT APPROACH OKAY
NOT A PRE SHEET AND I THINK JUST
THE REFERENCE OF SOME COMMENTS
THAT YOU'RE EGGMAN SAID NO PART
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS. YOU KNOW
THERE AND FOURTEEN THERE ARE A
LOT OF. WELL THAT'S THE OUT
THERE WHO. AREN'T REALLY HELPING
THEY'RE PROFITING AND- BUT
THAT'S BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
TO ME AND THE NEED FOR THIS AND
YET THERE'S NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO ACTUALLY CAN
PROVIDE THE ACTUAL HELP
INCREASED OPPORTUNITY FOR FRAUD
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS THAT
HAPPENED SO. YOUR INVESTMENTS
TO. INCREASE CAPACITY AGAIN
CERTAINLY THE API CAUCUSES
THIRTY YEAH I GOT THIS MONTH
SUPPORT OF CONTINUING AND
EXPANDING- ONE CALIFORNIA. AND
FINALLY AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE AFGHAN
REFUGEES I'D MAKE NOTE THAT- I
REPRESENTS TECHNICALITY WHICH
ACTUALLY IS. IS HAS THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF. OUR AFGHAN
REFUGEES WERE WELCOMING COUNTY
WE WANT TO HELP SUPPORT- HIS
ALLIES OF AMERICA WHO. WHO WHO
WHO NOW FIND THEMSELVES. NEEDING
A NEW HOME UNFORTUNATELY AND-
AND- GIVING THEM A WELCOME HERE.
AND IN CALIFORNIA SO. APPRECIATE
THAT AND THE LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING- IT'S IMPLEMENTATION IS-
THESE FAMILIES AND BY THE WAY I
DO SEE SOME OF THE- SCENES OF
MANY OF THEM IN MY CLINIC TO.
THE COUNTY SO- WILL BE SURELY
GIVES FOUR DANNY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON WITH OUR
THIRD AGENDA ITEM- WHICH WILL
INCLUDE AN OVERVIEW OF THAT
BUDGET FOR CHILDREN FAMILY
SERVICES DIRECTOR JOHNSON ARE
YOU GOING TO GET INTO THIS ONE
WELCOME BACK I WILL TRY TO ICK
US OFF TO HEAR HER CHAIR- AND
JUST JUST AS WE JUST HAVE NOT
LAST CONVERSATION- AT JUST
DEPARTMENTS THRILLED AND HONORED
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. CERTAINLY NO
DIFFERENT IN THIS SPACE AND THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
CAREGIVERS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY PANDEMIC IN MY
TRAUMA HOLISTICALLY IN THE CHILD
pEXCEPTIONS SO GLAD TO BE WITH
YOU TO TALK A BIT MORE. ABOUT
OUR RESOURCES HERE AS YOUR
AGENDA POINTS OUT- THIS HAS BEEN
A TREMENDOUS LOOK THAT'S NOT
ONLY WITH THE CONTINUED EFFORTS
AT THE STATE HAS LED ON THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM WHICH
WAS FOUNDED UPON THE COLLECTIVE
BELIEF AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED IN CALIFORNIA STRUGGLE
FOR SYSTEM THAT ALL CHILDREN
SERVED BY THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
NEED DESERVE AND HAVING THE-
ABILITY TO BE PART OF A LOVING
FAMILY. I AM NOT TO GROW UP IN A
CONGREGATE SETTING AND SO- WE
JUST ACTUALLY RELEASED A BRIEF
EARLIER TODAY WILL MAKE SURE
THIS COMMITTEE AND CONSULTANTS
HAVE THAT BRIEF I TO DEMONSTRATE
SOME OF THE OUTCOMES WE'VE HAD
TO DATE WITH THE C. C. R.
EFFORT. OVER ARCHING WE IN THAT
GOAL YOUTH PLACEMENT INTO
CONGREGATE CARE HAS DECREASED BY
MORE THAN 60% WELL PLACEMENT
INTO HOME BASED SETTINGS OF THE
ULTIMATE GOAL FOR FOSTER YOUTH
HAS INCREASED SO AGAIN GLAD TO
SHARE SUCCESSES I IN THAT EFFORT
AND JUST TREMENDOUS WORK AT BY
ALL OF OUR- I COUNTIES IN
VARIOUS PARTNERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN THE SUCCESSES
WE'VE ACHIEVED TO DATE. COULD
ALSO BE AS YOUR DATA POINTS OUT
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION SERVICES
ACTED SINCE THE FEDERAL LAW AND
CHANGE WHILE BECAUSE OF OUR
EARLIER IMPLEMENTATION AT THE
CONTINUAL REFORM WERE AHEAD OF
THE CURVE HI IN SEVERAL WAYS IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION AT THE
ACT THIS IS ALSO BEEN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT LIFT IN NEW OUR WORK
IN EFFORTS IN MANY MANY WAYS AND
SO. AT THAT S. C. C. YEAH
CONTINUED EMPLOYMENT. COUPLED
WITH THE NEW PHONE LAW. IT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ADDED OF
COURSE THE PANDA RISK. WHICH
AGAIN YOU'RE CHEN OUT MY THE-
THAT THE- AND LET'S. HAVE MADE
GAS BETTER TO SUPPORT AND
FAMILIES- IN THE STATE AS WELL
HAVE BEEN. I KNOW YOU'RE A POINT
OUT. OF QUESTIONS RELATED. TO
THE SPEED IN WHICH WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO ISSUE GUIDANCE. I HAD TO
GET THE DOLLARS OUT OF THE DOOR
AND SO I WANTED TO SAY A COUPLE
THINGS IN THAT SPACE. KNOWING
THAT THESE THREE THINGS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT MAJOR THINGS WERE
HAPPENING. I WE DID MAKE SOME
STAFFING. ADDITIONS ARE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. IN ADDITION IT
CONDITIONS KEEP THAT BE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR POSITION AND
SHORT SHORT. JUST A MOMENT. I WE
CREATED A NEW ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OF EQUITY INCLUSION SPECIFIC TO
CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES AND
ALSO AN ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR POSITION REALLY
RECOGNIZING AGAIN THE LEADERSHIP
AND SUPPORT IT WOULD TAKE. AFTER
MANY WE'VE ALSO BROUGHT ON
FORMER CHILD WELFARE DIRECTORS-
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
EXPERTISE CAN BE EMBEDDED IN OUR
PROCESS THESE BUT- AGAIN AS THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO HOLD IN
VALUE. AND PRIORITIZE THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AS A WAY IN
WHICH WE ARE SENDING THESE
POLICIES DESIGNING THESE
PROGRAMS. I AM CERTAIN THAT
TAKES A BIT OF TIME AND ALSO I
RECENTLY JUST ACTED DIRECT
TRIBAL CONSULTATION POLICY AND
SO WE HAVE TIMELINES- INCLUDED
IN THOSE AT PROCESS SEES IN
TERMS OF HOW WE MOVE FORWARD SO.
COMPLETELY COMMITTED TO ADD TO
CONTINUE TO GETTING EVERY SINGLE
RESOURCE DOLLAR. POLICY AND
FOLLOW THAT UP WITH REPORTS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE
ITS OPERATIONALIZED AT ONE END
OF THAT. I BASED ON THOSE
QUESTIONS. SO WITH THAT I WILL.
ALSO BE AVAILABLE THE Q. A
PORTION WILL TURN IT OVER TO
DEPUTY. IN WORKS TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND YOUR AGENDA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELL A SHORTAGE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE EGGMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MANAGES
FOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
DIVISION. JENNIFER TODAY'S
HEARING ON OUR MARKET DIRECTOR
JOHNSON PROVIDING EXCELLENT
COVERAGE YOU'LL AT THE CHILDREN
AND FAMILY SERVICES PROGRAM ALL
THE STRAIGHT TO THAT. QUESTION
POSED IN THE AGENDA. THE FIRST
QUESTION ASKED FOR AN OVERVIEW.
OF THE SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
AUGMENTATION FROM THE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. BUDGET THEY'LL BE
FIXED BUT I'LL BE DISCUSSING
BRIEFLY. FIRST IS THE PROPOSAL
FOR ONE MILLION TOTAL FINE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND. TO SUPPORT FAMILY FINDING
ENGAGEMENT- AND SUPPORT EFFORT.
THIS FUNDING WOULD ENABLE THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN TRAINING
ACADEMIES IN MEETING THE NEEDS
OF CHILDREN AFTER YEARS. AND I'M
A COMPANY MINOR IN ORDER TO
CONNECT THEM PERMANENT. FAMILY
HELLO REQUIRED YES FASTER
DOUBLES CONTRA FOR THE DEVELOP
THAT. OF A FAMILY FINDING AND
ENGAGE PRO. AND THAT KIND WOULD
PROVIDE THE TRAINING COACHING
TECHNICAL IF THE- AND OTHER. TO
COUNTY WELFARE AGENCIES TO HELP
BUILD SPECIALIZED CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE CULTURALLY SENSITIVE
TRAUMA INFORMED AND FAMILY
CENTERED FAMILY FINDING
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT ACTIVITY
. THE SECOND PROPOSAL IS FUNDING
TO PURSUE APPEALS FOR SSI
BENEFITS ARE TRANSITION EACH
YEAR. CURRENT STATUTE REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO SCREEN FOR
ELIGIBILITY FR APPETITE BENEFIT
FOR YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE WHEN
THEY'RE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
SIXTEEN AND A HALF SEVENTEEN AND
A HALF. INTEREST EXPENSE YOU'D
BETTER SCREEN THAT'S LIKELY
ELIGIBLE AND APPLYING FOR SSI.
THIS CALL. RIGHT THE GOAL IS TO
HAVE THE AND BEFORE U.
TRANSITION OUT OF. HOWEVER THIS
DOES NOT REQUIRE COUNTY TO
PURSUE APPEALED DENIED. CENTER
CURRENTLY OPTIONAL THE PROPOSAL
WOULD BE TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY TO PREPARE
AND FILE APPEAL FOR THAT THE
NIGHT AT THE PLANT LOCATION FOR
THOSE THAT ARE NEARING AN
APPLICATION. FOR THAT MORE ARE
YOU CAN MEET THE CRITICAL
SUPPORT WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT. THE THIRD. IT ALSO FOR THE
FOR ENTRANCE AGED. AND IT'S FOR
ONE TIME FUNDS CONTINUE TO
FOSTER AND- PILOT. THAT WOULD
DIMINISH NISHIDA ED WITH OF THE
ADDITIONAL PENALTY. DAHLE THAT
WE'RE THE AT THE BEGINNING OF
LAST YEAR. BOB WELFARE AGENCIES
I CONSISTENT X. BARRIERS AND
LOCATE STATE AND- HOUSING FOR
FORMER. YEAR THE HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT OR HIDE
CREATED FY I THOUGHT SURELY THE
TYPICALLY CAN PROVIDE UP TO
THIRTY SIX MONTHS I'VE RENTAL
SUPPORT FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS.
COUNTY HAVE REPORTED THAT THE
LACK OF FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
CASE MANAGEMENT AND SUPPORTIVE
OF THOSE THAT ARE REQUIRED AS
PART OF THE FY I PROGRAM HAS
HINDERED THEM IN TAKING FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE VOUCHERS. THE
PROPOSAL IS FOR ONE MILLION ONE
ONE MILLION AND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT YOU MORE YEARS
OF THE PILOT PROGRAM FOR CANDY
CORPORATE THE PADDING IN THE
PILOT WILL HAVE PENDING FOR THE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR THE
ENTIRE THIRTY SIX MONTHS AHEAD
PATRICK. ARE AVAILABLE. WHEN I
FIRST. IS FOR FOUR POINT. FOR
POINT SEVEN MILLION ONE FUND
THAT COULD BE. OVER THREE.
TAKING THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARENTS BEEN YOUR
HELPLINE THAT WAS INITIALLY
ESTABLISHED. DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN CAN DAMAGE. THE HELP
LINE HAS BEEN- A FOR PROVIDE THE
Y. TRIAGE AND PORT THE- TO HELP
CONNECT. CHILDREN IN CARE GIVER
IF VITAL SUPPORT PARMA. TO THE
FUNDS AT FINDING IN A ASKING. TO
HELP ONE THE PART. NOT IS A FOR
SIX POINT ONE TOTAL. ARE PRETTY
JOHN FUND. TO A LIMON THE BACK
EVERY FIRST OF. THAT HAPPENED.
ORDER HAVE HAD PROBATIONARY
APPROVAL FOR MORE THAN NINETY
DAYS. THE IMPACT OF KEVIN
NINETEEN MANY COUNTY HAD TO
REDIRECT SOME OF THEIR RETURNS
DOWN THE APPROVAL STAFF THE
OTHER REFINEMENTS WITHIN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. THEY ALSO
PAY STAFFING SHORTAGES AND MANY
FAMILIES WERE RELUCTANT OR
UNABLE TO ALLOW SPECIAL WORKERS
INTO THE HOME TO COMPLETE THE
REPAIR. PROCESS THE RESULT IS
THAT THERE BEEN DELAYS AND
BACKLOGS OF THE ART DAY I'M IN
THE TIME LINE WHICH HAD BEEN
DROPPED TRENDING. DOWNWARD
BEFORE THE CAN DOWN I. THE
FUNDING WOULD ALLOW US TO.
ADDRESS THAT PASSED AND BELIEVE
ON THE FUNDS ARE EXPENDED THAT
ATTACK LIES ISSUED BE A BRIEF. I
KNOW WHAT IS FOR A HUNDRED A ONE
TIME SUPPORT FOR FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES USED TO SPEND
IN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENT. TO DEVELOP A TRIBAL
CONSULTATION POLICY THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE. AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
REQUIRED THE CREATION OF INTER
AGENCY RESOLUTION TEAM FOR
COLLABORATIVELY K. JENNIFER FIVE
REVIEWS AND A LEMONADE VERY
VERY. FOR THE PLAY ENOUGH AFTER
YEAR THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED
SEVERE TRAUMA AND THE
CONSULTATION PROCESS POLICIES
ARE CRITICAL AND IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT ARE TRIED IN OUR
TRIBAL. YOUTH ARE FULLY
ACCOUNTED PARKS. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
HELPFUL. OTHERWISE THE SECOND
QUESTION ASKED FOR AN UPDATE ON
THE TIME LINE FOR THOSE ITEMS
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET
BUT HAVE NOT YET BEEN COLLOCATED
BURKE JOHNSON THE LEAVE IT TO
THAT IDENTIFIES THE TYPICALLY
MENTION THE FUNDING AROUND
PREVENTION SERVICES THE BLOCK
GRANT BUT THE PART THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF PART ONE A
FAMILY. AS WELL AS THE FUNDING
FOR THE COMPLEX CARE NEED BUT
YOU CAN FOSTER CARE RELATED TO
THIS COMPLEX CARE NEEDS
OUTSTANDING WAS ACTUALLY BROKEN
INTO THREE DIFFERENT ALLOCATION
THE FIRST EIGHTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION OF ONGOING FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO PARK COUNTY WITH
THE CHILD I THANK REQUEST IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE EMERGENT OR
EXTRAORDINARY NEED INDIVIDUAL
YOU. THINK I DON'T THINK
TRAINING INSTRUCTIONS FOR THOSE
PLANS HAVE BEEN RELEASED AND THE
FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE ON AN ON.
GOING AS NEEDED BASIS. WE'RE
PROCESSING REQUEST FROM COUNTY
AS THEY HYUNDAI. SHE DATE OVER
FOR HAVE BEEN ACCRUED. AND IT IS
TO THE FUNDS FOR THAT THIS NEED
ALSO FORTY POINT THREE NINE AND
BY. AVAILABLE TO BUILD A COMPACT
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL TO ADDRESS
THE COMPLEX CARE NEED YEAR AND
TO ENSURE THAT THE EACH COUNTY
HAS A FULL CONTINUUM SERVICE
PLACEMENT REPORTS NECESSARY. TO
SERVE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THANK IDENTITY. INSTRUCTIONS FOR
THESE CAPACITY BUILDING PLANS
WERE TESTED IN DECEMBER AND THE
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE FOR FIVE
YEARS. HURDLE TO USE THOSE FUNDS
BASIS ORNATE ART CAN BE SEVERELY
OR THEY COULD BE COMMITTED ONE
TIME FOR THE ENTIRE. YEAR PERIOD
. AT THE PRESS TIME COUNTY FOR
DOING A GAP ANALYSIS WHICH IS
REQUIRED AND THERE OFFER
DEVELOPING A COMPLEX CHARACTER
PASSED THE BUILDING PROPOSAL
WHICH WILL DETAIL HOW THEY'RE
PLANNING ON UTILIZING THAT TIME
TO ADDRESS THAT GAP IF
IDENTIFIED. YEAH ANY FOR FROM
THE COUNTY'S BUT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THEM TO PROVIDE THE
TECHNICAL. ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT NECESSARY IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE S. THAT HAVE
THEIR GAP ANALYSIS AND ALSO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR PROPOSALS.
LASTLY RELATED TO THE COMPLEX
CARE NEED THAT YEAR SIXTY ONE
POINT THREE MILLION THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET FOR
CREATION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CHILDREN CRISIS CONTINUE I'M
HIGHLIGHTS. WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF GETTING THE
ARCTIC AIR THE REQUEST FOR
APPLICATIONS FOR THE PILOT
FINALIZED IN PAKISTAN. AT THE
POINT EIGHTY ONE FIFTY THREE
PASSED WE WERE FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE GOT ALL OF THE
GUIDANCE AND IMPLEMENTING
INFECTION OR- COMPLYING WITH
FAMILY FIRST. I'M THAT PART FOR
FAMILY FIRST THAT RELATED TO
THAT NEW PROVISIONS- PRAYER YOU
CAN CONGREGATE CARE. IN PLACE AS
THERE WAS A FINANCIAL RISK
INVOLVED OF BEING OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL LAW
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT KIND AND
COMPLETE BY OCTOBER FIRST OF
LAST YEAR. SHORTLY AFTER OCTOBER
ONE. AFTER WE PASS THAT DOES WE
SHIFTED TO WORKING ON. WE ARE.
OF THE HIGHLY AND WE ARE NEARING
THE STAGE ABOUT WEEKS THAT THE
TABLE BECAUSE AT THE OF MARCH-
AND THEN RESPOND TO THE ARCADE
WILL BE. REQUIRED BY MID MAY AND
AGAIN THAT'S FIVE YEARS FROM
WHICH TO. EXPAND THEIR PILOT
DOLLARS. THE LAST ITEM WAS MEANT
IN AGENDA. THAT'S PENDING. IS
THE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
YEAR POINT FIVE MILLION. THREE
YEAR BLOCK GRANT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FAMILY
BURKE PREVENTION SERVICES ACT
PART ONE BAKER NINETEEN DOLLARS.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS RECENTLY
FINALIZED THE BLOCK GRANT
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY AND THE
GUIDANCE LETTER THAT WILL BE
PROVIDED TO THE COUNTY FOR THE
USE OF THE FINAL. ONE FIVE
GUIDANCE IS RELEASED IN THE
COMING WEEK OR TWO ZERO COUNTIES
WILL BE ABLE TO ACT. ON YOUR
DEFINITION OF A LETTER OF
INTENT. WHICH WILL INFORM THE
STATE OF THEIR EARLY INTENTION
POPPED INTO THE FAMILY FIRST
PREVENTION CORRECTIVE ACTION
PROGRAM. RECEIPT OF THAT LETTER
OF INTENT BY THE COUNTIES WILL
MABEL AND- MAYBE ELLIE ACT
PASSED THEIR ALLOCATION OF THE
STATE BLOCK GRANT FUNDS- AND
I'LL BE ABLE TO UTILIZE THOSE
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO START
BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY. TO CLEAN. FEDERAL
FUNDS UNDER FAMILY FIRST ONE
STOP PORTION IS IMPLEMENTED AS
WELL AS- TO BE ABLE TO VIEW-
DAHLE THAT ARE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. TOWARDS CLEANING OF THOSE
DOLLARS- AS WELL AS TRYING TO
GET OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT
YET INCLUDED IN THE CLEARING
HOUSE. BUT WE THINK WILL BE OR
SHOULD BE. INCLUDED IN THE
CLEARING HOUSE AND- I THINK THAT
IDENTIFIES THE VERY ABOUT. OF
THAT PROGRAM. RELATED TO THE
ITEM THEATER BECAUSE THEY
REQUIRE WHY THAT- TIMELINE
EXPAND EXPENDITURES BE EIGHT
GIVE THE DELAY AND I'M GETTING
THE DOLLAR PROPERTY- THE LEGAL
IT FOR THE COMP CARE. RELATED TO
THAT HI OF WELL THE FORTY THREE
THREE FOR THE PAST BUILDING HAVE
FIVE YOUR AUTHORITY BUT WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT IN THE
CONVENTION WILL BE. IN A BUT
REGARD THE FAMILY FIRST- BLOCK
GRANT WE WERE PREFER IT IF YOU
HAVE ANY. AND THE NUMBER
COMMITTEE FORMER. AN EXTENSION
TO THAT HIGH. THE THIRD QUESTION
ON THE AGENDA RELATES TO THE
KANSAS ASSESSMENT TOOL AND ASK
FOR AN UPDATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAN. AT THIS
POINT ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CWS CARE ACT LIFE
CANCEL HOWEVER NOT ALL CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES ARE USING THE
TOOL INTO THEIR CAMP ST AT. THE
REASON FOR THE FERRY AND SANK
COUNTY IN A LOCAL EIGHT
TREATMENT HAS BEEN REACHED FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TAKE THE LEAD
TO COMPLETE IN THE CAMP. AND
THERE'S COUNTY I CAN'T IMAGINE
IT AND PUT IT INTO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ELECTRONIC
RECORD AND THE CAMP THAT I
PROVIDED TO BE H. YEAH THE CODE
BECOME A DUPLICATION OF DATA
ENTRY FOR THE TOP WATER AGENCIES
ALSO BE DOCUMENTING THAT RAIL.
THANK HERACLIDES TOOL. AND OTHER
COUNTIES THE CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY HAS CONTRACTED WITH THE
PROVIDER TO COMPLETE THE- AND
THOSE PROVIDERS DO NOT
NECESSARILY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
KURDS LIVE CANCEL. OTHER COUNTY
FOR CHILD WELFARE AGENCY IS
COMPLETING THE CAMP BUT HAS NOT
YET IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU AT
THAT CURRENT LIFE YOUNG PEOPLE
WE ARE WORKING TO IMPROVE OUR
DATA COLLECTION AND REPORTING
THAT SOUNDS. AND IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP A CANCER PART WHICH WILL
ALLOW COUNTY PLACE IN AGENCIES
MONITOR CAN'T COMPLETION FOR
EVERY OPEN CASE WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SURE CAN'T BAT AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND DEVELOPING
METHODOLOGIES TO SUPPORT FUTURE. CAN'T EIGHT RECORDING. I BONTA
AFTER PROVIDING. ON IN. OF THE
FAMILY FIRST PER VERY BACK INTO
. BUT THE FACT THAT APART OF. TO
AND- ANYTIME. THAT COUNTY AND
OTHER. ARE HOW. FUN CALTRAIN
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW CAR. CARE
REQUIRE. I UNDERSTAND PART. IN
FACT ONE. AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FAMILY FIRST PART FOUR
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
AND THOSE NEW REQUIREMENTS APPLY
TO ALL OF OUR YOU WILL BE PLACED
USED TO ASK YOUR T. P. AND THEN
CLEARED AN ASSESSMENT BY A
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL NEW COURT
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND THE
COURTS TO APPROVE OF THAT
STATEMENT THE PROVISION OF AFTER
CARE SERVICES AND THE NURSING
HOTLINE IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
COUNTY THING IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS NEW PROVISION. YES THAT'S
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THE DISCOUNT BOTH
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN HOSTING
MONTHLY TECHNICAL AT THE RECALLS
THE FATEFUL VERY TO ADDRESS
QUESTIONS SUBMITTED IN ADVANCE
OR DURING THE CALL ITSELF AND WE
REPOST THE RESPONSES TO THOSE
QUESTIONS ON OUR WEBSITE THAT
THEY'RE AVAILABLE TO THEM AT
THAT POINT PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CALL FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE. JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
ALSO HOSTING MONTHLY TA FASHION. FOR THEIR COURT PARTNER. THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALL OUT.
ADDITIONAL TRAINING FOR THE
QUALIFY IN THE- AS WELL OF THE-
MORE WORKING ON IT IS ALL OF
GUIDE. AND I AND READ TO SOME OF
THE AND- WITH REPEAT. I'M FROM
THE COUNT REGARDING THAT COMPANY
YEAH ISSUE. YEAH SEVENTY EIGHT
YEAH ALSO HOST WORKING GROUP
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
HERE INDIVIDUAL. COURT
EMPLOYMENT CASE ABOUT FELLOW.
BACKGROUND CARE SERVICES. THE
QUESTION ON THE AGENDA IS ABOUT
THE ISSUE ON THE GRANTS TO THE
F. CARE KEEP THE PROVIDER CAN
CALIFORNIA THAT EXPERIENCE
BLOCKS DURING THAT HAVE BEEN
MAKING CONTACT AS WELL AS THE
PANDEMIC ASSISTANT FUND FOR A
RESTART ANILINE- ASKING
WEDNESDAY THAT DEPARTMENT EXTENT
EXPECTS THAT THE FUNDS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED. RESPECTFULLY S.
HERE KEEP YOU COVERED RELIEF
FUND. YES THAT WAS PROVIDED ARE
AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE FORTY TWO
MILLION FOR CONTRACT AND GRANT
HILL ARE AT THE PEAK THAT
EXPERIENCED ADDED EXPENSES LOST
REVENUE TO THE CABIN 19% THAT
MAC. AS OF TODAY ALL NINETY
THREE REIMBURSEMENT REQUESTS
THAT WERE RECEIVED AN
APPROPRIATE AFTER THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE AND
MORE WORKING WITH URGENCY TO
FINALIZE THE CONTRACT APPROVAL
PROCESS WHICH WE HOPE WILL
HAPPEN THIS WEEK AND THEN FIND
SHOULD BE DEFERRED TO THE YARD.
HE'S WITHIN A WEEK. AFTER THE
EIGHTEEN MILLION WAS INCLUDE IN
THE BY FOR. ASSISTANT ARE A
FAMILY I STAGE OF THE COMPLETING
THE- FOR THOSE TIMES I WANT THE
KIND TO COMPLETE THE ACT. TIME
OF BIRTH OF THE CARD. I THINK
CASH CARD TO THE READ CAME WILL
BE FOUR WEEKS THEMING. BY
DELAYED ON THE PHYSICAL CARD.
ARE ALSO HELPFUL FOR THAT THE
GUIDE DISCUSS THE- WILL BE. BY
THE END OF WEEK FOR THE COUNTY
IN THE FOR. A CARE GIVER TO ADD
A AND EVERY ELSE UP TO DATE WITH
AMERICA THIS TIME THAT WE CAN
BURGER KING. GETTING THAT
SUPPORT. THE LAST. I THIS PORCH
OF THE ASK HOW MANY CALLS THAT.
CAN YOU HELP UP WITH BATTLE
DURING THE BECAUSE NINETEEN THAT
MIKE HAS THREE SPEECH. THE CAN
THANK HELP TRYING YOU HELP LINE
HAS BEEN A VITAL YOU KNOW. FOR
OUR CHILDREN PARENTS AND YOU.
AND IT HAS SERVED. YOU CAN PARA
FROM ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
DURING THE PANDEMIC. ACCEPTABLE
BY. ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA AS
LONG AS THEY HAVE ACCESS TO A
TELEPHONE. OR THE INTERNET. AND
THREE DECEMBER AT TWO ONE THERE
WERE TWELVE THOUSAND. FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY KILL NINE
PEOPLE STATE IS CALLED THE HELP
LINE. IN ADDITION TO A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN TOTAL WEBSITE IS. THANKS
JULY OF LAST YEAR DECEMBER 2021%
26% INCREASE IN CALLS LIVE CHATS
AND TAX AND A 90% INCREASE FROM
ACT MANAGED BEGIN CALLER. IN
ADDITION THAT THAT TAXONOMICALLY
WILL RENT THE HELPLINE HAS BEEN
HOSTING PARENT SUPPORT GROUPS
AND THREE D. VIRTUAL PARENT THE
CORPORATE GREED IT CAN'T SUPPORT
GROUP BEHIND IT IN NINETY THREE
PARENTS HAVE RECEIVED FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
HOURS. AT THE PORT. AND EACH
GROUP HAS REPORTED BETWEEN TEN
AND FIFTEEN ATTENDEES AND
THERE'S ALSO A WEIGHTLESS. TO
ATTEND ANY OF THE SUPPORT GROUP.
I THINK THAT COVERS ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WORK HAS BEEN THE
AGENDA AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
ADJUSTED REYES PARK FINANCE
NOTICED ALL COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. HELLO YES THANK YEAR
ANGELES SHORT WITH THE L. A. L.
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS IN THE MIDST OF THE
PANDEMIC DSS HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTING MAJOR CHILD WELFARE
REFORMS AND YOU PROGRAMS
INCLUDING AND NEW FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FROM CONGREGATE
CARE PLACEMENTS EFFORTS TO BUILD
IN STATE PASSAGE YOU TAKE CARE
FOR YOUTH WITH COMPLEX NEEDS AND
ONGOING CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION- AND- WE HAD
KNOWLEDGE THAT BOTH RESPONDING
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
AS WELL AS CARRYING OUT THESE
MAJOR PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES HAS
INVOLVED- SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS-
GIVEN THE SIZEABLE EFFORTS AS
WELL AS THE- LARGE ONE TIME THE
FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS- FOR CHILD
WELFARE. INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET WE FIND
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEES FOCUSED
ON- OVERSIGHT AND REQUESTING
IMPLEMENTATION THE PROGRESS
UPDATES TODAY IS WARRANTED- WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO UNDERSTAND THE
STATUS OF A CURRENT YEAR
AUGMENTATIONS- TO HELP ENCOURAGE
THINKING AROUND WHAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES MAY BE NEEDED- FOR
VARIOUS TRAVEL FOR GRAMS
INCLUDING ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION- IN THE
CURRENT BUDET YEAR THAT WOULD
HELP THE DEPARTMENT- FULLY
ALLOCATE AND DISBURSE THE BUDGET
AND FUNDS. FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES- I
WILL NOTE THE WE PUBLISHED
INITIAL AND- OF THE GOVERNOR'S
CHILD WELFARE PROPOSALS- LAST
WEEK AND IN THAT INITIAL
ANALYSIS- WE RAISED- A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS WHICH HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN YOUR AGENDA AND
WHICH WERE ALREADY SPOKEN TO
YOU- BY TRACTOR JOHNSON AND
DEPUTY DIRECTOR SHORTS. SO I
WON'T REITERATE THOSE NOW- THE
JUST ONE ADDITIONAL POINT WE DID
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IS A RELATED
TO THE STATE'S PANDEMIC RESPONSE
WITHIN CHILD WELFARE- AS YOU CAN
SEE FROM THE FIGURE THAT'S
INCLUDED ON PAGES TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN. GENDA PROVIDINGA
SUMMARY OF STATE FUNDS FOR
PANDEMIC RESPONSE WITHIN CHILD
WELFARE. MOST OF THOSE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES EITHER HAVE
PARTY AND DID- OR ARE YOU TO. IN
THE TIME SINCE THE
ADMINISTRATION DEVELOPS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS- OUR
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED THE
OMICRON VARIANTS AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC SITUATION
HAS CONTINUED TO RECALLS- AS
SUCH WE SUGGEST THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER. ONE
WHETHER ANY CHILD WELFARE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE ACTIVITIES- IN
ADDITION TO THE HELP LINE SHOULD
BE- CONTINUED INTO THE BUDGET
YEAR GIVEN THE ONGOING PENDANT
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC
PARTICULARLY ON VULNERABLE
FAMILIES AND TO- HOW THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
PRIORITIZE ANY ON GOING-
SUPPORTS THAT ARE PROVIDED- I
DON'T STOP THERE FOR NOW THANK
YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
TWENTY DIRECTOR DRESS AS NICE TO
HAVE YOU RECOGNIZED AS TRYING TO
DO ALL OF US IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC ALL THESE MASSIVE
CHANGES END. I DON'T THINK WE
CAN UNDERSCORE ENOUGH WORKING
WITH OUR MOST VULNERABLE KIDS
WHO HAVE ALREADY BEEN
TRAUMATIZED BY VARIOUS FORCES IN
LIFE. NOT JUST- THEIR FAMILIES
DOING BUT OFTENTIMES BY THE
SITUATIONS THEY FIND THEMSELVES
IN- AND I'M SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION OF THE L. A. DO WE NEED
MORE. PANDEMIC RESPONSE NOW TO
DEFER TO FAMILY STILL NEED MORE
SUPPORT YOU HAD SOME PROBLEMS
GETTING ENOUGH OUT WHICH I
UNDERSTAND IS COMPLICATED. BUT
WILL BE MORE MORE MORE NEED TO
BE DONE TO SUPPORT. I MEAN THE
FRAGILE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IN
THE FRAGILE SYSTEM. THE SYSTEM
THAT FAMILIES FIND THEMSELVES
LIVING IN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AFTER THE QUESTIONS HERE AND
CERTAINLY ADD FIFTY DIRECTOR
SHORTS OUTLINED KIND OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS INCLUDING
IN TERMS OF CONTINUATION OF
BECAUSE ONE THING. THAT WE
DIDN'T ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT IT IS
CERTAINLY PART OF OUR PROCESS
STEP IS THE NUMBER OF
FLEXIBILITY STRAIGHT IN ADDITION
TO THE ACTUAL FUNDING AND
APPRECIATE THE L. R. ELLIE AS
OUTLINED OF THEIR INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'VE MADE- IN TERMS THAT
SUPPORT AGAIN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. SPEAKS TO THOSE THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE OTHER HAVE BEEN
ECHOED COUNTLESS THAT WE CAN'T
ACTUALLY COUNTS THE NUMBER. OF
ALL COUNTY LETTER LETTERS- IN
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS AND I THINK
THIS DEPARTMENTS PUT OUT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS IT'S
JUST BEEN TREMENDOUS I WANTED TO
JUST TAKE THAT BRIEF OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY LIFT UP IN A PRE SHAPE
MY STAFF INVOLVED IN. WORKING I
DON'T. BRING THE KENNELS ON BOTH
ENDS AS THEY STAGE ITS WORK ON
THESE THINGS. I RECOGNIZING THE
URGENCY IN NEED BUT I THINK ALSO
AS WE LOOK AT AND SHE DALY IS AT
POINT AROUND. KIND OF WE HAD
DIFFERENT VARIANTS YOU CAN
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES TO THIS
PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF THE SUPPORT
CENTER NEEDED WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
KIND OF HOLISTICALLY AT THE
FLEXIBILITIES. AND THAT WE'VE
BEEN PLACE HASSLING CONVERSATION
ENGAGEMENT WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COUNTIES
AROUND THOSE FLEXIBILITIES AND
ARE EXPLORING IN THINKING
THROUGH. WHAT ELSE WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF ANY
CONTINUATION OF THOSE OR
THINKING ABOUT WAYS THAT WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE FLEXIBLE.
I SHOULD THERE BE A NEED IN THE
FUTURE I THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT
AT DECISION POINTS MCKENNA
SCORED ENOUGH RIGHT THE IDEA
THAT. MAYBE WE WOULDN'T HAVE
SOCIAL WORKERS AT INTER I MEAN
I'M VISITS THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
BUT ALSO. HEALTH AND SAFETY
SAFETY IN TERMS OF THAT.
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE OF CHILDREN
ACT HUGE HUGE AT DECISION POINTS
IN JUST A SECOND GRATEFUL FOR
AND BOSTOCK PARTNERS ON THESE
FRONTS TO GO FORWARD SO. THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE KIND OF WHAT'S
OUTLINED NOW IN TERMS OF
INVESTMENTS IN THE SPACE AND I
THINK WE'LL CERTAINLY WANT TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU.
IN A LONGER TERM ON ON WHAT ELSE
WE'RE SEEING WHETHER NEEDS ARE
MERGING. I ANTICIPATE YOUR PANEL
- AND THE NEXT LOS BECAUSE OF
THE THINGS THAT THERE'S EMERGING
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTO FOR
CLERK. WHEN YOU SAY WE WOULD
NECESSARILY HAVE SOCIAL WORKERS.
YOUR TO SOMEBODY WHO- THE AGING
HAS DETERMINED IS A SOCIAL
WORKER NOT SOMEBODY WITH AN
ACTUAL DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK AS
SOCIAL WORKERS DO NOT YET HAVE
CATTLE. IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING COUNTY STAFF OKAY MISTER
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ON THE- BEING ABLE TO
DO SO LIKE LOOKING AT A
CONTINUING CARE AYE I THINK
ABOUT IT LIKE THE BY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUE OF CARE RIGHT WE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO PUT A LOT
MORE MONEY ON THE UP FRONT PART
WHICH IS. VITALLY IMPORTANT. BUT
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF KIDS WHO
ARE VERY AND I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
TALK MORE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
EQUITY- LATER ON IN THE-
COMMUNICABLE MONTHS I THINK- BUT
THESE KIDS WHO ARE WHO HAVE.
INTERACTION WITH WITH DJ AS OF
AT IN IN ADDITION TO CHILD
WELFARE ON THAT ARE OFTEN THE
HARDEST TO PLACE- THAT I THAT I
FEAR SOMETIMES GET LOST WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER ABOUT
PREVENTION INTERVENTION WHICH IS
IMPORTANT. BUT WE STILL HAVE
THESE VERY HIGH NEED KIDS THAT
CAN COUNTIES ARE TRYING TO
STRUGGLE TO FIND WHERE WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO FIND
A PLACE FOR THEM. HOWEVER WE
HELLO CONTINUING TO ADDRESS AT
THE END OF THE CONTINUE WHILE
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
SUPPORT ALONG THE WAY. PRESHEAF
FACT QUESTION AND AN ABSOLUTELY
TO FOCUS THE BUYERS AND- I THINK
CERTAINLY- NOT ONLY THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC MAKES VARIANTS RIGHT
THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE
AND AT CHILDREN AND USE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. UNIT THAT
NEEDS OF CHILDREN THAT SPEND.
ALSO SEEING SOME INCREASE THE
OBVIOUSLY IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SPACE HERE AND SO- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY. WITH
COUNTIES WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
THE ISSUE WITH COMPLEX NEEDS
WHETHER THEY WHAT. IF I CAN'T
HAVE CHALLENGES FINDING. OUT A
PLACE FOR EITHER A SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
ARE AT THEIR FIND A COMPLETE ON
THE HIGHER END OF THE CONTINUUM
OF SUPPORTS ACT. AT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT AND IF YOU
DIRECTOR SHORTS I JUST
REFERENCED IN TERMS THAT HAVING
DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY EARMARKED
FOR CHILD SPECIFIC. SOLUTIONS
MAYBE SOMETHING DOESN'T EXIST
BUT NEEDS TO BE RESOURCE OR
ADDITIONAL WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS
THAT NEED TO BE. INVESTED IN TO
ENSURE THAT. YOU CAN BE WITH A
RELATIVE OR AND OTHER.
PLACEMENTS OPTION. BUT ALSO A
KIND OF ACROSS THE CONTINUUM SO
THAT AT DEPUTY DIRECTOR SHORTS
MENTIONS. THE ACT GAPS ANALYSIS
TO LOOK IN THIS IS AGAIN WORK
WE'VE BEEN DOING OVER A NUMBER
OF YEARS WITH EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE TO SAY. IN MY
COMMUNITY WHAT ARE THE NEEDS. OF
INDIVIDUAL YOU'D BETTER BEING
PRESENTED AND DO I HAVE ENOUGH.
FOR THE VARIOUS- CAPACITY ACROSS
THAT CONTINUUM TO SUPPORT THEM.
AND SAID THOSE INVESTMENTS
AROUND LOOKING AT THAT FULL
CAPACITY IN IDENTIFYING THOSE
GAPS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE WORKING
ON NOW. I WE'VE RECENTLY ALSO
KIND OF COMPILED A FULL LIST OF.
AB WITH THE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR EXCUSE ME I
ALSO DID REFERENCE THE PILOT
THAT WAS OFTEN MENTIONED IN THE
PILOT THAT WILL BE ADDED. GOING
FORWARD WITH TO AS ANOTHER WAY
TO LOOK AT THE YOUTH WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS AND HOW WE'RE
SUPPORTING THEM. BUT I WAS JUST
GONNA MENTION THAT WE HAVE A
WHOLE COMPILATION OF NOT ONLY
THE INVESTMENTS WE'VE MADE HERE
OUT TOGETHER BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATOR. MINISTRATION IN
THE LEGISLATURE. BUT ALSO THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE RESOURCES
NOT ONLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT. IN
OUR STAFF BUT ALSO FROM.
PARTNERS CONSULTING AND THERE'S
GAMES THAT HINTING ON THE INTO
THE NEEDS OF THE YOUTH WHO ALSO
MANY TO BRING IN. OTHER
EXPERTISE IN. IN SUPPORT. US
WITH THE U. OF THAT OUR BEST
SUITED FOR EVANS. ABSOLUTELY YES
OKAY OF OUR- IN IN IN THAT WE
SPENT. MATCHING GAUGE IN WITH
COUNTIES. THIS ABOUT IN.
CONTINGENCY PLANNING NUMBER THE
STATE WHERE THE STATE AGENCY
THAT HAS RELATIONSHIPS WITH ALL
THE COUNTIES. WHAT HOW MANY
COUNTIES WOULD YOU SAY HAVE
ENOUGH FOSTER CARE HOMES I MEAN
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I HEAR
IN EVERY COUNTY I REPRESENT. WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOSTER CARE
HOMES IT'S REALLY HARD TO.
RECRUIT AND RETAIN HOMES. IT HOW
WE DOING WITHOUT ACROSS THE
STATE STATEWIDE. YEAH WE'VE
CERTAINLY SEEN INCREASES. OVER
TIME AGAIN AS I MENTIONED. IN
THE OPENING ON C. C. R. WE HAVE
ACTUALLY SEEN AN INCREASED
ANNUAL STATIONS OF RELATIVES AND
HOME BASED. CARE GIVERS. WE HAVE
IT AS SLIGHT DIP I THINK IN THE
PANDEMIC ANGIE. AT THE DIRECTORS
WERE TO BE ABLE TO GIVE ANY
SPECIFICS THERE I KNOW WE
RELEASED A QUARTERLY REPORT AT
JUST LATER ON ON THE SPECIFICS
WE DID SEE. A SLIGHT DECREASE IN
THE IN THE YEARS OF THE PANDEMIC
IN TERMS OF ABILITY TO RECRUIT
BUT CERTAINLY I'VE HAD SINCE
SEEN UPWARD TICK OVER TIME AND
THAT'S EXPECTS THE TREND WE
WOULD EXPECT AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT GOING
FORWARD BUT- I THINK YOU
DIRECTOR PORTS. ANYTHING
SPECIFIC YET OUT THERE. I THINK
WE HAVE SEEN A MIGHT TAKE. WITH
REGARD TO THE RESORT THEM BUT
NOW. RELATED READ DAMAGE BUT IT
A COUPLE OF. TO OUR- FRIEDMAN
SISTER JOHN. STATED WE HAVE.
REALLY ALSO HAD AN INTENSIVE
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE KIDS CAN
CONNECT BE CONNECTED BUT THEIR
OWN RELATIVES AND THEIR- FAMILY
MEMBERS TO STAY WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES AND WE CONTINUE TO.
BE INCREASE SAYS- AND THE DATE
AND THAT OPERATE I THINK WE HAD.
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER AND USE THAT HAVE THEIR
PREDOMINANT PLACEMENT WITH A
RELATIVE OR AN EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBER. I'M DELETING. THAT
CONTINUING. AND WE KEEP AT ALL
THE RATE OF. FROM FROM FAMILY
RELATIVE PLACEMENT. TO ACTUAL
ADOPTION. WE DO HAVE DATA ON THE
NUMBER OF YEARS THAT ARE GOING
TO ADOPTION AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY AND THEY ARE WITH A
RELATIVE OR OR HAD BEEN WITH A
NON RELATIVE I RESOURCE FAMILY
NOT THAT IHAVE YOU KNOW THE
TIMELINE TO ADOPTION I CAN WE
CAN GET THAT. FOR YOU I DON'T
HAVE IT- OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
THAT WE HAVE ALL OF THAT DATA.
OKAY AND THAT'S FINE TUNING AND
AS WELL AS GUARDIANSHIP OF WHILE
I'M. AT OPTIONS GUARDIANSHIP.
AND UNIT. HELPING AT. MOST
SEAMLESSLY CLEAR THE PATH I
JUST- AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
EXPERIENCED A FAMILY ADOPTION-
HAD THREE AND I AND I KNOW THEY
WERE SOCIAL WORKERS BECAUSE I
CHECKED THEIR THEIR CREDENTIALS
THREE SOCIAL WORKERS FROM
VARIOUS AGENCIES AROUND THE
STATE IN MY HOME AS WELL AS-
HAVING TO ACQUIRE TWO ATTORNEYS
AS WELL AS IT BEING SOMEWHAT
COSTLY SO I MEAN THAT WAS FOR ME
AND SO I JUST THINK ABOUT
FAMILIES OUT THERE WHO ARE
TRYING TO NAVIGATE AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX SYSTEM- AND JUST TRYING
TO KNOCK DOWN AS MANY BARRIERS
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN. TO MAKE SURE
KIDS ARE ARE OR WHERE THEY NEED
TO BE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR DR GRANT. THANK YOU AND-
YEAH AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION I THINK HER NAME
QUESTIONS- IT IT JUST WANT JUST-
ASK ABOUT THE- KANSAS-
IMPLEMENTATION. AND DAY I KNOW
THIS TO YOU TALKED A BIT ABOUT.
THIS ASSESSMENT TOOL I MEAN-
WHAT. SO I UNDERSTAND THEY ARE
NOT ALL THE COUNTIES ARE. THE
BOND SYSTEM AT CETERA I MEAN
THEY'RE TRYING EIGHT THERE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT REYES STAGES SO
FORTH SO. AND OF COURSE HAD
TOBIN YOU'VE BEEN MOVING A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS. SO I MEAN
IT IT IT SO WHEN DO YOU THINK-
SO I KIND OF COME TOGETHER AND
HELP AND REALIZE HOW CRITICAL
CANS IS TO- AS AN INFORMATION
SYSTEM. RT ASSESSMENT ANY
SUCCESS TOOL BY I MEAN TO HELP
DID. TO HELP YOU MORE
EFFECTIVELY DELIVER SERVICES FOR
- FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH. I CAN'T
DO I MEAN THEY'VE GOT HUNDRED
YET COME FROM OVER. THAT THEY
CAN'T ITSELF IS IN ORDER
IMPORTANT- IN MY- THE FRAMES AND
THE NEEDS AND DEVELOPING THE
COMPLAINANT PLAN PART IN THAT
HOUSTON IN THOSE CAMPS ARE
HAPPENING I THINK THAT QUESTION
AND PART OF HOW WE'RE CAPTURING
THE DATA IN TERMS OF. HOW MANY
YOU HAVE ACTUALLY HAD THE CAMPUS
RESTAURANT DOWN THERE ARE THERE
ARE GAPS IN THE DATA RECORDING
BECAUSE NOT ALL OF OUR- CHILD
WELFARE AGENCIES ARE USING THE
CAMP WHY FULL WHICH IS THE DATA
FOR REPORTING SO IT'S NOT THAT
WE THINK THANK YOUNG-
ASSESSMENTS AREN'T HAPPENING AND
YOU KNOW IS IMPACTED OR WENT
THROUGH FORMING. THAT THAT'S NOT
BY THE QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THE YOUNGER
THAN. WOULD REQUIRE REPLACEMENT
TO ENACT YOUR KEEP YOUR COULD BE
SUPPORTED IN A LAS RESTRICTIVE
PLACEMENT WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
ANTHONY CAMPUS ARE HAPPENING IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP. PLANS IN ORDER
TO CONNECT THE INTERPRETER BUT
DOES BUT WE DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE COMPLETE DATA THAT SHOWS
THAT I HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT IT I'M
CAMPUS THAT ARE OCCURRING
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WERE CAPTURED NINETY
THAT'S- RIGHT SO WHAT WHAT SORT
OF THE PATHWAY ME WHAT'S WHAT
WERE THE GOALS IN TERMS OF.
GETTING ALL YOU TO ASSESS AND
THEN I UNDERSTAND SOME YOU KNOW
SOME PEOPLE ARE USING PAPER DOES
THAT SELLS. SOME HATS ARE SAYING
THAT. THEY'RE NOT GETTING US.
THAT THAT- IN A SUMMER. I
UNDERSTAND. YOU WE'RE WE'RE
HAVING SOME CHALLENGE GETTING.
ALL THE DIFFERENT. TO YES- YEAH
GETTING FOR TO THIS TO AN OFFICE
YOU KNOW AND SO FORTH- SO WILL
SO WHAT DO YOU WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS THE BERRIER SOMEBODY THINK IS
THE TIMELINE TO TRY TO GET ALL
THAT YOU KNOW TO GET ALL THEIR-
ALL THE FOSTER YOUTH BUT NOW
THROUGH THAT THAT MEANS ALL THE
COUNTIES OR OTHER AGENCIES ON
BOARD. IN TERMS OF- THE OF THE-
IT TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT THAT
DATA. SO WE ARE TRYING TO
DEVELOP WORKING WITH A MAJOR IN
ORDER TO DEVELOP A CAMP REPORT
THAT WHILE OUTLINES MORE TO BE
ABLE TO DROP OR NOT H PLANET.
OPEN FOR TO HAVE THAT DATA
AVAILABLE WHAT ABOUT REPORTING
TOOL AS WELL AS CONTINUING TO
TRY TO COORDINATE WITH THE EIGHT
YEAH. I'M IN TERMS OF HAVING.
AND THAT SHARE DATA SYSTEM IN
TERMS OF THE TIMELINE I KNOW
THAT THESE THINGS ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT. RIGHT NOW I'M NOT.
I KNOW THAT I HAVE. IN FOR
INTERN THAT EXACTLY HOW MANY
MONTHS WERE PROJECTING OUT I CAN
GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT OKAY ALL
RIGHT BYE NEEDS AGAIN ADDED TO
THIS. I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A- I
CHECKED IN AND DEVELOPMENTAL
OVER QUITE A BIT OF TIME IS
WE'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW. YES
MORE SYSTEMATICALLY- HEALTH DO
THE ASSESSMENTS AND GET THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO BE SURE
WE GET THE RIGHT YOU KNOW THE
RIGHT SERVICES TO TICKETS SELL
IT I DO APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
AND I KNOW CERTAINLY THE
CHALLENGES. WITH GILDED AND SO
FORTH HAPPENING. ABOUT ALSO
INVENTED THE OUTSIDE GONNA FLY
WHAT WHAT'D. YOU KNOW IT IS THE
CURRENT BARRIERS WE ARE TO
TRYING TO GET TO THE PLACE
WHERE- WE KNOW THAT- WE'RE
GETTING YOU KNOW A CONSISTENT
VAST. ASSESSMENTS AS WELL AS OF
COURSE I THINK THAT COLLECTING
THAT DATA IS USEFUL. IN
AGGREGATE TO UNDERSTAND LIKE
WHAT WHAT TYPES OF. SUPPORT WE
NEED TO FIND AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO PLEASE GET
BACK. ON THAT ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW I THINK WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
. TWO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR- AND ARE. SO WE WILL HAVE WE WILL HAVE A
AND OUR PANEL- NEWS FROM MR-
BRAM BLAYLOCK SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE YOUTHFUL LAW
AND CENTER- AND THEN WE HAVE
CREW- CHRISTINE STONER MERTZ CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
YOUTH AND FAMILIES. AND KRISTIN
AND- I MISS UNDERWENT- THE CHILD
ABOVE YOURS OKAY SO LET'S GET
STARTED- MISTER BLAYLOCK. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH UNIVERSALLY
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW I WAS ASKED
SPECIFICALLY TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW WE CAN STABILIZE
YOU FAMILIES. AND I JUST WANNA
START WITH IS PUTTING OUT THERE
ISN'T HUGE IMPROVEMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT HOW WE DO THIS
SUCCESSFULLY SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN THE CONTINUING CARE
REFORM- THAT REPORT IT WAS JUST
ISSUED TODAY IT'S FANTASTIC
pHEARD THE DEPARTMENT TALK SOME
ABOUT IT ALREADY. JUST MAKE
GREAT STRIDES IN HELPING US
REDUCE RELIANCE ON INSTITUTIONS
WHERE CHILDREN USED TO THE WORSE
INCREASING THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN TO STAY WITH RELATIVES
AND RESOURCE FAMILIES WHICH IS
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHERE CHILDREN
DO BEST AND WHERE WE MOST WANT
OUR CHILDREN IF HE CANNOT BE AT
HOME WITH PARENTS- IT
CALIFORNIA'S REDUCE COUNTY CARE
BY SIXTY PERCENT. DURING THAT
INITIATIVE SO IT'S CURRENTLY
AROUND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OR SO
OF THE SIXTY THOUSAND USE THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN FOSTER CARE.
AND REALLY INCREASED USE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO STAY
WITH FAMILY AND COMMUNIY- AND I
THINK I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT CELEBRATE THAT SUCCESS
TO REALIZE WHAT'S WORKING- BUT
OF COURSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WE SHOULD
ALWAYS ALSO BE ASKING WHAT ELSE
CAN WE DO- SO A COUPLE OF THINGS
KEY THINGS THAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP SUPPORT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES SO THAT YOU CAN STAY AT
HOME. WE KNOW THEY BOTH WANT TO
BE AND SUCCEED I'M GOING. TO GO
THROUGH A FEW NUMBER ONE. OUR
WORK UPSTREAM. TO IMPROVE REAL.
HEALTH ONE OF THE MOST DAMAGE
ASK OF PLEASE IN SEARCH. THAT'S
WHEN SHE- ARE CORD. IN THE KEEP
GETTING MOVED FROM PLACE TO
PLACE. WHERE THE MOST DAMAGING
ASPECTS OF THAT IS THE DAMAGE
THIS YOUNG PEOPLE'S
RELATIONSHIPS. I STILL NEED TO
MOVE UPSTREAM TO STRENGTHEN
RELATIONSHIPS AND PREVENT THOSE
DESTRUCTION FROM HAPPENING. IN
THE FIRST PLACE I WANT REALLY
GOOD EXAMPLE BUT SURE TELL ME-
DEPLOYS EXPERIENCED RESOURCE
FAMILIES TO MENTOR COACH AND-SUPPORT FAMILIES. IN SENDS OUT
THESE PEER EDUCATORS WHEN A
RESOURCE FAMILY REPORTS
CHALLENGES- THIS PROGRAM'S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT PEER TO PEER
RELATIONSHIP AND REALLY STRENGTH
IN THAT NETWORK TO PREVENT
PLACEMENT DISRUPTIONS. US
INVESTING FURTHER IN PROGRAMS
LIKE THAT SO WE CAN WORK
UPSTREAM- WOULD BE VITAL. A
NUMBER TO. TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CURRENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
INITIATIVES IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SIDE WHICH INCLUDES VCR IN TEAM
CARE REFORM. ALSO INCLUDES
FAMILIES FIRST- NCSS IS. NEW
INVESTMENT SUPPORTS FOR YOUTH
WITH COMPLEX NEEDS. HANDS ON
MEDICAID SIDE- IN ITS FIRST YEAR
ON THE ELIGIBILITY FOR SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES REQUIRING
DIAGNOSIS. NEW BENEFITS COMING
THROUGH THE NCOS INCLUDING
ENHANCED CASE MANAGEMENT. TO ALL
OF THESE ARE FOCUSED ON
DELIVERING HIGH QUALITY SPORTS
WHERE YOU NEED THEM THE MOST IN
THE COMMUNITY AND AT HOME. HOW
DO WE LEVERAGE SEIZE
OPPORTUNITIES. I THINK PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO HEALTH SYSTEMS TO ADOPT NEW
FAMILY THERAPY AND YOU SEE AND
THEN IF IT'S- TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT
IN. FOR EXAMPLE PEDIATRIC
PRIMARY CARE AND OTHER PLACES.
WHERE AT RISK POPULATIONS USED
CAN AND WANT TO ACCEPT ACCESS
THEM. BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY MUCH
OF WHAT WE DO ENSURE SUCCESS IN
THESE INITIATIVES GOING FOR THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. WILL BE REALLY
RELIANCE ON WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO
DO AND HOW WE'RE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH NGOS IN THE STATE- AND ALSO
WITH WHAT WE DO WITH OUR WORK
FORCE. NOW WE SUPPORT AN
EXPANSION OF THE THERAPEUTIC.
WORK FORCE HERE INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. ALSO BY TO BE SICK.
NUMBER THREE ON MY- THE SILO. WE
HAVE THIS. FREE MORE WE SAW HAVE
A LOT OF TO DO OKAY. DECIDED
ASSIST. THAT DELIVERY OF A TO
RECALL INVOLVED USE THAT INCLUDE
FOSTER AND YOU KNOW JUSTICE. DO
AND GETTING TO OUR SHARED GOALS
FOR THESE USERS ARE GETTING
EVERY POSSIBLE OPPORTUNITY. TO
HELP STAY IN THE COMMUNITY WITH
THEIR FAMILIES IS GONNA RELY
HEAVILY ON THE DELIVERY SEAMLESS
AND INTEGRATED THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES ON EVERY LEVEL. THIS
INCLUDES OMMUNITY BASED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
WITH COMPLEX RELATED HEALTH
NEEDS. BUT ALSO TRAUMA RESPONSES
SERVICES THAT WORK UPSTREAM
SUPPORTING CHILDREN WHO'VE
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA. AND FRANKLY
THAT'S ALL OF US AT ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN IN THE SYSTEMS SO
THEY'RE GIVEN THE TOOLS TO
THRIVE. AND BUILD RESILIENCY IN
STATE ALMOST FAMILIES IN A
POSITIVE HEALTHY WAY. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE NEED CHILDREN
FAVOR OFTEN TELL WELFARE. AT THE
SAME TABLE SPEAKING THE SAME
LANGUAGE AND CREATING CLEAR
METHODOLOGIES AND PROCESSES AND
THE CHILDREN CAN EASILY ACCESS
THE SERVICES THEY NEED. SO THAT
ON THE GROUND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CCR AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT USING YOU TO STAY WITH
FAMILIES. THE PEOPLE WORKING
WITH THE ISSUE OF THE AND THE
USE AND THE FAMILIES CAN SAY I
KNOW EXACTLY THIS IS HOW I
NEEDED TO ACCESS THE SUPPORTS
THAT WE NEED. AND RIGHT NOW.
CONTAGION IS FAIRLY EVEN ACROSS
THE STATE SO THIS IS GONNA TAKE
SOME WORK EVEN JUST TRANSLATING
TERMS AND LANGUAGES BETWEEN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM IN THE
HOUSE SYSTEM CAN BE A DIFFICULT
STARTING POINT. WE ALSO TO GET
TO THE POINT WHERE THE SYSTEMS
ARE DOING SHARED BUDGET PLANNING
INSIGHT AND FUNDING. FOR EXAMPLE
BEING SURE THAT THE NON FEDERAL
MATCH FOR MEDICAID REIMBURSABLE
SERVICES- FOR VEHICLE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS FOR THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
LEVERAGE SO THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
OF THOSE. WE KNOW HOW TO
LEVERAGE THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
BE SURE THAT THEY'RE BUILDING
THE SYSTEM THAT OUR CHILDREN
NEED AND MAKING IT ACCESSIBLE
FOR THEM- TO REMOVE THOSE
BARRIERS FOR ACCESS- DISAPPOINTS
ALSO NEED TO INCLUDE SERVICES
THAT USE. EXCESSIVE OLDER YOUTH
ONE- SO TO MORE QUICKLY VITAL
POINTS YOUR NUMBER FOUR WE HAVE
TO DEAL SERVICES THAT USE ONE IN
NEED- THIS MAY INCLUDE
THERAPEUTIC BEHAVIORAL SERVICES
MULTI SYSTEMIC THERAPY LIKE
TYPES OF COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES WE KNOW. THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPONENTIALLY SUCCESSFUL YOUR
CALIFORNIA'S RECORD INVOLVED
USED BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES
SERVICES WE MAY NOT
TRADITIONALLY THINK OF AS MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORTS- BUT THEY CAN
HELP CONTRIBUTE TO OVERALL CHILD
WELL BEING WELL THEY PROMOTE-
PLACEMENT STABILITY- THINGS THAT
WE MAY THINK OF THIS EXTRA
CURRICULAR OR ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES LIKE DANCE LIKE
KARATE LIKE SPORTS TEAMS THE
STUFF WE KNOW THE KIDS WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN. AND CAN REALLY
BENEFIT FROM IT THAT PROMOTES
SOCIAL COHESION AND SOCIAL
CAPITAL ACCORDING TO ALL DO YOU
THINK SPECIALLY DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS- AND
ARE USED WHO ALSO NEED THEM THE
MOST- YOU FOSTER WHERE I WORK
RECENTLY DID A SURVEY OF-RESOURCE FAMILIES IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WHILE ALMOST 70% REPORTED THAT
WHEN THEY REQUESTED THEY RECEIVE
SOME LEVEL OF SUPPORT FOR
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS FOR THEIR
CHILDREN 60% SAID THEY DID NOT
RECEIVE SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXTRACURRICULAR ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES AND HALF SAID THEY
DID NOT RECEIVE SUPPORT FOR
CHILDREN TO MAINTAIN OR BUILD
SOCIAL AND PEER RELATIONSHIPS.
TO SAY HOW IMPORTANT PLACEMENT
STABILITY IS SO IMPORTANT OUR
RELATIONSHIPS RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING ACTIVITIES THAT SOCIAL
COHESION AND SOCIAL CAPITAL
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT WE NEED TO
INVEST IN THESE PROGRAMS TO MAKE
THEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO CHILDREN
WHO NEED THEM THE MOST. AND
LASTLY NUMBER FIVE AND I CANNOT
STRESS THIS ENOUGH WE HAVE TO
LISTEN TO USE AND BUILDING A
REAL OPPORTUNITY AND WAYS TO DO
THIS YOU KNOW WHAT THEY NEED AND
BASED ON THE INCREASING
TECHNOLOGY THERE'S REALLY NO
EXCUSE FOR US NOT TO BE CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM. DEGRADE
US TO TELL US HOW WE'RE DOING AS
SYSTEMS AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING IN THESE COMMUNITIES- I
CAN USE MY PHONE RIGHT NOW AND
FIND OUT WHAT PEOPLE THINK OF
ALL THE RESTAURANTS AND BARS IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO THE SAME THING FOR SERVICE
SUPPORTS FREE. BASED ON YOU ON
INPUT VALUE. A UTILITY. ALSO
REAL. AND HOW FIX THE SYSTEM. TO
CREATING PROGRAMS TO. AND HELPED
SHAPE WELFARE SYSTEM AND CAN
ADJUST SYSTEM. HIGHER MORSE LIVE
NEXT. IN SUPPORT THAT. SIMILAR
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT IN THE
EMS. IS A FANTASTIC PROGRAM IT'S
AN ALAMEDA COUNTY IS GROWING IN
DIFFERENT PLACES- THAT WOULD BE
VITAL IN KEY TO HELPING MAKE OUR
SYSTEMS MORE EQUITABLE AND FAIR.
AND HELP US TO GET TO OUR GOALS
OF KEEPING CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BUSH
AND I APOLOGIZE MISFORTUNE DID
YOU WANNA MAKE A TRIP
PRESENTATION. ABOUT THIS
CONNECTING YOUTH AND FAMILIES
AND SUPPORTING USE VALUE BASED
CARE OR DO YOU FEEL LIKE. PEOPLE
JUST JUMP RIGHT IN AND TALKING
ABOUT IT SO IT'S OKAY. I'M HAPPY
TO. FRAME I'M I'M REALLY PLEASED
THAT THIS WAS THE THEME OF THIS
PANEL AND I CONTINUED FOCUS. ON
FAMILY FINDING ENGAGEMENT
REQUIRED WHICH HAD BEEN AT THE
HEART. OF CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
COMPASSION- WE NOW AND I DIDN'T
MISTER BY OFFICE MANAGER AND
DIRECTOR JOHN FROM THE JUDGMENT
THE ISSUE THREE THAT HAD BEEN
CUT. TODAY I'M NOT REALLY HIGH.
THE SIX OF THE ARE YOU. IN MAY
SURE THE WE ARE CONNECT. SO WHEN
THEY CAN'T BE THEIR FILE.
PARENTS THAT WORK NOT THEM TO.
FAMILY HOW I'M. INDUSTRY FOR
HAVE BROUGHT ABOUT SIGNIFICANT.
CHANGES WITHIN OUR STATE INCLUDE
. THE PRODUCTS THEY ARE. OF
CHILD AND FAMILY. THE CREATION
OF THE EMERGING CARE PRO. THAT
ARE YOUNG PEOPLE BE AND- CONNECT
TO OUR- OR FAMILY YOU BEFORE IT
AN APPROVAL. AS A RESOURCE
FAMILY. ESTABLISHING EQUITY OUR
RELATIVES TO MAKE SURE THAT
RELATIVES CAN CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE PLACED IN
THEIR HOME AND THAT CHILDREN CAN
STAY WITH THOSE RELATIVES EVEN
IF THEY HAVE HIGHER LEVELS THAT
NEED. FUNDING AND SERVICES THAT
ARE REQUIRED. ESTABLISHING A
LEVEL OF CARE HOME BASED FAMILY
RATE SYSTEM LET'S TRY HI TO THE
CHILD LEVEL OF NEED FOR THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO MOVE FROM
PLACEMENT TO PLACEMENT. IN ORDER
TO GET THE FUNDING AND SERVICES
THEY NEED. EXPANSION OF OUR
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN MEET THE MORE
INTENSIVE NEED TO GET IN THAT
FAMILY FACED. UP FRONT THE ONLY
FINDING I'M AT THE PORT
PRACTICES AND OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE TODD MENTON
SUPPLEMENT THAT AND ADDS MORE AT
. BASED PRACTICE IN THE FIELD
YOU EVEN MORE FAMILY FINDING.
SUPPORT AND ENGAGEMENT. AND THEN
ALSO MAY SURE. THAT WHEN YOU
TALK BE AN AMNESTY HE THAT WE'VE
GOT- WE'VE GOT TREATMENT PLANS
IMPAIR. PLANT SOMEWHERE. THAT
PLANNING AFTER AND GETTING THEM
. BACK TO HOME BUT THEN THEY OWN
. WITH THAT AFTER CHARACTER BUT
THAT. HOW WE CAN BE THE DATA THE
PROFOUND IMPACT THAT THESE WERE
. HAD UNDER. AND MISTER BOYLE
JUST THAT WE'VE HAD DECLINE KIND
CARE PLACEMENTS BY MORE 50%
BELIEVE ALSO HAD A DRAMATIC
INCREASE- YOU IN THEIR FAMILY
AND BEING. TO THEIR RELATIVES
SEVEN LAST FIVE YEARS GOOD
BENEFITS THREE FOR IN. IN THE
THAT A- WITH RELATIVE. AND
NINETY PEOPLE CUNNINGHAM IN YOUR
PRINT. PLACEMENT WHAT THAT IS
WHAT THE RELIC OR DOWN MEMBER.
AND WE SEE THAT PLACEMENT. IF
POWER. TO THOSE AFTER. SEVENTY
FIVE FOR OF YOU. HAVE A FOR
PLACE WHATEVER. AND STILL IN
CHARACTER MONTHLY ARE WITH BE
RELIC THAT. SAID THAT. THAT
DEALING SIX. CHILDREN THEIR OWN
. MEMBERS IT X. IMPACT FOR
CHILDREN. THE BILL. TIME
EVERYTHING THE TO. THAT COMES
WITH BEING REMOVED MCCARRON CAN
ENTER THE CARE. A NUMBER OF
RESEARCH FAMILY HOMES ARE PRETTY
COURT HAS ALL BEEN IN. UNDER THE
- AND DID MENTION THERE A CLICK
FIGHT BECAUSE DURING THE CAN.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO BE- US MOVED
. THAT DELAY AT LEAST THE OF THE
- OUR OFFICE BEING TIMELINE FOR
PRE HOME. DOWN TO AVERAGE A
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN. I KNOW WAS
AT A HIGH TRYING AND FIFTY ONLY
AND- THE- PROGRESS. WHILE I
TALKED THE IN. IN OUR AND
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT YEAR THAT
WILL. TO THE FAMILY FINE. AN
ENGAGING ACTIVE AND ALL IT TO
CONTINUE THAT REALLY. I'M
THINKING IF I CAN'T WORK IN A
CRUISE. THE REMARKS OF THE
ANALYSTS- OTHER THE ADDITION
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE. THAT
WE DO AND TO SUPPORT KIDS THE
FAMILY BUT JUST WANTED TO KILL
PROVIDE THAT DOES INCOME AND- OF
. WERE WE'VE GOT- TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND MY APOLOGIES. L. A. O.
DID. EN ROUTE ON THIS WE MOVE TO
MISS THE NEW ENGLAND. BUT YES
THANK YOU- AGAIN ANGELA SHORT
WITH L. A. O. JUST WANNA READ
FOLK COMMENT- THE RESOURCE
FAMILY ARE. PROCESS AS WELL
DISCUSSED UNDER THE AYE DON'T
WANNA THE PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR BUDGET IS FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- TO
ADDRESS THE CURRENT BACKLOG
EVERY SOURCE FAMILY-
APPLICATIONS PENDING BEYOND DJS-
AS WE JUST HEARD FROM DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SHORTS. WHILE THAT
APPROVAL TIME IS TRENDING IN A
POSITIVE DIRECTION- TO DATE IT
IS STILL ABOVE NINETY DAYS- BUT
WE WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT-
THERE IS A STATUTORY CHANGE SET
TO TAKE EFFECT JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THAT WILL- SHORTEN
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF TIMES THAT
RELATIVES WHO ARE EMERGENCY CARE
GIVERS- CAN RECEIVE FOSTER CARE
MAINTENANCE. PAYMENTS PRIOR TO
COMPLETING THAT RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL. AND THAT IS THAT TO
DECREASE TO NINETY DAYS. AND
THAT'S A DECREASE FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR- STATUTE STATUTORY
TIME LINE WHICH IS A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS WITH A COUPLE OF
GOOD BECAUSE EXTEND. UP. TO
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS-
SO GIVE THE CURRENT. AS WELL
SOME AGAIN THE SUCH AND- THE-
THE PANDEMIC. WE WOULD JUST
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER- WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE
TO YOU AD THEN STATUTES TO
ALLOW FOR THE CONTINUATION OF A
GOOD CAUSE EXTENSION-
PARTICULARLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
TO ENSURE THAT EMERGENCY CARE
GIVERS DON'T LOSE ACCESS TO
FOSTER PAYMENTS IF THEY
EXPERIENCED. LATEST MARKET
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOTED HER. STUFF ON
OUR SIDE ARTICLE NOTED. ABOUT
THAT THAT ISSUE- MAJORITY IS
THEIR PLAN THE DO TO TIGHTEN UP
THAT TIME LIMIT DO YOU HAVE ONE. I THOUGHT MY COLLEAGUE IT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DEFERRED
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU READY TO.
THE PARTNER FINANCE YES JUST
RAISED FROM FINANCE I DO THINK I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
REQUIREMENTS AND THE FIRST
THING- THAT THE EMERGENCY
CAREGIVER ASSISTANCE PAYMENT
WON'T STOP- AND NINETY DAYS WHAT
WHAT THE WAY THAT THE STATUE TO
STAND UP RIGHT NOW. GOING INTO
THE BUDGET YEAR IS THAT THE
STATE WILL COVER THE NON FEDERAL
SHARE OF THAT ASSISTANCE PAYMENT
FOR THE FIRST NINETY DAYS AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT AN APPLICATION
IS APPROVED THE CARE GIVERS AND
APPROVED- STATE THAT THIS IS THE
SAME IT MAY CONTINUE COUNTIES ON
THE IN THE OPPOSITION THIRTY TWO
ACTUALLY WITH THE EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE AND PAYMENT. IS JUST
THE STATE WON'T COVER THE
NONSTRUCTURAL SURE OF THAT-
TYPICALLY WHAT WE DO- WILL
DEMONSTRATION IS DONE IN THIS
AREA IS HOW WE LOOK BACK AT
WHETHER OR NOT. THAT WE NEED TO
EXTEND BEYOND THE NINETY DAYS
TEMPORARILY BASED ON NEW AND
INCOMING DATA FROM THE FISCAL
YEAR- WHAT HAPPENS IS EACH YEAR
WE'VE BEEN SEEING THAT THE-
APPLICATION TIMELINE APRIL
TIMELINE IT'S BEEN DECLINING AS
WE GET CLOSER TO NINETY DAYS
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC OF COURSE.
THE GRANITE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
PANDEMIC TO CHANGE A FEW THINGS
SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IS
LOOKING AT THE NEED TO EXTENDED
A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS TO NEED TO
EXTEND FOR LONGER AND THEN WE
NEED TO THE POTENTIAL INCLUDE
SOME ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
COUNTIES. TO ADDRESS ANY SORT OF
BACKLOG ISSUES AND THEN GO FROM
THERE BECAUSE THE GOAL
EVENTUALLY WAS TO HAVE NINETY
DAYS TO HAVE THESE FAMILY
CAREGIVERS APPROVED AUTHORIZED
AND READY TO GO TO TAKE CARE OF
THE ISSUES WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME- THE OTHER THING THAT I
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE SUMERIANS
SETS. REFOREST THEIR RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS IS A
REAL LINES PROGRAMS SO IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY OF COUNTIES AND
IS EXPANDING WAS INCLUDED IN THE
TWO THOUSAND REALIGNMENT FOR
THAT'S SO THE AUGMENTATIONS IN
IT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING HAVE BEEN
THESE DIVERSE SPORTS TO HELP
ASSIST COUNTY SPENT WITH US.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. ON THE NECESSARY.
MMHM OKAY THE- THANK YOU BUT
LET'S GO TO A SAID MCDONNELL
EXEC DIRECTOR COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS THIS. THANK YOU DR ED
JERRY AND CAN APPRECIATE THE
OFFER TO IN TODAY'S. TODAY'S
PANEL. I WAS ALSO ASKED TO TALK
ABOUT IT OF THAT THAT CAN ARE
ACTIVELY IN RELATED YOU OVER
PRETEND AND AT APPROVAL OUT OF
BOB FOSTER FAMILIES AND IN
PARTICULAR I'LL BE ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT THE L.
A. O. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REPRESENTED
REPRESENTATIVE JUST MADE- AS
WELL SO IT'S TIMELY TO COME TO
THE NEXT- I DON'T THINK WE PLAY
ON THAT BUT WE CAN NEVER PLANNED
ON MATTER. SO- ONE OF THE-
THINGS THAT I WAS ASKED TO TALK
TO SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'VE DONE THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL. IN RECRUITING AND
RETAINING FOSTER FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY RELATIVES WHO AS
YOU'VE HEARD ARE JUST THAT
PREFERRED OPTION WHEN CHILDREN
COME INTO CARE. IF WE CAN FIND A
RELATIVE OR A NON RELATED
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER WE WILL-
DID MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO DO THAT
AND- WHERE THAT FAMILY. AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD WE'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL BOTH IN REDUCING
CONGREGATE CARE PLACEMENTS AS
WELL AS HAVING A SIGNIFICANT.
PERCENTAGE OF OUR PLACEMENTS
WITH THE FAMILY WHETHER THAT'S A
RELATIVE NON RELATED EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBER OR ANOTHER THEY
HAVE FOSTER FAMILY OF SOME KIND.
WE'VE BEEN OUT ABOUT 86% OF THE
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE AT ANY
GIVEN POINT IN TIME. SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF CC ARE PLACED WITH
A FAMILY OF SOME KIND DURING
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT- I WILL
MENTION AS WALTER DR EGGMAN
GIVEN YOUR- COMMENT EARLIER- AND
DR PANAS WELLS PASSION ABOUT
DATA. WE HAVE REALLY EXCELLENT
DATA IN OUR SYSTEM BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING NOW FOR NEARLY TWO
DECADES WITH UC BERKELEY- DOES
CENTER FOR SOCIAL SERVICES
RESEARCH. COLFAX NOT JUST THE
FEDERAL OUTCOME MEASURES THAT
WERE REQUIRED TO TRACK AND
REPORT ON BUT ON EITHER A
MONTHLY OR QUARTERLY BASIS
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE DATA ARE.
THEY TRACK ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION POINT IN TIME
PLACEMENTS- AGE RACE AND
ETHNICITY ACTUALLY PRETTY
AMAZING TO BE ABLE TO LOOK BACK
AND SEE. TWENTY YEARS WORTH OF
DATA AND HOW THINGS HAVE CHANGED
OVER TIME HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
SORTS OF LINKS OR INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT. BUT IT'S- IT'S BEEN
AN INCREDIBLE RESOURCE FOR
COUNTIES INDIVIDUALLY AND IT
CERTAINLY HAS FOR US IN
REPRESENTING COUNTIES AND COUNTY. HUMAN SERVICES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I THINK THAT SHE
SIERRA PUT INTO TO HAVE REALLY
HOW AND- US TO RECRUIT AND-
FAMILY CARE. OUR THE FOSTER
PARENT. RETENTION AND SO- ALSO
KNOWN AS THE FOR TIME. FOR USING
THAT AKRAM DURING MY COMMENTS AS
WELL AS WE WERE JUST DISCUSSING
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL OR
ARE IN. I'D LIKE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE FIRST
FIRST. WHEN WE FIRST STARTED CC
ARE BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN REALLY GOT THINGS
GOING YOU CAN RIP YOU FOR JUST
ONE SECOND IS A DISCREPANCY
MISTER BOYLE TO SAID WE SHOULD
USE THE SAME LANGUAGE ACROSS ALL
SYSTEMS AND SO NOW. EVERYWHERE
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT THE
FOR. THE FIRST. SEE FIRST BUT
WITH NO HELP.OKAY THAT'S
ACTUALLY KIND OF CATCHY IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT- APPRECIATE THAT
SO EVERYONE. BE PREPARED IF THE
BIRTH PANGS- ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAD TALKED ABOUT WHEN WE
STARTED WORKING ON EASIER AND
THAT WE NEEDED TO WORK RIGHT.
AND BETTER SUPPORT FAMILIES WAS
I THINK THIS IDEA THAT WE WERE
GONNA LIVE INVEST. IN FAMILY
RECRUITMENT WE GOT A CHUNK OF
MONEY TO DO THAT OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME THEN I SHALLOW DOWN AND
ACTUALLY GOTTEN ZEROED OUT. AND
THIS CURRENT YEAR IS THE SECOND
YEAR WERE IN THERE'S BEEN NO
FUNDING UNDER THIS IS THE FIRST
OF PROGRAM. AND THERE WAS THIS I
THINK- YOU KNOW ASSUMPTION AND I
THINK WE ALL MADE IT AS WE ARE
WORKING IN THE SPACE. THAT WE
WERE GOING TO GET ENOUGH FOSTER
FAMILIES AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
BE THERE WE'RE GONNA HAVE ENOUGH
WE DON'T REALLY NEED THEM
FUNDING WE'RE GOING TO START
SEEING SAVINGS FROM HAVING
CHILDREN. PLACED WITH THE
FAMILIES AND SO- EVERYTHING
WE'RE KIND EQUALIZE THE KIND OF
BALANCE OUT A WE WOULD. NEED
THAT DEDICATED FUNDING.
INTERESTINGLY NOT THAT HAVE AND
- I THINK WE'VE BEEN. IN A WAY
I'M BIT OF A VICTIM OUR OWN. AND
BEING A TO BETTER FIND. AND A
FINE FAMILY. AND PLACED ON WITH
AN- BECAUSE WHAT WE SEEN AS-
OFTEN THE FAMILY IS FOR THAT
CHILD OR FOR THOSE SIBLINGS
THAT'S MORE THAN ONE SHOULDER
AND- AND THEN WHEN THE FAMILY
REUNITE. WHICH IS OUR GOAL AND
SHE SAYS THEY DON'T AFRICA
BIOLOGICAL FAMILY. THAT FOSTER
PARENT WILL SAY YOU KNOW I DON'T
REALLY WANT TO CONTINUE BECAUSE
I WAS HERE FOR THAT KID. OR FOR
THOSE CHILDREN. OR AT LEAST THEY
WERE UNABLE IN FORCED LABOR
UNIFIED BUT WE WANT GUARDIANSHIP
OR ADOPTION. THEY DID THAT THEY
FINALIZE THAT AND THEN THEY'RE
GONE I MEAN WE DON'T HAVE THAT
AS BASED RESOURCE. AND SO WHAT I
THINK WE'VE COME TO REALIZE IS
THAT. THIS RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION MEANS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IN A SYSTEM WHERE
WE'RE DOING A GOOD JOB. OF
FINDING AND DOING RELATIVE BASED
PLACEMENTS AND THEN GETTING
CHILDREN IDEALLY EITHER BACK
WITH THEIR BIOLOGICAL FAMILIES
OR JUST SOME KIND OF PERMANENCE
WITH THOSE. WITH THOSE FAMILIES
WE'RE GONNA JUST HAVE TO KEEP
DOING THIS WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
BE ABLE TO FIND. SUPPORT RETAIN
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE BUT MORE
I THINK IT'S ABOUT DEVELOPING
REALLY JUST BETWEEN THE
CHILDREN. AND THE CARE GIVERS
THAT CAN ULTIMATELY RESULT IN A
ADOPTION
WE BE UNABLE TO RE UNIFY THAT
FAMILY. AND SO- WE'RE REQUESTING
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE STATE
FOR THE FIRST- PROGRAM. TO
RECRUIT RETAIN. TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE AND SUPPORT
THOSE PLACEMENTS SO THE CHILDREN
ARE ABLE TO REALLY THRIVE AND
REMAIN TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE. WITHOUT ONE. PLACEMENT
THAT ONE CARE GIVER WHILE WE'RE
WORKING TRYING TO REUNIFY. OUR
QUESTIONS FOR A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR. GENERAL FUND WE'RE
REQUESTING THAT THAT BE ON
ONGOING AMOUNT SINCE WE DON'T
THINK. THE NEED FOR THIS IS
REALLY. GONNA GO AWAY. AND THE
KINDS THEY THAT WE PROVIDED A
COUNTY THAT HAVE BEEN. IN XP.
CANS CAN SHOW SUPPORT SERVICE.
AIMED DIRECTLY AT RELATIVE
CHARACTER. PROVIDING REALLY.
SUPPORT THAT COULD BE GAS. IF
THEIR FREQUENT TRY TO.
APPOINTMENTS GIFT CARD TO HELP
PURCHASE ITEMS THAT YOU MAY NEED
. WE'VE DIRECTLY. BETTER PLAYS
PENN TODDLER. FURNITURE OR OTHER
THINGS OF THE HOME NEED. IN
ORDER FOR THE REAL. TO BE ABLE
BRING IN WATER MORE THAN ONE.
THAT THEY WERE NOT X. TO HAVE
LIVING IN THEIR HOME. WE'VE ALSO
FUND HOUSING REPAIRS AND CAR
REPAIRS BUT NEED A- IN ORDER FOR
THE FAMILY TO. EVEN BE ABLE TO
BE ABLE. UNDER OUR NAY OR BE
ABLE TO TRANSPORT THAT CHILD
TAKE THEM TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS OR TO VISITATION TO
COURT AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE'VE WHAT A VERY IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
USED TO PROVIDE RESPITE CARE.
FOR CAREGIVERS- I MEAN I MIGHT
COULD TURN DAY TODAY SO I'M A
I'M A CARE GIVER AND I KNOW THAT
YOU NEED. YOU NEED A BREAK
SOMETIMES AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE WORKING WITH A CHILD WHO
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE RELATED TO
YOUR HAVE AN EXISTING
RELATIONSHIP WITH. JUST TAKE A
BREAK SOMETIMES AND HAVE THE
SHALL BE SAFE AND CARED FOR I
FEEL. FINE TO HAVE A FAMILY
NIGHT OR AT YOU KNOW ONE NIGHT
OUT WITH SOME FRIENDS OR OTHERS
THAT THEY KNOW ALL. BUT NOT HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT BEING THERE FOR
THEM A 100% OF THE TIME JUST
LIKE ANYONE WOULD WANT TO HAVE A
NIGHT OUT AS I AS A PARENT OF A-
BIOLOGICAL CHILD WE TRY TO DO
THAT AS WELL FOR THE ROLEX.
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
ACTIVITIES AND BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT LIST YOU- BUT WERE
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITIES OF BEING ABLE TO.
CONTINUE TO FUND THESE EFFORTS
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. AND DIFFICULT ALWAYS
TO SORT OF FIND THE FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THESE ACTIVITIES
WITHOUT THAT ONGOING SUPPORT AND
ESPECIALLY AS WE- LIKE I SAID
REALLY RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE AN. ONGOING NEED WELL IT
WOULD BE GREAT IF WE CAN WORK
WITH AS- I. THE AND THE MINUTE.
TO MAKE THIS AN ONGOING OF
FUNDING COUNTY. THE OTHER THING
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF THEIR FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS. THIS WAS-
REALLY MAY CHAIN I AND HOW LIVE
OUR GROUP FOSTER AND THAT
INCLUDE NON RELATED PARENTS ARE
WHAT WE- THOUGHT ABOUT. AS
LICENSE FOSTER FAMILIES BUT ALSO
FOR RELATIVE CAREGIVERS. HE CAN
BE A SPONSORED LEGISLATION
BEFORE THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT WHICH- MR FREITAS
MENTIONED AT STARBUCKS IMPORTANT
POINT TO THINK ABOUT IN OUR- RFA
RESEARCH FAMILY APPROVAL CHANGE-
LIFESPAN. WE HAVE SPONSORED
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED THE
CONCEPT AND CREATED AS A PILOT
IT WAS NOT SOMETIME WITH
STATEWIDE- WAS NOT MANDATED FOR
EVERY COUNTY TO DO IT.
ADDITIONALLY THE REQUIREMENTS
BEING PLACED UNDER RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS WAS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLY DISCUSSED AT THAT
TIME BECAUSE FEDERAL LAW HAD UP
UNTIL THAT POINT ALLOWED US TO
TREAT- RELATIVE CARE GIVERS AND
LICENSE NON RELATED FOSTER
PARENTS. SOMEONE DIFFERENTLY
WHEN IT CAME TO WHETHER WE
RELICENSING. ARE PROVING. AB WE
SPONSORED WOULD JUST. THE PILOTS
TOOK AWHILE TO GET OFTEN THEY
WORK OFF THE GROUND AND THAT'S
YOU SEE OUR- FEES HAPPENED IN
TWENTY FOUR HE HOST TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT. AND SO THE
REASON THAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT
PROPOSITION THIRTY IN OUR
OPINION APPLIES TO THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL. AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY COUNTIES ARE NOT
FUNDED FOR THE RESEARCH FAMILY
APPROVAL WE HAVE EACH YEAR BUT
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND- THIS
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION. CAN'T
RECEIVE FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO DO
THESE ACTIVITIES- AND THIS YEAR
WE DID RECEIVE ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND- IT WAS
CALLED THE GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION FOR CWS WE DO- WE
DO KNOW THAT COUNTIES ARE USING
THESE FUNDS PRIMARILY THE OFFICE
THAT. THE OTHERWISE UNFUNDED
AREN'T THEY COST. THIS IS- I
DON'T ONGOING DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND
THE ADMINISTRATION I'LL JUST
SAY- BUT WE KNOW HOW MUCH THIS
IS COSTING OVER AND ABOVE. OUR
EXPENDITURES PRIOR TO GOING
STATEWIDE WITH RFA BECAUSE WE DO
A- PROCESS WITH THE STATE. TO
TRACK ALL OF OUR COSTS BEFORE
AND AFTER SEIZE THE ARTS
REQUIRED UNDER PROP THIRTY THAT
WE DO THAT. AND SO IT'S COSTING
COUNTIES A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OVER IN ABOUT THE
LICENSING AND APPROVAL
ACTIVITIES THAT WE HAD
UNDERTAKEN HIGHER NEXT PARTY
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT. PRIOR
TO THE MANDATE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND SO WE ARE
REQUESTING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WE'RE ASKING THAT
THAT BE AN ONGOING INVESTMENT
WE'RE ASKING THAT IT BE CALLED
RFA. SO THAT WE KNOW THAT
COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY FUNDED TO
DO THE WORK AS WE BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD BE. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
SHIFT. IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
IT IS A MUCH BETTER PROCESS
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR RELIGION.
THEY NOW GET TRAINING THEY GET-
ACCESS TO MORE SERVICE THAN THEY
PREVIOUSLY DID. WHEN WE WERE
JUST DOING A SORT OF MORE
CURSORY. AND NOT OF ON. SORT OF
LICENSE TIGHT OF AGREE LIKE WE
DO NOW. SO WE SUPPORT IT THERE'S
NO WAY TO BACK OUT OF THE REMEDY
UNDER PROP IS THIRTY IS TO JUST
NOT DO THE THING THAT MANDATED.
THERE'S REALLY NO WAY NOT TO DO
THIS OR DON'T HAVE FOSTER. SO WE
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
I HAD. WORK TOGETHER. TO GET
THIS FUNDED ON ON BY BASIS AND-
BRACKET THAT IT IS A STATEWIDE
MANDATE. HOW TWENTY RELY.
ALTHOUGH AHEAD AND- STOP MY
COMMENTS HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OF COURSE AND- LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE REST OF THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- LET'S MOVED ON ON WITH THE
CHRISTINE STONER MERTZ
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILDREN
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH HERE EGGMAN- TO THE-COMMITTEE- REALLY APPRECIATE
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. ON HOW CAN THE STATE-
BETTER CONNECTS YOUTH IN CARE TO
FAMILIES AND ALSO WHAT SORTS OF
FUNDING BY THE STATE BE
CONSIDERING- IN TERMS OF DOING
JUST THAT- I THINK IF I WANT TO
START BY SAYING- YOU KNOW
CULTURE EATS STRATEGY FOR
BREAKFAST. AND WE STILL AREN'T
QUITE THERE IN TERMS OF THE
CULTURE WE'RE BUILDING- I
THOUGHT THAT MISTER BLAYLOCK'S
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW CRITICAL IT
IS THAT SERVICES ARE COORDINATED
LOCALLY. AND. AT THE STATE LEVEL
OUR IS AT. ENGAGING FAMILIES AND
GETTING THEM THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS IT AND HAS MISSED-UNDERLING SAID. YOU KNOW THOSE
THOSE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE
GET DEFINED BY FAMILIES MAYBE
LOOK DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE
PARTICULARLY THINK OF AS YOU
KNOW THE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
OR SERVICES FOR THE THINGS THAT
WE CURRENTLY FUNDS SO. I THINK
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO ON THAT
AND WE HAVE TO START WITH THE
FAMILIES BEING AT THE TABLE. NOT
JUST INVITED TO THE DINNER- WE
HAVE TO CREATE THE ENVIRONMENT.
WHICH MEANS SOMETMES WE HAVE
EVENING MEETINGS WE DON'T DO
THEM WHEN THEY'RE MOST
CONVENIENT FOR YOU KNOW THE
STAFF THAT ARE WORKING- WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT HOW IT IS THAT WE
GET TO FAMILIES RATHER THAN
EXPECTING THEM TO COME TO US AND
WE'VE GOT TO BUILD SYSTEMS THAT
TRULY NOT JUST INVITE THEM IN
BUT MAKE THEM A CRITICAL
DECISION MAKER IN THE PROCESS.
THAT MEANS ENSURING THAT WERE
USING COMMUNITY TO FIND SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS THAT ENGAGE THOSE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THAT ARE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
RESPONSIVE SO THEY FEEL NOT JUST
INVITED BUT IN FACT WELCOMES TO
THE PROCESS. WE HAVE TO HAVE A
DATA DRIVEN APPROACH TO ENSURING
THAT EVERY CHILD AND YOUTH IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. IS BEING
ACTIVELY CONNECTED TO RELATIVES
AND NATURAL SUPPORTS. WE SHOULD
NOT AS A SYSTEM BE RAISING
CHILDREN WE SHOULD BE
INTERVENING AT POINTS WHERE
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING AND
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
CONNECT TO USED TO THEIR PEOPLE
- WE REALLY DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
MANY CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
HAVE ACCESS FAMILY FINDING AN
ENGAGEMENT SERVICES. TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS NOT. THIS
TRACKED ON A STATEWIDE BASIS
THAT I'M AWARE OF. WE DON'T
REALLY EVEN HAVE A CLEAR WORKING
DEFINITION OF WHAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO BE ON THE OUTRAGE
THAT'S CURRENTLY REQUIRED IN LAW
. WE ARE FOR THE DURING THE
FIRST THIRTY DAYS THERE HAS TO
BE THAT FAMILY FINDING. I THINK
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO REALLY
FIND AN ARRAY OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS TO CONNECT YOUTH IN
CARE SO FAMILIES WHICH INCLUDES
ACTUALLY FUNDING THE FAMILY
FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT SERVICES-
THE BASIC NEEDS FUNDING THAT
MISTER BLAYLOCK TALKED ABOUT.
THAT WOULD ALLOW FAMILIES TO
HAVE THEIR CHILDREN LIVE WITH
THEM. BY PROVIDING THINGS LIKE-
US ADICIONAL SUPPORTS OF A
FAMILY NEEDS A LARGER SPACE.
RESPITE CARE TO CARE GIVERS THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT THAT MAY
NOT. BE AVAILABLE AND SOME OF
OUR STRUCTURES- WRAPAROUND
SERVICES PROVIDED TO EVERY CHILD
AND FAMILY ENGAGED IN CHILD
WELFARE AGAIN DEFINED BY THE
FAMILY NOT BY. OUR OWN FISCAL
SYSTEMS. NOT BY WHAT'S MOST
CONVENIENT FOR US BUT HOW THE
FAMILY DEFINES WHAT THEY NEED-
WE REALLY NEED FUNDING FOR
SUPERVISED VISITATION FOR USE
AND CARE. THIS IS OFTEN DONE. BY
CASE WORKERS FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY IS WITHOUT REIMBURSEMENT
AND IF WE'RE REALLY PRIORITIZING
THESE CONNECTIONS WITH FAMILY WE
HAVE TO FUND ORGANIZATIONS TO
SUPPORT. MAKING AND MAINTAINING
THOSE CONNECTIONS- THE PROPOSAL
IN THE BUDGET THE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS A GREAT START BUT
IT'S JUST THAT IT'S A START. WE
DESPERATELY TO FOR. VARIOUS
FAMILY FINDING AN ENGAGEMENT
THERE ARE SOME OTHER PROPOSALS-
OF THAT WILL BE COMING BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE THAT DO JUST
THAT AND SO THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BE CRITICAL BUT-
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO FUND DOING
THE SERVICES. WHETHERIT'S- AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL OR AT THE
PROVIDER LEVEL. EVERYONE SHOULD
BE ENGAGED IN THAT SHOULD BE
DOING IT SHOULD BE MAKING IT A
PRIORITY AND WE HAVE TO FUND IT
- IN ADDITION TO FUNDING THESE
TYPES OF PROPOSALS. THE STATE
HAS TO BUILD IN SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
ENSURE THAT ALL YOU THINK HERE
ARE CONNECTED TO FAMILY THIS
INCLUDES. REQUIRING THAT CFTC'S
SORRY CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW THAT
ACRONYM MUST HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
PRESENT. THERE HAS TO BE
DOCUMENTATION THAT SOME OUTRAGE
HAS OCCURRED IN THE EVENT THAT A
FAMILY IS NOT AVAILABLE. AND WE
HAVE TO CREATE WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS- THAT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES NEED TO WORK ON THAT RE
ENGAGEMENT WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
SEPARATED. OR TO REMAIN TOGETHER
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. AND FINALLY I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT
MENTION TAT WE THAT AS WE
CELEBRATE THE REDUCTION OF YOUTH
IN RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENTS. WHICH
IS PHENOMENAL 60% IS I THINK
PROBABLY BETTER THAN ANY STATE
I'VE HEARD OF. WE ARE ALSO
FACING A CHILDREN'S BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS THAT CRISIS IS
IMPACTING FOSTER YOUTH. ALONG
WITH OTHER YOUTH- IF WE ARE
STILL GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
KEEPING CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH
THEIR FAMILY OR RETURNING THEM
TO THEIR FAMILIES. WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDING THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE SERVICES. THAT
HELP YOU STABILIZE AND
RECONNECTED THEM WITH FAMILY TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE PREPARED TO
PIECE TOGETHER FOR THE LONG
TERM. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH- HE ADDED THAT
CAN WORK IN A RESEARCH PROJECT
BACK IN THE LATE NINETIES IN
OREGON LOOKING AT THEIR CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM IN THE SAME
THINGS WE FOUND TO BE TRUE THEN
CONTINUE TO BE TRUE NOW IF YOU
GET FAMILIES WHAT THEY NEED TO
KIND OF FIND OUT HOW THEY-
DEFINE IT GOOD THINGS CAN
HAPPEN- SO I THINK TO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT I THINK EVERYONE.
REALLY BELIEVES YOU'RE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- IN IN AN
INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED-
ENVIRONMENT- AND ASTRONOMERS YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
SAID. THAT THE CULTURE STILL
NEEDS TO CHANGE YOUR TALK ABOUT
THE CULTURE OF. STATE AGENCY
COUNTY AGENCIES OR- ALL OF THE
ABOVE. FIVE I WOULD SAY PROBABLY
ALL OF US HAVE TO. WORK ON THAT.
YEAH MMHM. AND I AND I DON'T
THINK ANYBODY WOULD DISAGREE
WITH YOU IT'S VERY HARD TO TAKE
A BUREAUCRACY. AND WRAP IT
AROUND A LITTLE NIBBLE CHILD AND
FAMILY'S LIVES- AND STILL BE THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
BE. SO THEY ARE VERY DIFFICULT
THINGS I APPRECIATE ALL THE
INPUT YOU GAVE- AMASSED DR PAN
FEE HAS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU OUR
COMMENTS. HEALTH THANK YOU-
ACTUALLY I DID A QUESTION FOR.
SANDERLING DONALD- WITH CTW DA-
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE SUGGESTING A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR I GUESS THE
FIRST- AND- YOU. KNOW WE HAVEN'T
FUNDED FOR A COUPLE YEARS- SO
CAN YOU JUST HELP ME QUALIFY-
WILL. THE HUNDRED MILLION WOULD
RECRUIT HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
FOSTER FAMILIES- THAT- WE'RE NOT
DOING NOW BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
FUNDING FOR FIRST. I THINK IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION DOCTOR PAN I
CAN'T ANSWER AT THE MOMENT AT
ALL OKAY WHEN Y. I THINK IT'S
HARD TO SAY X. NUMBER OF
FAMILIES BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THE DIVERSE FUNDS
ISN'T JUST A MEDIA CAMPAIGN-
YEAH MORE PEOPLE TO SIGN UP
RIGHT YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN IT'S
ALSO. REPORTS FINDING THOSE
RELATIVES IN TEACHING THEM LIKE
US ON OR JUST SAYING THAT
ACTUALLY TAKES A LOT OF WORK
I'VE- TALKED WITH A NUMBER OF
THAT COUNTY STAFF WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE LOCALLY FOR DOING
THAT FAMILIES FINDING. AND
YOU'RE YOU'RE DOING A LOT OF
DATA MINING YOU'RE NOT JUST
LISTENING TO WHAT PEOPLE SAY IN
A COURT HEARING YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO MORE CONVERSATIONS AND FIND
OUT MORE THROUGH ANCESTRY AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT THEN YOU
FIND SOMEONE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
TO REACH OUT TO THEM MAKE
CONTACT WITH THEM IN A WAY THAT
THEY WANT TO TALK TO YOU THEY
MAY NOT EVEN KNOW IN SOME CASES
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TO FIND A
RELATIVE- THEY MAY NOT EVEN
KNOW. THAT THERE IS A CHILD AT
ALL IN THEIR FAMILY OR A
CERTAINLY THAT THE CHILD HAS
BEEN THE SUBJECT OF A REPORT OF
A DECENT LIKE THAT CAN BE REALLY
TRICKY AND SO THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE WITH THAT AND THEN TRYING
TO ENGAGE IN THAT PERSON'S LIFE.
EVEN IF WE DON'T END UP PLACING
THE CHILD WITH THEM WE WANNA TRY
TO HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM WE MAY FIND MORE THAN ONE
PERSON WHO'D BE A GOOD. PLACE
FOR THE CHILD TO LIVE THEY ONLY
LIVE IN ONE PLACE AND SO WE CAN
TRY TO HELP GROW THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS STUDENTS FUNDING-
NOT JUST FIND. BURKE ABSOLUTE OF
PROJECT PLACE SO THERE. A LOT
THAT GOES INTO IT SOMETIME AT
IT'S HARD TO. DO YOU YOU A
NUMBER BUT I WELL WELL IT WAS OF
THE WAY I MEAN I KNOW YOU. GIVE
UP. NUMBER AND I WILL. I OF
SERVICE YOU TALK ABOUT IS NOT
KNOW IT'S NOT NEARLY PUTTING OUT
ADS AND COUNTY COUNTY PEOPLE
SAID YES I WILL. DO THIS- BUT I
THINK WE WE'VE HAD PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCE. I'M JUST. I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT TO. IDENTIFY THE
METRICS IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW IF
WE ROLL OUT THE PROGRAM WHETHER
ONE TRACK OR NOT- AND YOU KNOW
FRANKLY PEOPLE DO WANT. A BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT AT.
LEAST WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
TARGETS AS TO- YOU KNOW HOW. A
WE'RE GOING TO A HUNDRED.
DOLLARS MANY YOU KNOW HOW HOW
MANY MORE KIDS- YOU KNOW FOSTER
YOUTH ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE. TO HAVE A FAMILY PLACEMENT
AND- BETTER OR SOMETHING SO. I
THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO. HAVE SOME
METRICS AS TO WHAT THE
INVESTMENT SHOULD RESULT IN. AND
WHETHER THERE'S INFORMATION FROM
. YOU KNOW WHAT WE FUNDED IN THE
PAST THAT MIGHT HELP INFORM THAT
ANY DIESELS NOT SIR LIKE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET EXACTLY YOU
KNOW WHAT THE THREE HUNDRED OR
SOMETHING X. NUMBER FAMILIES.
BUT I THINK IT I THINK THAT AT
LEAST SOME METRIC OF THE TERMS
OF. OF A FOSTER YOUTH WOULD NOW
HAVE YOU KNOW CERTAIN LEVEL
PLACEMENT THAT CURRENTLY AREN'T
OR SOMETHING TO THAT THAT THAT
WITHOUT. THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
WE DOCTOR BE AND I THINK THAT'S
A REALLY POINT AT- AN AREA THAT
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT MEMORY
MENTIONED THERE'S ALL THESE DATA
AVAILABLE. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN AS MUCH
MOVEMENT OF THE NEEDLE AS WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. IS JUST THE
STRAIGHT UP. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE PERCENTAGE OF CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE ARE WITH A RELIGION.
RIGHT IF YOU BACK OUT THE
GUARDIAN TOOK PLACE OF THE
ADOPTIVE PLACEMENTS YEAH ALL OF
THAT STUFF AND THE OTHER FAMILY
TYPE OF SETTINGS. SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN THIRTY FIVE AND 42% IT'S
GONE UP AND DOWN A LITTLE BIT
OVER THE LAST. YOU KNOW EIGHT TO
NINE YEARS NOW IT'S NOT REALLY
GROWN AS MUCH AS I THINK WE
HOPE. AND SO THAT MIGHT BE AN
AREA TO TAKE A LOOK AT AND SEE.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO MOVE THAT
NEEDLE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SAY
AT THIS MANY MORE CHILDREN. YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN SO I'D BE HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND WITH
THAT STAFF OF COURSE- DR POLK
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER. I'M WE
WORK WELL WITH AND SEE TO IT YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE KIND OF THINK
ABOUT THAT. AS WE LOOK AT TRYING
TO MAKE THAT KIND OF THE LAST.
OKAY NO THAT'S RIGHT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND ALSO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT- THAT JUST BY THE
RIGHT NUMBER RIGHT IT'S NOT
GONNA BE A HUNDRED PERCENT.
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF WEATHER
CIRCUMSTANCE AND OTHER REASONS-
IT'S- CERTAINLY SHOULD BE MUCH
HIGHER THAN ZERO. AND SO YOU
KNOW I THINK IDENTIFYING THE
TARGET RANGE SHALL AND KNOWING
WHAT. DATA LEAD TO DATA FIND AT
TARGET. AND IF THE CASE SOME OF
THE SOME OF THOSE NUMBER THE
BASELINE NUMBERS CHANGE THAT
WOULD CHANGE A TARGET BUT I
THINK I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
JUST SO THAT WE- HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS SO WE KNOW
WHETHER MAKING. APPROPRIATE
PROGRESS I THANK YOU. BUT MISTER
MOORE TO PUT YOU SAY THE- CAL.
IS DOING BEST A IT SIXTIES. PER
I THINK I WAS REFERENCING THE
REDUCTION IN IN CHILDREN
RESIDENTIAL. CARE TEXAS OKAY AND
IT'S AND IT'S 38% THAT WE HAVE
WITH WITH FAMILY PLACEMENTS THAT
RIGHT. TENDERING MCCONNELL ABOUT
YEAH I THINK THAT'S ABOUT RATE
CHANGES A TAD BIT FROM YOUR YOUR
BECAUSE ALL THE NUMBERS SHIFT.
JUST PUT SOME CONTEXT AROUND
THAT 67% DROP- WHEN C. C. R.
STARTED WE HAD 6% OF OUR
CHILDREN PLACE TO CONGREGATE
FACILITIES. AND THEN MOST
RECENTLY IN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT WAS THREE POINT 3%
SO THAT'S HOW YOU SEE THAT VERY
LARGE YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT DROP-
AND IT'S INTERESTING CALIFORNIA
IS ACTUALLY QUITE LOW IN
CONGREGATE CARE PLACEMENTS
PERCENTAGES. COMPARED TO A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES WHEN WE
WERE DOING SOME WORK NATIONALLY
ON THE FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT THAT WAS SPOKEN
ABOUT EARLIER IN THAT- IN THE
HEARING I WAS SURPRISED TO SEE
THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STATES THAT HA. DOUBLE DIGIT
PERCENTAGES OF CHILDREN
CONGREGATE THEY SPENT. SO EVEN
THOUGH THERE IS ROOM ABSOLUTELY
AND CERTAINLY THINKING ABOUT
SHORTENING THE LENGTH OF STAY
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
SERVICES ARE BROUGHT TO BEAR
MORE QUICKLY AND MORE ROBUSTLY-
WE DON'T HAVE AS FAR TO GO I'D
SAY AS WE'VE SEEN IN SOME OTHER
STATES. BUT STILL ALWAYS
IMPROVEMENTS TO BE MADE A PART.
THANK YOU ALL THINK YOUR MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE PRESENTATION AND THANK YOU
FOR THE DEDICATION. EVERY SINGLE
DAY TO HELP OUR MOST VULNERABLE
KIDS. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE CHILD CARE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU CARE EGGMAN
ADD DOCTOR PAN CAN JOHNSON AT
THE SOCIAL SERVICES AND HAD NOT
UNLIKE THE CONVERSATION WE JUST
HAD TO- THIS IS BANNED AT AREA
OF TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT IN
RESOURCE A LOT HAPPENING AT
ONCE- WITH OF COURSE AS THE
GREAT. VALUE AS YOUR AGENDA
POINTS OUT OF THE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES ABOUT A QUALITY CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM HAVE
THAT ONLY A SUPPORTING PARENTS
AND CARE GIVERS TO WORKING ON
LEARN BUT ALSO THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT REACHING ENVIRONMENT
SO I WE ARE THRILLED TO ADD TO
HAVE OFFICIALLY TRANSITIONED-
MUCH OF THE CHILD CARE SUBSIDY
SYSTEM. ADD TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES WE ALSO HAVE HAD
UNPRECEDENTED IN STORE
INVESTMENT- IN THE SPACE THAT
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL AS YOUR
AGENDA OUTLINES ESPECIALLY IN
TERMS THAT THAT PANDEMIC
RESPONSE AND- AND HOW WE COULD
TOGETHER WORK TO SUPPORT THE
WORK FORCE WHO AGAIN STAYED
OPEN- THE WHOLE TIME IN
SUPPORTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. WE ALSO HAVE THE VERY
FIRST MAIN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED REACHED ON
JUNE TWENTY FIFTH OF LAST YEAR
REPRESENTING A STORK INVESTMENT
OF NEARLY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AGAIN WITH ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
THAT WE'VE MADE AND THE SPACE-
IT DOES NOT AGAIN COME WITHOUT
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO. ENSURE WE ARE BOTH AT
GREAT RETAIN AT THE QUALITY
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT AB
MEMBERS OF OUR WORK FORCE IN
PROGRAMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA BUT
ALSO RECRUIT NEW- AND ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL CARING FOR
OUR OUR CHILDREN SO I WILL TURN
IT OVER. TO DR DEBATE HI HI MAY
MYLAN WHO IS OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF OUR CHILD CARE INTO THE
GOVERNMENT DIVISION WHO WILL
SPEAK TO THE QUESTIONS. IN YOUR
AGENDA THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK
YOU THE RECORDS- FOR INTO. AND
COULD ACT CHAIR AND MEMBER IT IS
PRIVILEGE TO. A UPDATE AND IT
THE QUESTION. IN TERMS OF- IN
REGARDS TO THE TRANSFER I HAVE
THE AT AT THESE PROGRAMS AS PART
OF THE TRANSITION A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE POINT SEVEN
POSITIONS TRANSPORTATION CDSS
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO FILL IN INSISTING
BACONSKY WE CONTINUE TO ASSESS
WORKLOADS ASSET TRANSITION HAS
COME TO PORTRAY. ATION AND
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION IS
OCCURRING AS PART OF THE
ONBOARDING PROCESS FOR OUR
TRANSFERRED EMPLOYEES THE DSS
HAS PROVIDED CUSTOMIZED
ORIENTATION TRAINING AND
EMPLOYEE ENGAGEMENT SESSIONS TO
ENSURE A SMOOTH TRANSITION OF
OUR NEW TEAM MEMBERS. IN
ADDITION THE TRANSITION STAFF
HAPPENED SURVEY THREE TIMES
ABOUT THE TRANSITION FIRST AND
DECEMBER AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BEFORE THEY TRANSFERRED TO CVS
ASK BEN IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
TRANSITION ON JULY THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THEN
FINALLY BETWEEN NOVEMBER EIGHTH
TO NOVEMBER NINETEENTH THANKS
PUT IT IN THE SURVEY THE STAFF.
IN THE CHAO PRINCIPALMENTE
ADDITION FAMILY EMPOWERMENT THE
VISION AND THE ADMIN DEFICIENT
THE RESULTS FROM THE MOST RECENT
SURVEY SHOWED THAT 89% AT THE
STAFF AGREED WITH THE STATEMENT
I HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
MY PROBLEM RESPONSIBILITIES. AT
CBS. EIGHTY ONE PER OF THE TWO
STAFF THREE WITH THE STATEMENT
THERE IS A CULTURE OF TEAMWORK
AND COLLABORATION WITHIN MY
FRENCH. IN ADDITION STAFF
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR
INFORMATION TRAINING AND
RESOURCES ON ADMINISTRATIVE
ISSUES SUCH AS CONTRACTING WITH
HR ORDERING OFFICE SUPPLIES.
UTILIZING SHAREPOINT CONSUMED
AND MAKING DOCUMENTS ACCESSIBLE
TO ADDRESS THE STAFF IDENTIFIED
NEEDS CDSS PROVIDED AN OVERALL
TRAINING ON MANY OF THESE ITEMS
THAT INCLUDED ALSO WALKING
THROUGH THE TEAM MEMBERS OF THE
CDSS L. M. PASSED THE SYSTEM
WHICH IS THE TRAINING PORTAL
WHICH CONTAINS MANY UP BETWEEN
SITES ON A FIVE. CDSS WANTS TO
DISTRIBUTE A FINAL SURVEY AT THE
END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO SUPPORT OUR
TEAM MEMBERS. ALSO IN TERMS OF
VACANCIES FOR THE NEW DIVISION
I'M OF THE ONE EIGHTY FIVE POINT
SEVEN POSITIONS AT TRANSFERRED
TO CBS S. SIXTY NINE POSITIONS
TRANSPORTATION WITH A NEW HEALTH
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT DIVISION.
CURRENTLY ELEVEN AT THE SIXTY
NINE OUR PATIENTS AND WE'RE
STILL RECRUITING- THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO RECEIVED EIGHTEEN POSITIONS
AS PART OF THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BY CHANCE I CURRENTLY THREE
OF THOSE POSITIONS ARE VACANT
AND WE CONTINUE TO HIRE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. NOW FOR THE
NEXT QUESTION IN REGARDS TO- AN
UPDATE ON RATES AND INCREASE SET
TO BEGIN ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THE FOLLOWING
INVESTMENT STEM FROM AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE STATE AND
C. C. P. YOU. THINK COMPASS A
CHECKER PENS THAT MAKE THE LEAP
PACKAGE AS WELL AS THE CCPO
FIRST BARGAINING AGREEMENT WITH
THE STATE WHICH WAS RATIFIED BY
ITS MEMBERS AND JULY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND CODIFIED
BY THE JUDGE LEGISLATORS ON. AND
THE GOVERNOR AND. AB ONE THIRTY
FIVE. IT UNLIKE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS- ARE WHAT ARE
REIMBURSED UP TO THE SEVENTY
FIVE FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE
TWENTY. TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REGIONAL MARKET RATE
SURVEY REFERENCE AT THE FARMAR
AND EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- SO PRIOR TO
THIS- PRIOR TO THIS THE PRIOR
REIMBURSEMENT WAS THE SEVENTH.
SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ARMAR SIR. BISON
EXCEPT PROVIDERS ARE NOW
REIMBURSED AFTER 70% OF THE
LICENSED FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME
PROVIDER RATE CEILINGINCLUDING
HOURLY DAILY WEEKLY AND MONTHLY
FOR BOTH FULL TIME AND PART TIME
REIMBURSEMENT CATEGORIES
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND DIRECT
SERVICE CONTRACTORS ARE
REIMBURSED AT THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE ARMAR CEILING UNLESS
THE CHANGE WOULD RESULT IN A
LOWER RATE REITZEL HOLDING TO
THE HOLD HARMLESS IN THIS CASE
THE CONTRACTORS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATES S. R. R.
PLUS THE COST OF LIVING INCREASE
GRANTED BY THE LEGISLATOR.
ANNUALLY PURSUANT TO HELP. FOUR
TWO TWO THREE EIGHT POINT ONE
FIVE. SO WHAT'S AND CONTRACT
SPACE THE FOR OH FIVE THAT'S OF
LIVING AFFECT FIFTY Y. FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FINALLY
CONTRACTORS RECEIVED A NOTICE AT
THE CONFRONTATIONS OF
INFORMATION FOR OUR CHILD WELL
IT'S AN THAT WE RECEIVED IN
DECEMBER IN PREPARATION TO THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF JANUARY AND-
NOW IN REGARDS TO MY NEXT UPDATE
WHICH IS THE ADDITIONAL SPOT
RELEASED IN THE FIELD OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE. TWENTY TWO THE
LEGISLATOR AND THE GOVERNOR MADE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO TOUGHEN DEVELOPMENTS
INCLUDING SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE POINT THREE MILLION. FOR ADDITIONAL CHECKERSPOT.
OVER FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY. I HAVE THAT IT BREAKS
DOWN TO THE FOLLOWING BY FIFTY
POINT ONE MILLION AND FUNDS
ADDITIONAL TO ALTERNATE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS REFERENCE ASCOT. CAP
SLOTS AND SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN FINES ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIA MIGRANT ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS THE MAPS LOTS.
BUDGET ACT AMENDMENT WAS
RELEASED ON HEALTH CARE BULLETIN
TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN ON NOVEMBER
TWENTY FOURTH I'M TO PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION TO CONTRACTORS
AND BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS. THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION TO FIND
ADDITIONAL EMERGENCY TUCKER
BRIDGE PROGRAMS FOR FOSTER CHILD
CARE CHILDREN SPOTS COUNTY
ALLOCATIONS WAS RECEIVED ON THE
S. C. F. L. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO DASH FORTY FIVE ON NOVEMBER
THIRTIETH. AND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION TO FIND
GENERAL HEALTH CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM SPOT SEE CTR
SOME TERMS OF THE CCTV HARD
BODIES. BROUGH EIGHT RFA-
PROCESS WHICH WAS RELEASED IN
DECEMBER AND WE ALSO RECEIVED
MULTIPLE APPLICATIONS NOW THAT
IT HAS CLOSED THE C. C. T. OUR
PRIORITY IS TO ADDRESS CHAO
PROFESSOR AN INFANT AND TODDLER
CARE WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING THESE
APPLICATIONS AND GROUP WILL HOPE
TO WILL BOARD. THE CITY ARE
FUNDING BY APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHICH IS ON TARGET. I WILL
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT CONTRACTS
CONTRACTORS ARE STILL IN PROCESS
OF BALI AND BELIEVE FAMILIES FOR
THESE NEW SPOTS BECAUSE THE DATA
SUBMITTED MONTHLY AFTER SERVICES
RENDERED WHICH PROVIDES
UTILIZATION STATISTICS AT THIS
TIME WE ESTIMATE PROVIDING THE
STATUS AT LEAST A QUARTER AFTER
THE AUGMENTATION AROUND MARCH. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE CAN SHARE
THAT CONTRACTORS ARE ACTIVELY
DOING THE WORK TO INCREASE
CAPACITY ENROLLMENT SUCH AS
HOSTING WEEKLY PARENT ENROLLMENT
SESSIONS TO FULLY UTILIZE THEIR
FINES HUNTER FIRST BILL
CONFIDENCE BUILDING THE NEW
SLOTS HOWEVER. ONE MAKE
KNOWLEDGE AT THIS IS A MASSIVE
INVOLVEMENT THAT WILL TAKE TIME.
FOR SOME OF THEM FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN AGENTS CONSENT SAN DIEGO
HAD LET US KNOW THAT. THEY HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY AND ROLLING
ABOUT SIXTY NEW CHILDREN PER
WEEK. AND WE HAVE ALREADY I HAVE
ALREADY ENROLLED OR PROFOUND
CHILDREN SINCE FUNDING A- WE
HAVE ALSO HEARD FROM THE FIELD
NEED FOR FUNDING RAMP UP. AND
CASH FLOW AND BECAUSE OF THESE
NEWS- WEEKS SOME CLEAR OUT THE
CON T ENSURE THEY ARE AWARE THE
ANTI SET POINT 5% UP THERE- M.
R. EIGHTY WHICH IS AB REGARDING
OF WHETHER IT BE ASSOCIATED
SERVICE HAS BEEN PROVIDED SO
THEY CAN ACCESS THAT SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE REGARDLESS OF THE
SERVICE. I'M PROVIDED WE WILL BE
PROCESSING IN ADVANCE OF
FORTUNATE TO THE CAP AND THAT
SIMAK CONTRACTORS TO SUPPORT THE
INCREASED COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
BUDGET ACT AMENDMENTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE TO CAPTAINCY MAP
EXPANSIONS. THOSE ADVANCE
APPORTIONMENT REPRESENTS A
THIRTY THREE POINT 3% AT THE
BUDGET ACT ALLOCATION. PROVIDED
AND- MORE INFORMATION THAT WAS
RELEASED AND THAT'S HELPED HER.
FULL ATTENTION TWENTY ONE
SEVENTEEN. CAP AND THE MAX.
KICKS TO RECEIVE THOSE OF. AND
BEGIN IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WHICH THIS MONTH. AND- LET'S
SEE AND FINALLY WE ARE- FOR THE
SCENE DIRECT SERVICE PROGRAM
CONTRACT AMENDMENTS AND NET- TO
LATE MARCH FOR IT HE AT TITLE
FIVE CONTRACTS WHICH INCLUDES
THE GENERAL CHILDCARE. M. C. C.
T. R. C. HÌNH C. H. A. N. AND-
JENNA WHICH OF MY FRIENDS- WHICH
IS THE SCENE MAKE PROGRAMS
REFLECTED RATES- AGAIN ON TOP OR
BELOW TEN TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAD ENOUGH
BROUGHT IT WHICH INCLUDED THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIXTEEN JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WOULD CLARIFY
THAT THE HOLLYWOOD OFTEN
INCLUDED IN THIS. AND THEN THE
NEXT QUESTION I WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS ALSO IN REGARDS TO THE
UPDATE TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PREPAYMENTS. SO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
RATE PAYMENTS LET ME START FIRST
WITH THE GENERAL CHILD CARE
WHICH IS YOUR TITLE FIVE
CENTERS. CITY NY AND CDSS AND
TOP HAVE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER
IN CONSULTATION WITH PLEDGE
STAFF DEVELOPED THE
IMPLEMENTATION METHODOLOGY FOR
THE SPENDING. ESTIMATES FOR
READY TO WILL PROVIDE NOTICE AS
REQUIRED TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE AS
WELL AND WE'RE WE'RE CLOSE TO
FINALIZING THIS IS A REMINDER
THAT SOME POINT- ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION IS
ALLOCATED TO AT LEAST PARTIALLY
ADDRESSED AN EQUITY BETWEEN. THE
AND- THE S. R. R. TO THE ARMAR
CEILING FOR CENTER BASED
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND BY
PROVIDING REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SUPPLEMENTS TO ALLOCATE OVER.
TWENTY FOUR MONTH PERIOD. SIXTY
FIVE MIL- IS- BUT IT'S IS TO.
PROGRAM THE FRIENDLINESS
INTENDED TO STOP REIMBURSED
RATES FOR MAY BUT NOT TO MY
BREAK UP ON OR LESS BONUS. CITY
TO BE A ARBUS FOR. AND EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTING BASED ON FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS FOR THESE PURPOSES
NUMBER CLOSELY LIKE MENTIONED
AND WILL PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION. AND THEN- WE ALSO
HAVE THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATE FOR
THE PRIVATE CENTERS AND
ACCEPTING VOUCHER PROGRAMS IN
TERMS OF THIS WE APPRECIATE OF
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATOR ON
THE EARLY ACTION ASKED ME WHEN
FIFTEEN THIS WAS JUST FINE-
PEPPERY NINE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHICH WOULD PRESS TO PROVIDE
FORTY THREE POINT FOUR EIGHT.
POINT FOUR MILLION AND FUNDING
FOR REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SUPPLEMENT TO LICENSE CENTERS
WILL ACCEPT VOUCHER PROGRAMS FOR
A STATE JUST ONE TWO THREE AS
WELL AS THE CAP AND SEE MAP AND
THE BRIDGE PROGRAMS. SB FOUR ONE
FIVE APPROPRIATED AN ADDITIONAL
THREE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ISSUING THE
STATEMENTS TO THE CENTERS CBS
SAYS IT'S STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPING THE METHODOLOGY IS
CHANGED PAYMENTS BUT WILL
CONSULT WITH THE LEGISLATOR AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
METHODOLOGY AS ACCORDING TO SEE
B. ONE ONE ONE FIFTEEN. ONE ONE
FIVE. AND THEN THE SUPPLEMENT
FREE ARE IN EVERY. TO ARE SIX HE
PARTNERS SO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR SIXTY PARTNER. THROUGH A
JOINT LABOR COMMITTEE AND TO
DETERMINE THE FINAL DETAILS
RELATED TO THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE SPENDING WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL UPDATES TO THE
LEGISLATOR AS SOON AS WE'RE ABLE
TO SHARE FURTHER INFORMATION. IN
THE MEANTIME AND AS A REMINDER
THIS IN THIS FUNDING INCLUDES AT
TWO EIGHTY NINE MILLION AND ONE
TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT FAMILY
CHAKRA HOME PROVIDERS BOTH
LICENSED AND UNLICENSED ROGUE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SUPPLEMENT.
TO BE ALLOCATED OVER A PERIOD OF
TWENTY FOUR MONTH PERIOD. YOU
HAVE TO THE DISCRETION TO DECIDE
HOW THE FUNDING MAY BE USED TO
SUPPLEMENT RATES- THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WHICH MAY.
INCLUDE BUT NOT LIMITED TO
MONTHLY RATE SUPPLEMENTS BURKE
FAMILY CHOPPER HOME PROVIDERS OR
A LUMP SUM SUBJECT TO REVIEW AND
APPROVAL OF THE STATE TO ENSURE.
VISIBILITY THE STATE SEC.
ESTABLISHED JOINT LABOR
COMMITTEE MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
J. L. M. C. TO FACILITATE THESE
AGREEMENTS ON THE USES OF THE
SPENDING AND THE METHODOLOGY.
CDSS AND CCQ IS WORKING CLOSELY
TO FINALIZE THE FINAL DETAILS
AND CAN PROVIDE AN UPDATE ONCE
FINALIZED. AND SO WITH THAT I
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS AND I AM
HAPPY TO- ANSWER ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SINGLE GO TO THE FINE. THANK YOU
CHECK MANY MEMBERS SCABBY CENTER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
IN RESPONSE TO THE- REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AFRIN OVERVIEW OF
THE POST FUNDING IS LAW
INCREASES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR. I
THE GOVERNOR'S. TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACTION BY ADDING THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND ONE CHILD CARE
SLOTS THERE A TOTAL INVESTMENT
OF ONE POINT SIX BILLION- THIS
INCLUDES INVESTMENTS BEGAN IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO ADD
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS. AND ADDITIONAL FUNDS OF
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FOR A
TOTAL OF ONE POINT ZERO FIVE
BILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM.
SEVENTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION FOR
IT B. I CAN ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THE
GENERAL CHILD CARE PROGRAM AND
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION FOR IT
BE. A BIRD IS THE CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROGRAM FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN. I'M IN RESPONSE TO THE
REQUEST SUBCOMMITTEE FOR AN
UPDATE ON THE EXPENDITURE OF
FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
AFTER ARE THE FUNDS- ROUGHLY ONE
BILLION IN FEDERAL OUR FINDINGS
ARE PERFORATED IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FOR CHILD CARE WITH
FUNDINGFOR RATE INCREASES-
INCLUDING SEVENTY. MILLION
TOWARDS INCREASING CHILD CARE
SLOTS. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION FOR INCREASING PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES. SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION FOR A SUPPLEMENT TO
PROVIDER RESEARCH REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION FOR PROVIDER STIPENDS.
AT THIRTY ONE BILLION FOR
SIXTEEN NON OPERATIONAL DAYS FOR
PROVIDERS ACCEPTING VOUCHERS
THAT HAVE TO CLOSE FOR COMFORT
NINETEEN RELATED REASONS.
SEVENTY MILLION FOR PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT AT A CHILD'S
MAXIMUM CERTIFIED LEVEL OF NEED.
HUNDRED MILLION TO PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS FOR THE
ACQUISITION CONSTRUCTION
DEVELOPMENT AND RENOVATION OF
CHILD CARE FACILITIES FOCUSING
ON DESERT AREAS. TEN MILLION
SUPPORT CONTINUED RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL PARTNERSHIPS TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR INTERMEDIATE
ROLE WITH HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
EXPANSION OF THE CHILD CARE
INITIATIVE PROJECT AND TEN POINT
SIX MILLION PER EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION.
AREN'T HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THAT THAT MEMBERS
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU. ILIO GOOD
AFTERNOON OUT OF MEMBERS ARE
GOOD WITH THE THAT ABOUT OFFICE
ARE I THINK I WAS AT THE PUMP A
OF A OVERVIEW OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWO BUDGET ACTION THAT I THINK-
YES HI MY NAME AND THE CENTER
EXIT TALK ABOUT BOTH WITHIN
THERE WAS IN THE BUDGET ACT AND
THE- THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGETS ALL JUST FOCUS OUR
COMMENTS ON- BUT- OUR REVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET PROPOSAL. WE DID IT
ONE THAT NO ONE ISSUE REGARDING
THE FUNDING FOR OUR GENERAL
HEALTH CARE OR CTR- FOR THE
SLOTS THAT WERE PROVIDED-
INITIALLY IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FORTY SIX THOUSAND NO GENERAL
TUCKER SLOTS IN THAT AMOUNT OF
FUNDING WAS BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE SLOTS WOULD
BE RELEASED ON APRIL FIRST
TWENTY ONE APRIL FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO THAT'S TWENTY
THREE THREE MONTHS WORTH OF
FUNDING DURING THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. ARE
THERE ANYWAY THE COST OF THE
SLOTS FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD NEED TO
SENSE A QUADRUPLE- FUNDING TO GO
FROM THREE MONTHS WITH A FUNDING
FOR TWELVE MONTHS WITH THE
FUNDING- SO THIS WOULD REQUIRE A
TOTAL OF EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE- DIED
MINISTRATION TWENTY TO TWENTY
BUDGET HOWEVER ONLY PROVIDES
FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER THE
FULL THE FOR YOUR CALL THREE
SLOTS THAT'S THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS LAST
AND WE WOULD'VE EXPECTED. ON
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL%
SERVICES THIS IS DUE TO A CHANGE
IN METHODOLOGY OF HOW THEY ARE
CALCULATING THE COST PER GENERAL
CHUCK TUCKER SLOT I'M WOULD YOU
BRING WITH YOUR ATTENTION
ANOTHER TO MEET- TECHNICAL
REASONS WHY WOULD MAKE DIFFERENT
ASSUMPTIONS BUT BECAUSE IT'S
HAPPENING IN THE MIDDLE OF
IMPLEMENTATION THIS WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DEPARTURE FROM THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY BUDGET
AGREEMENT- WITH THIS CHANGE
AMERICAN MYTHOLOGY THIS RESULTS
IN BUT MINISTRATION ONLY
PROVIDING UP 260% OF THE FUNDING
FOR GENERAL CHALKER THAT WE
WOULD HAVE EXPECTED BASED. ON
THE TWENTY ONE TO BUDGET
AGREEMENT. I'M MORE STILL
CONTINUING TO REVIEW THE OTHER.
OPERABLE- SPEND CHANGES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BY RELATED CHILD CARE
. I'M A LITTLE YOU KNOW WE SEE
ANY ISSUES THAT WE BE IMPORTANT
HIGHLIGHT- AND BACK. MY COMMENT
I HAVE BEEN THIRTY FIRST. THANK
YOU VERY. DURING JOHNSON A ARRAY
. IT BURGER HAVE ALONG YOU WANT
TO ABOUT THE- THAT THREE
HUNDRED. NINE AS THE- THE
DIFFERENT COUNTY. I CHECK
MANTISES GARRISON TORN APART IN
A FINANCING PACKAGE TO RESPECT
TO THAT ISSUE- AS MR PEROT HAD
NOTED- THAT THE DIFFERENCE AND
SORT OF EXPECTATION THAT THE L.
A. WITH EXPECTING FOR THE COSTS
RELATED TO THE SPOTS. IS REALLY-
IN TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND DUE
TO A TWICE A METHODOLOGY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION MADE- WHERE
WE'RE INTENDING TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN MAINTAINING
COMMITMENTS AND THE NUMBER SPOT
TO GREET YOU AND AVAILABLE
ACROSS BUDGET WINDOW AND- TO
APPROPRIATING FUNDING. BASED ON
ACTUAL PRODUCTIVE UTILIZATION
I'M JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
ADHERE TO THE COMMITMENTS MADE
IN THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET BACK.
AND WE ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
ENGAGING WITH L. A. O. AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER OTHER
BUDGET METHODOLOGY SUPPORT
PROVIDE. REQUISITE FUNDING IN
NINETEEN COMMITMENTS. SOME OF
THE MOST RECENT IS SO. IS THE L.
A. O. ESTIMATE THAT ONLY SEE
PERCENT OF THE SLOTS INTENDED
BY. THE ADMINISTRATION AND
FUNDED BY THE LEGISLATURE WILL
BE ABLE TO BE FULFILLED. YES IT
IS OUR INTENT TO MAINTAIN THOSE
THOSE HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND SLOTS
AND ENCOURAGE YOUR WITH THAT THE
RAMP UP OVER THAT THE BUDGET
WINDOW THAT WAS AGREED TO LAST
YEAR SO WE'RE HAPPY TO ENGAGE
WITH LEN THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE AN APPROPRIATE
APPROACH. TO BUDGET AT THE BACK
COMMITMENT. SO WOULD YOU SAY
THIS IS A- AN EXAMPLE OF THE
LAST PANELS TALKING ABOUT THAT
WE STILL LIVE IN SILOS AND IF WE
LIVE IN SILOS ABOUT HOW WE
CALCULATE PAYMENT METHODOLOGIES
FROM ONE DEPARTMENT TO ANOTHER
AND I AND I WANNA. HIGHLIGHT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS DEPARTMENT
HAS JUST- DIVISION HAS JUST
RECEIVED THIS NEW RESPONSIBILITY
AND SO I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S A-
IT'S A COMPLEX- BUT IS THIS AN
EXAMPLE OF SILOS NOT TALKING TO
EACH OTHER OR HOW COULD HE- A
MISTAKEN CALCULATION HAVE
RESULTED IN. THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE MILLION AND 60% OF
SLIDES. I WENT YESTERDAY TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT ABOUT THE AND THE
TRANSITION OF THESE PROGRAMMES
THAT AND THE COMPLEXITY THAT
THERE YOU KNOW WERE ANSWERED IN
A LEARNING PERIOD ABOUT HOW WITH
THE PROSPECTS TO PURCHASE THAT
THIS IS THE PARTS WE TOOK WORK
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT-
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE- THAT THEY
OFFER SOME LEGISLATURE AND BUT
THE L. A. O. TO ENGAGE ON THIS
ISSUE SINCE WE CAN CONCEPT YOU
KNOW AND MUTUAL UNDERSTANDING
OF. WHAT THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO
MAINTAIN. A COMMITMENTS LAST
YEAR. OKAY SO THEN MY ASSUMPTION
IS WE'RE GONNA COME BACK IN AND
VISIT THIS AGAIN. THEM BEFORE I
MEAN CERTAINLY WELL BEFORE. WE
PASSED THE BUDGET SO WE CAN GET
A FIRM UNDERSTANDING OF HOW MUCH
MONEY IT'S GOING TO COST. AND
HOW MANY SLOTS WILL BE FUNDED-
AND IF WE GO INTO- THEN
ADJUSTING THE RAIDS. DOES THAT
IS THAT GOING TO IS THAT GOING
TO FURTHER COMPLICATE- THE
AMOUNT OF. THE DEBT IN THE
AMOUNT OF SLOTS THAT WERE ABLE
TO FIND. FOR A SECOND OR DOES IT
DOOR DOES IT FURTHER THE-
DISPARITY IN FUNDING FUNDING
METHODOLOGIES. I WOULD SAY THAT
I THINK THAT THE SORT OF THE-
MULTIPLE SORT OF EFFORTS THAT
WERE THAT WERE PROCEED THROUGH
THE TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT IT
DOESN'T- ADDED COMPLICATION WORK
WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH MULTIPLE
EFFORTS THAT ARE BEING ADDRESS-
PROCEED AT THE SAME TIME- RIGHTS
ACT- I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DID ENGAGE ON
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TO LOOK AT LIKE HOW. HOW WERE-
AT REVISING THE- THE RATES
EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY ALONGSIDE
THE INCREASE IN SPOTS AND AN
ESTIMATE AGAIN WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR- ON THE
OFFER FROM LA- AND LEGISLATURE
TO TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
ENGAGE JUST AS WE REVISIT GOING
INTO- FOR THE REVISION FONG
ABOUT. WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT AN
APPROPRIATE ASSESSMENT MIGHT BE.
OKAY THIRTY PARA. THANK YOU AND-
I GUESS IT'S JUST ONE OF THE
SITES WITH CHAIR ALSO SAID
NGUYEN FIRST OF ALL I THINK WE
NEED TO STRAIGHTEN THIS OUT AND
I WAS THE IT'S A SIGNIFICANT SUM
OF MONEY BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
AS- IN A WERE. GETTING THROUGH
CODED HAND- ALL AND- PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO RETURN TO WORK AND SO
FORTH AND EVEN LOCAL IT'S NOT
GONE AWAY YOU KNOW WE- WE CAN.
PEOPLE WELL THIS IS WHY WE HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
WOMEN WHO AREN'T ABLE TO REENTER
THE WORKFORCE IT IS A CHILD CARE
SO- SO AND SO REALLY APPRECIATE
THE PREVIOUS COMMITMENTS WE NEED
HONOR THEM. WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE NEED TO BUDGET FOR
THAT TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
THEN WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THOSE
SLOTS ARE AVAILABLE SO THAT-
PEOPLE. CAN DO THINGS THEY- NEED
TO DO AND- ALSO THAT HELPS WITH-
THE FAMILIES AND HELP THE
ECONOMY SO- I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING BACK FROM EVERYONE. THAT
HOW TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE BUT I
THINK- I THINK WE COULD SAY THAT
IT'S A PRIORITY THAT WE FIND
FUNDUS AND THAT WAS A PRIOR
COMMITMENT SO LET'S BE SURE WE
KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT NUMBER IS.
THANK YOU. OKAY I APPRECIATE
EVERY HARD WORK AND SOUNDS LIKE
WE GOT A LITTLE BIT BASED MORE
TO GO AND SO WILL. WE WILL WE
WILL KEEP WORKING ON THAT- THINK
EVERYBODY FOR YOUR WORK AND NOW
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE. ON TO AND
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS A CHILD CARE
STAKEHOLDER PERSPECTIVE- AND THE
WE HAVE INVITED JUSTIN BLAKELY
PUBLIC POLICY ASSOCIATE FOR
CRYSTAL STAIRS. INCORPORATED KIM
HERRON. DOES CFO CO OWNER OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD DISCOVERY
CENTERS. DIFFERENT CORLEY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER. KIMBERLY
ROSENBERGER- S. C. A. YOU. AND
MARISSA OVER SALAS PARENT VOICES
LEADER WELCOME EVERYBODY. PANEL
SHALL WE START WITH- MR BLAKELY
. YES THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS JUSTIN
BLAKELY ON THE PUBLIC POLICY
ASSOCIATE FOR CRYSTAL STAIRS
CRYSTALS THERE IS A RESOURCE ARE
PRO AGENCY THAT SERVES OVER
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN THE SOUTH THE LAKE
COMMUNITY. ON THE START BY
THANKING THE STATE LEGISLATURE
THE BILL KNOWS HOW HARD THE
LEGISLATURE HAD TO WORK- TO
FIGHT LAST YEAR FOR THE RATE
INCREASE TO GET TO THE SEVENTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REGIONAL
MARKET RATE SURVEY BACK COME
BEFORE YOU ALL TODAY TO SHARE
THE SIGNIFICANT STRUGGLES
SHOCKER PROVIDERS ARE STILL
EXPERIENCING TO KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN- THE NEED FOR HIGHER RATES
RIGHT. LAST YEAR THE CHILD CARE
RATE INCREASE- GOT PROVIDERS UP
TO THE SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ARMAR
SURVEY HOWEVER SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN INFLATION HAS
INCREASED BY 11% WITH A 7%
INCREASE ALONG THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. EARLY DATA FROM JANUARY IN
THE CASE THAT THE NATIONAL LABOR
CRISIS HAS FINALLY HIT THE CHILD
CARE PROFESSION. YES IT IF WE
LOOK AT- INFLATION EXCUSE ME FOR
A FOUR YEAR OLD AND A L. A.
COUNTY FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME
THE PROVIDER SHOULD BE RECEIVING
AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY SIX
DOLLARS AND EIGHTEEN CENTS HER
CHILD HER MOM. THE SAME PROGRAM
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY- THE
PROVIDER SHOULD BE RECEIVING AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY TWO DOLLARS AND
SEVENTY EIGHT CENTS PER CHILD
PER MONTH TO KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION I'M GOING TO SHARE-
THE FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME- BITER
EXPERIENCE OR EXPERIENCE EXCUSE
ME ALTHOUGH I'M SURE OUR FRIENDS
FROM CZ P. YOU. I CAN'T WILL
EXPAND FURTHER ON THE FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN THE
FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR CARE
EXPERIENCE- CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
OPENING CLOSING DURING- COLBY-
WE'RE I HAPPEN AT A ATE I WANT
TO SHARE A STORY WITH YOU OFF
FROM A PROVIDER THAT I SHARED
THIS STORY WITH ME- THE
EXPERIENCE OF BEING A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
BECAME VERY DEVASTATING BECAME
VERY DEVASTATING AS A ROLL MAN
TWINBILL. WHILE ALSO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE MONEY- AND
FUNDING WAS COMING FROM IT WAS
COMING AT ALL. HOW TO SUSTAIN
STAFF THAT CAN LEAD. AND MAIN.
BILLS REPLIED THAT YOU IT HAS
HER LOW. POINT OF BEING A CHILD
PROVIDER. SHE HAS BEEN IN SHOCK
PROVIDER LEASING GENTLEMEN FOR
OUR TO SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE- STAFFING SHORTAGES RIGHT
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER OF CHILD
CARE EMPLOYMENT NATIONALLY THE
CHILDCARE INDUSTRY IS STILL DOWN
A HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
JOBS SINCE FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY. LOW WAGES AREONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS PROVIDERS
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK IN LATIN
NEXT WOMEN. ARE LEAVING THE
CHILD CARE INDUSTRY AND NOT
ENTERING THE PROFESSION AT ALL.
I WANT TO PROVIDE ANOTHER
TESTIMONIAL FROM A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER. YOU SHARE WITH ME THAT
SHE HAS EXTREME DOES EXTREME
DIFFICULTY FINDING AN ASSISTANT
TO HELP OUR DAY TO DAY- PREVIOUS
ASSISTANT NOT DUE TO- HER PEER
FOR HOME HEALTH. IN THE WAKE OF
THE PANDEMIC. THIS CHILDCARE
PROVIDER HAS BEEN SEARCHING TO
FILL THE VACANCY SINCE TWENTY
TWENTY AND A HALF HAS HAD NO
LUCK. IS IT HAS FORCED HER TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT CHILDREN SHE
SERVES SHE WENT FROM PROVIDING
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE TO TWELVE
HOUR CARE EVERY DAY. OUR INCOME
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE HAS BEEN
REDUCED BY MORE THAN HALF. AND
SHE IS UNFORTUNATELY A PLAN
SHE'S IMPORTANT PLANNING ON
LEAVING THE BILL BEFORE THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SHE HAS
BEEN A CHILD CARE PROVIDER FOR
OVER THIRTY TWO YEARS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. ASK YOU ALL TO
REFLECT ON THEIR DISPOSITION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- IMAGINE
DISPOSITION APPARENTLY KNEW AND
EVEN SEASON OR PERSPECTIVE. HOW
CARE PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
WHAT THEIR EXPERIENCE MAY BE.
ENCLOSING WE MUST TAKE A STEP
BACK. AND CONSIDER THE SOCIAL
IMPLICATIONS OF EVERYTHING THAT
HAS JUST BEEN DESCRIBED IT IS
CLEAR. THE LACK OF CHILDCARE IS
DIRECTLY IMPACTING WOMEN'S
ABILITY TO RETURN. TO THE
WORKFORCE. FOR ALL OF LABOUR'S
THE TO. GARY'S CHOPPER. THE
ECONOMY RECOVERED. FOR MANY.
ACCORDING TO THE NAY. WOMEN'S
LAW CENTER WINNING GAINED A
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND
JOBS IN JANUARY. BUT WERE STILL
OVER ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
JOBS SHORT SINCE FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY. THE PROBLEM IS EVEN
WORSE FOR BLACK WOMEN AND LIVE
NEXT WOMEN IN OTHER DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS. I'LL SURELY STATISTICS
NEARLY ONE IN SEVENTEEN BLACK
WOMEN AGES TWENTY AND OVER JUST
FIVE POINT 8% WERE UNEMPLOYED IN
JERRY JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
DOWN FROM SIX POINT 2% IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
NEARLY ONE IN TWENTY LIVE NEXT
WOMEN AGES TWENTY AND OVER- FOUR
POINT 9% WERE UNEMPLOYED IN
JANUARY TWENTY SECOND TWO. I'M
CHANGE FROM DECEMBER. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY COMPARISON. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR WHITE MEN
AGES TWENTY AND OVER WAS THREE
POINT 2% IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO UP FROM 3% DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IS STARKLY
BUT CHAO K. INDUSTRY HAS
DEMONSTRATED ITS ADAPTABILITY
AND REMEMBER NEXT ENSURE OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ARE
SERVED. HOWEVER WE ARE NOW AT AN
INFLECTION POINT WHERE CHILD
CARE WHILE WHERE THE CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE CANNOT HOLD MUCH
LONGER AT THIS RATE. IN ITS
FRAGILITY HAS EXISTED OVER
DECADES. THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT
ONLY EXACERBATED HISTORICAL
RACIAL INEQUITIES BUT HAS
CREATED NEW ONES WE MUST MAKE
THESE SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS
NOW BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE. AND
THE REPERCUSSIONS BECOME EVEN
GREATER OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
AND I YIELD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR BLAKELY- MISTER
CALDERON. CFO. EARLY CHILDHOOD
DISCOVERY CENTERS. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTERS MY NAME
IS KEN HERE I'M A CO OWNER AND
CFO OF EARLY CHILDHOOD DISCOVERY
SAM CENTERS IN SELMA ABOUT
FIFTEEN MILES SOUTH OF. FRESNO I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
PARTICULARLY CENTER EGGMAN FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU- MYSELF MY WIFE
AND MY SISTER IN LAW OPERATE FOR
PRESCHOOL CENTERS ALL IN SELMA.
THE FIRST ONE BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE IN THE LAST ONE
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. WE
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES. SOME IS A MODERATE
INCOME CITY OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE I WOULD ESTIMATE
THAT ABOUT 80% OF POPULATION IS
STATIC WELL PERCENT WHITE 7%
JABI. AND 1% OTHER ALL OF OUR
CENTERS ARE FUNDED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM CONTRACTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION.
PROXIMALLY A THIRD OF OUR
CHILDREN ARE CLASSIFIED AS THE
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. WE CAN
USUALLY GET PRIVATE PAY FAMILIES
TO PAY THE SAME RATE AS THE
STATE PAYS US. HOWEVER THERE ARE
VERY FEW AND MOST FAMILIES AND
MOST OF OUR TEACHERS SADLY
QUALIFY FOR OUR SUBSIDIZE-
REGIONAL PROGRAM. YEAH COULD NOT
ECONOMIC BASE FOR SELMA AS WITH
MOST SMALL TOWNS AND CITIES IN
THE VALLEY AS AGRICULTURE. AND
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES WILL HAVE
AT LEAST ONE PARENT EITHER
WORKING IN THIS FIELD OR IN
PROCESS PLANTS. YOU MIGHT BE
INTERESTED DO YOU KNOW HOW WE
FARED DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND
HONESTLY WE HAVE BEEN VERY
BLESSED IN THAT REGARD. TWO
YEARS AGO OUR GOVERNOR DISPLAYED
THE LEADERSHIP THAT WAS SORELY
LACKING IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
YOU SHUT DOWN OUR STATE TO
PROTECT THE TWENTY SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. THE EXPERTS
THOUGHT WOULD OTHERWISE GET
INFECTED AND OVERWHELM MEDICAL
ASSISTANT AND I WAS VERY
SUPPORTIVE. EXCEPT WHEN HE CAME
TO THE PART ABOUT SCHOOLS BEING
SHUT TO PREVENT THE SPREAD BUT
NOT CHILD CARE CENTERS. MY WIFE
AND I WERE SCARED SCARED FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES AND WE WONDERED WHY DO
YOU THINK KEEPING CHILD CARE
CENTERS OPEN WON'T ALSO LEAD TO
THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE. WE
QUICKLY REEVALUATED AND CAME TO
REALIZE THAT IT WAS OUR CENTERS
TO BE. HE SOCIETY THE SAY OPEN
AND TRY TO CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN. OF THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND THAT'S JUST WHAT WE
NEEDED TO DO AND THAT'S HOW WE
APPROACH THEM WITH OUR EMPLOYEES
IT WAS NOT A DISCUSSION THE
MATTER THEY WERE EXPECTED TO BE
AT WORK AND THEY CAME TO WORK.
IT WAS SCARY AT FIRST I REMEMBER
AN INSTANCE EARLY ON WHEN WE
LEARNED THAT A CHILD WASN'T
COMING TO SCHOOL THAT DAY
BECAUSE HE TESTED POSITIVE. AND
ONE OF OUR TEACHERS RIGHT THERE
BURST INTO TEARS. SHE REACHED
DOWN AND TIED THAT SHOOT THAT
KIDS SHOES THE DAY BEFORE. AND
SHE HAD A ONE YEAR OLD AT HOME
AND SHE WAS SCARED. I SEE THAT
WE WERE BLESSED DURING HIS ON
GOING ON OKAY NINETEEN DOWN DOWN
BECAUSE WE'VE ONLY HAD ONE BRIEF
CLOSURE DURING THIS TIME. MOST
OF OUR TEACHERS HAVE BEEN
INFECTED IT SEEMS LIKE ABOUT
HOUSES WERE SECOND JANUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AND THE
OTHER HALF OF THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. EVEN WITH THE VACCINE
MANDATE THAT WE PUT INTO PLACE
IN AUGUST. FORTUNATELY WELL A
NUMBER OF TEACHERS HEADS HAVE
HAD SOME PRETTY SERIOUS SYMPTOMS
ONLY ONE AND HER HUSBAND. WERE
HOSPITALIZED AND THEY RECOVERED
FULLY. HOWEVER THE OMICRON VERY
IS REALLY HAMPERING OUR ABILITY
TO STAY FULLY STAFFED. MY WIFE
NEEDED TO WORK IN THE CLASSROOM
YESTERDAY AND SHE'LL BE AND ONCE
HE'S IN ONE TODAY THIS AFTERNOON
BECAUSE OF TEACHERS OUT WITH
PROGRAM. THE THING THAT IS SAVED
AS FINANCIALLY DURING THE PAST
TWO YEARS HAS BEEN THE STATE
FUNDING OUR CONTRACTOR FULL
REGARDLESS OF OUR ENROLLMENT OR
ATTENDANCE. SOMETHING REFERRED
TO AS THE HOLD HARMLESS. WITH
DRASTICALLY REDUCED CLASS AND
GROUP SIZES BEING DICTATED BY
THE PANDEMIC AND WITH ALL THE
CLEANING AND ADDED SAFETY
PROTOCOLS THAT REQUIRE MORE
STAFF TIME AND COST. WE NEED ALL
THE STAFF WE GET EVEN WITH YOUR
KIDS IN THE CLASSROOMS. NOW DUE
TO THE OPENING UP OF OUR STATE
AND THE DROPPING OF MASK
MANDATES WE ARE CLEARLY GOING TO
TRY TO LIVE WITH. AS WE DO WITH
OTHER DISEASE. HOWEVER IT STILL
MAKES PEOPLE SICK KIDS TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS AWAY FROM SCHOOL.
BBC COALITION IS REQUESTING A
CONTINUATION OF THIS HOLD
HARMLESS FOR ANOTHER YEAR. AS WE
ARE NO DOUBT GOING TO HAVE
ONGOING VARIANTS THAT WILL MAKE
CLASSROOMS AND FILL THEM WITH
KIDS. WHICH BRINGS ME NOW TO THE
NEWEST AND BIGGEST THREAT FOR
CENTERS AND THAT IS STAFF. IN
THE LAST NINE MONTHS WE'VE LOST
THREE TEACHERS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD BE BECAUSE THEY
CATER TWELVE WORLD PAYS MUCH
BETTER. NOW THAT TRANSITIONAL
CAN YOU'RE GONNA GUARD HAS BEEN
GREEN LIGHTED SQUAD RUBLE IN
SIZE IN LITTLE OVER THREE YEARS
FROM NW. AND EXPERTS SAY
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED ABOUT
SIXTEEN THOUSAND UTK TEACHERS
OVER THOSE THREE. YEARS AN
OBVIOUS STRATEGY IS FOR THEM TO
GO AFTER THE WORK FORCE AND
ALREADY HAS BEEN WORKING WITH.
T. K. H. HERE. OUR WORK FOR. RCS
PPG. I LITERALLY HEARD ON JUNE.
THAT THAT IS GREAT STRATEGY TO
GO AFTER SCHOOL THIS. I HAVE
THREE MORE TEACHERS WHO ARE
PREGNANT WITH SPRING AND SUMMER
BABIES AND WE'VE BEEN HAVING A
HARD TIME JUST GETTING
APPLICANTS TO REPLACE THEM AND
FULLY STAFFED FOR OUR CENTERS.
THE ONLY WAY WE CAN POSSIBLY
RETAIN TEACHERS BY UPPING THEIR
PAY AND BENEFITS AND THE ONLY WE
CAN WE CAN DO THAT AS WITH
HIGHER REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
CENTERS. AS YOU KNOW IN CONCERT
WITH THE BOW TO EXPAND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN LAST
YEAR THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATORS
ALSO APPROVE SOMETHING CALLED
RATE REFORM FOR INDUSTRY. AND
TOOK A STEP OF CONVERTING A
REIMBURSEMENT RATE HE TO CSPD
CONTRACTORS TO ONE BASED ON A ON
REGIONAL MARKET RATES. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I SUPPORTED OUT
OF A SENSE OF FAIRNESS. AS
OBVIOUSLY HIGH COST REGIONS IN
THE SATE SHOULD BE PAID HIGHER
RATES THAN LOW CASARES OF THE
STATE I SUPPORTED WITH THIS
BECAUSE THERE WAS ALSO SUPPOSED
TO BE UPWARD ADJUSTMENTS THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
CONTRACTORS SUCH AS US. BASED ON
THE HIGHER QUALITY AND HIGHER
STAFFING RATIOS WE ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE AS A TITLE FIVE
CONTRACTOR AS SOON AS AN EXAMPLE
CSV CONTRACTORS ARE REQUIRED TO
HAVE ONE ADULT IN THE CLASSROOM
FOR EVERY EIGHT CHILDREN. BUT
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATES THAT
REPRESENT WHAT PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS ARE CHARGED ARE
BASED ON STAFFING RATIOS OF ONE
ADULT FOR TWELVE CHILDREN. WHICH
IS 50% LESS CHAP CLASSROOM
STABBING. THEM WHAT WE ARE
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN. AB
WORKGROUP AS BEEN CAN BE CONVENE
TO HELP FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
QUALITY ADJUSTMENT SHOULD BE.
HOWEVER NOTHING WAS DONE ABOUT
THIS RATE DISPARITY FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR AND THE WORK
GROUP'S FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL COME IN AUGUST OR IN THE
FALL. SO THIS DISPARITY WILL
CONTINUE FOR A SEPARATE YEAR
NEXT YEAR. IF NOTHING ELSE IS
DONE IN THE MEANTIME.
ACCORDINGLY THE EASY CORE
COALITION IS REQUESTING A 20%
RATE INCREASE FOR THE UPCOMING
BUDGET YEAR WHICH WOULD HELP
IMMENSELY. BOSTON THE MORE
COSTLY STAFF STAFFING RATIOS
WE'RE REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN
COMPARED WITH PRIVATE PROVIDERS
. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU FOR KEEPING YOUR
DOORS OPEN REALLY A KNOWLEDGE IT
AND APPRECIATE IT AND I CAN
ONLY. HE TO YOU TOOK ME BACK TO
HOW AFRAID WE ALL WERE- AND I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE A CHILD CARE
WORKER AND SOME OF THAT I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH- THINKING ABOUT.
AND THINKING ABOUT THAT THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SURROUNDING.
YOUR AREA. THAT IS NOT VERY
VIGOROUS AND JUST MAKING
EVERYTHING MORE FRIGHTENING SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR YOUR
STAFFING. THANK YOU- ED. DEVER
CORLEY. CHILD FAMILY CARE
PROVIDER. YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DEBORAH
QUALITY BARS THAT I HAD BEEN A
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDER KERN
COUNTY FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE YEARS PROVIDERS ARE
EDUCATING MOTIVATING AND
STIMULATING THE MINDS OF YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS. EVERY DAY BY
TRYING TO REMAIN HEALTHY
THEMSELVES. THE PANDEMIC STARTED
THOUSANDS ARE PROVIDED TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS TEMPORARILY AND
PERMANENTLY DUE TO COLD IT.
THOSE WHO HAVE REMAINED OPEN. I
HAVE DONE AT A VERY HIGH CALL.
BUT PROVIDERS STAND ALL. THANK
WITH THEIR LIVES. HEALTH CARE
GIVER LABOR OF LOVE. BUT THE
LACK OF HEALTH CARE. RETIREMENT
OKAY TIME ALL I DO WAY TOO MANY
ARE DRIVING TOO MANY PROVIDERS
OUT BY MYSELF EIGHT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
HEALTH CARE INSURANCE. I HAVE. I
CAN'T AFFORD TO GO WITHOUT
HEALTHCARE INSURANCE. MY ONLY
LIKE I HAVE BEEN MY HUSBAND'S
SURVIVORS CALLED PLANT. EIGHT
WHAT ABOUT THE OLD HEY THAT
OPTION. WELL BUT- ON THE DAY
CARE PROVIDER YEAH I CAN'T THAT
I WAS MEANT. LET ME HEALTHCARE
AND IT COST HER LIFE. THREE
MONTHS AGO. BUT MASSIVE HEART
ATTACK. WHAT OTHER DAY GET
KILLED. NO PROVIDE NO CHAU NO
FAMILY OR COMMUNITY THE GOAL
THROUGH THIS TYPE OF CRIME. ALEX
PROVIDERS. WELL I PLAYED A
CRITICAL. FORTY CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY. YOUR FAMILY CHARACTER
PROVIDERS ARE STANDING TOGETHER
. DEMANDING THAT THE STATE PRO
LIFE ALL FAMILIES HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS WITH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. PROVIDERS DO THE JOB
THAT ALLOWS SO MANY OTHERS. WHEN
QUALITY HEALTH YEAH WE HAVE THE
RIGHT. WE DIE. FIVE FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
WORK AND- THAT YOU DO EVERY
SINGLE DAY. LET'S HEAR NOW FROM
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER FROM
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION OR SEIU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON THE
NEEDS OF THE CHILD CARE WORK
FORCE AND THE STATUS OF OUR
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES- I I'M PRESENTING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDER UNITED WHICH IS A
U. D. W. I. C. I. U.
COLLABORATION- WHILE WE HAVE
RECENTLY MADE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN CHILD CARE AS
DEBORAH STORY HIGHLIGHTED WE
STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO
APPROPRIATELY SUPPORT WORK
FORCE. ONLY BEGAN ORGANIZING
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE WE WERE LOOKING
AT A WORK FORCE OF WELL OVER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS BY
TWENTY NINETEEN PROVIDERS WON
THE RIGHT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING JEREMY LESSEM FORTY
THOUSAND WORKERS. THE PANDEMIC
HAS FURTHER HIGHLIGHTED THAT OUR
CHILD CARE WORKFORCE IS NOT
OPERATING ON THE STRONG
FOUNDATION. THAT THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION. CURRENTLY THEY CANNOT
DO THEIR JOBS WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING NOT ONLY THEIR OWN
LIVELIHOODS BUT IN MANY CASES
THEIR OWN LIVES. THE HISTORIC
INFLUX OF STATE REVENUE IN YOUR
HELP. WE CAN TURN THIS AROUND.
FOR THIS FEMALE DOMINATED WORK
FORCE. LAST YEAR WITH THE
SUPPORTOF THE LEGISLATURE
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
RATIFIED THEIR FIRST UNION
CONTRACT. PART OF THIS HISTORIC
AGREEMENT FORM NINE JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE. THANK
RECALL OF THESE COMMITTEES. ARE
TO STRENGTHEN THE FOUNDATION
NEEDED TO STABILIZE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE IN THE SHORT TERM TO
CREATE A PATHWAY OUT OF POVERTY.
A STABLE CAREER FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS LONG TERM. OF THE
NINE. THREE WERE HIGHLIGHTED
BECAUSE OF THE URGENCY- THEY
NEED TO PROVIDE STABLE- IT. IS
TO HELP STABILIZE PROVIDERS
THOSE THREE ARE HEALTHCARE
RETIREMENT AND HE TIME OFF. CCQ
IS GLAD TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON
THIS WORK TO GET THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMATION TO BEST MAKE
IMMEDIATE AND MEANINGFUL
INVESTMENTS IN THE PROPOSAL SET
FORTH. THE COST REPRESENTING OUR
OWN. AND INTENDED TO PROVIDE
CURRENT UPDATES AND INFORMATION
BASED ON OUR INTERNAL RESEARCH
AND THE DIRECTION OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE BEING HAD
IN HIS COMMITTEES. IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL OF A THREE
DAY ON SEES. INVESTMENTS WILL BE
NEEDED. AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
IDEALLY IN THIS LEGISLATIVE YEAR
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BUDGET ACT.
INACTION THESE CUTE CREMINS.
ONCE REGIONAL COMMITTEES. WILL
ENSURE THAT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
CONSERVATOIRE EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO KEEP PARENTS
WORKING IN CHILDREN FIVE. AND
TOOK TO THE BACK. TO KEEP THEM
IN THE EARLY CHILD CARE CHILD
CARE INDUSTRY- AND NOT LEAVING
FOR K. TO TWELVE WHICH DOES HAVE
A WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. BUT ALSO
WE HAVE AN IMMEDIATE NEED HERE.
STARTING WITH HEALTHCARE MORE
THAN 50% OF OUR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS SURVEY REPORTED
DELAYED OR POSTPONED MEDICAL
TREATMENT DUE TO LACK OF HEALTH
INSURANCE. OR BEING UNDER
INSURED. 20% REPORTED BEING
UNINSURED AND UNABLE TO AFFORD
THE MOST. BASIC PLAN THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. OUR CURRENT
AS- IS TO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE MILLION WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS OVER TWO
YEARS. RETIREMENT IS ALSO A KEY
ISSUE MORE THAN 90% OF FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS SURVEYED
REPORTED NOT HAVING THE MEANS TO
SAVE MORE THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
PER RETIREMENT OVER THEIR
LIFETIME. MUCH LESS SAVING
ENOUGH FOR THEM PREVENT THEM
FROM RETIRING INTO POVERTY. WELL
EXPERTS ADVISE A RETIREE SHOULD
PLAN TO COVER EXPENSES OF FORTY
THOUSAND A YEAR THAT WOULD MEAN
HAVING SAME ONE MILLION BY AGE
SIXTY FIVE TO ENABLE THEIR
BENEFITS TO LAST UNTIL AGE
NINETY OR TWENTY FIVE YEARS. OUR
MEMBERS ARE NOWHERE NEAR STAVING
ENOUGH FOR JUST ONE YEAR LET
ALONE TWENTY FIVE. OUR CURRENT
ESTIMATE WOULD BE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN MILLION TO ENROLL
ELIGIBLE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN A FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
B. RETIREMENT PLAN. THAT HELPS
ME PROVIDERS HOLE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD RETIREMENT
SAVINGS TO TWO YEARS OF BEING
UNDERPINNED BY THE STATE. AND
FINALLY MEANINGFUL PAID TIME OFF
BALANCE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE
CONSIDERED INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OF THE STATE AND
MANY ARE NOT ENTITLED TO PAID
HOLIDAYS AND VACATION TIME. NO
PROVIDER HAS SUFFICIENT PAID
TIME OFF TO THE MAX OF. TEN DAYS
FOR SICK LEAVE VACATION
EMERGENCIES ARE HOLIDAYS THIS
CAN BE ESPECIALLY TAXING ON. A
PROVIDERS WHO CAN AFFORD TO TAKE
TIME OFF. I WE HAVEN'T. OF EIGHT
SIX AND WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
ELIGIBLE RIDERS WITH FIVE
ADDITIONAL PAID TIME OFF DAYS
INCLUDING REIMBURSEMENT. FOR
CHILDREN THAT ARE UNBEARABLE
SCHEDULE. TCP YOU IN THE
MINISTRATIONS AND DILIGENTLY
WORKING TO REACH AGREEMENTS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AND RECOGNITION
OF THE URGENCY OF THE NEEDS- THE
CALIFORNIA STATUTE LAID OUT IN
OUR AGREEMENT AND RATIFIED BY
THE LEGISLATURE SPECIFIES THAT
BENEFITS FOR PROVIDERS WILL BE
PROVIDED THROUGH UNION RUN
TRUST. WILL SERVE ALL LICENSED
AND NON LICENSED FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. EARLY WORKING TO
SET UP TRUST I'LL PROVIDE
SERVICES BUT NEED TO FINALIZE
DETAILS ON THE BASICS SUCH AS
WHAT TYPE OF PLAN WILL BE
UTILIZED BEFORE WE CAN
OFFICIALLY ESTABLISHED TRUST. I
AM HAPPY TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL
IN THE GREEN UPON FRAMEWORK FOR
THE THREE JAIL AND SEE IS
HIGHLIGHTED. AS WELL AS FURTHER
BREAKS DOWN OUR COST ESTIMATES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MY SOUL ROSE US PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MONEY
SEVERAL SILENCE. I AM HERE
REPRESENTING OUR VOICES
CALIFORNIA. AND THE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BENEFITED FROM CHILD YOUR FAMILY
FEE WAIVER SINCE JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BACK TO TWENTY
SIX THOUSAND FAMILIES WHO WILL
BE IMPACTED IF YOU DON'T EXTEND
THOSE WAIVERS. AS A MOTHER OF
FOUR I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE THE
BAY TALK YOUR FEES THAT ARE
UNAFFORDABLE I HAD TO DECIDE
WHICH BILLS THE PAPERS DOWN
WHICH BILL TO PAY LATER I WAS
THE LEADING LADY YES THERE WAS
NO BREATHING SPACE FOR ME I WAS
ALWAYS BEHIND AND NO MATTER HOW
HARD MY HUSBAND. AND I WORK WE
COULD NEVER GET AHEAD. ALL THAT
CHANGED. OF CARE. LIKE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GÓMEZ REYES STARTING JULY
FIRST THAT. THEY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PUBLISHED IN A FAMILY
FEES WENT TO PAY OFF THE STUDENT
LOAN INSPECT. BECAUSE I GAVE MY
TOTAL DEBT DOWN MY CREDIT FOR
INCREASED BY TWENTY POINTS WITH
A SIX MONTH. IT WAS ONE OF ALL
MY KIDS AND THROW PARTICLE DANCE
CLASS. WITH THE PANDEMIC INDIAN
AND ISOLATION AWAY FROM THEIR
PEERS. BOTH SIDES. ARE BRINGING
JOY TO MY KIDS AGAIN. I WAS ABLE
TO BRING IT EVERY MONTH BECAUSE
I HAD THE EXTRA FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO MAKE CHOICES THAT
BENEFITED MY ENTIRE FAMILY. WELL
AS THE BILL ONE LESS WORRY. THE
FEES ARE WAIVED UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR. AND WE
NEED ALL OF YOU TO USE YOUR
POWER TO KEEP. THE PROGRAM
BEYOND THAT. IMAGINE. IF BADLY
FEES WERE ELIMINATED. MY GOAL IS
TO. INCREASE CREDIT SCORE EVEN
MORE TO HAVE IT THAT OWNERSHIP.
THE BILL THAT LIFE MIGHT GET
DESSERT. THIS IS JUST THE IMPACT
ON ME. A MALE OF DOLLARS HAVE
STAYED IN A BANK ACCOUNT OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WORK CHARTS
OR ANYTHING ALL OF THEM
EXPERIENCING FINANCIAL LIBERTY
AND MORE STABILITY THROUGH ON
ONE OF THE MOST UNCERTAIN TIME
IN OUR HISTORY. THIS IS WHY IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR THE NEXT BUDGET
WAY THE FAMILY UNTIL SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT ALLOWED BY
FEDERAL REGULATIONS. IT WILL
ALLOW FAMILIES LIKE MINE TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC BUILT
FINANCIAL STABILITY AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR CHILDREN.
BUT WAIT WAIT THESE ARE ONLY ONE
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO FIX SUCH
HEALTHCARE CRISIS. BY NEEDS
HEALTHCARE WHAT PART BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BUT IT'S EVEN HARDER
NOW. WE ARE WATCHING OUR VERY
LITTLE CHILDREN HEALTHCARE
SUPPLY BANISHED BECAUSE
PROVIDERS CANNOT AFFORD TO STAY
OPEN. WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ADD THIRTY THOUSAND
THEN. THAT CHILD CARE SLOTS BUT
IT HAVE TO HAPPEN TOGETHER WITH
THE WAIVERS AND INCREASES YOUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDER WAGES. I
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM AMAZING
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS OVER THE
YEARS BUT I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN PAID FORTY AND THAT IS NOT
RIGHT. FOR MY HUSBAND AND I TO
WORK WITH YOU THE MIND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ALSO HAVE BEFORE MINE.
HOW CAN THEY HAVE IT IF THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT PAYING BILLS
PAYING STAFF PAYING THEM STOP.
WHAT PROVIDERS APPARENT OUR
WHOLE. WHEN WE HAVE PEACE OF
MIND ALL OUR KIDS BENEFIT. SO WE
STAND WITH THAT YOU SEE FEEL
DEMANDING. SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT. IT IS WITH HIGHWAY.
AND EXPENSE LAW LOCKS WITH NO
FEES THIS IS HOW WE ENSURE ONE.
SPECIALLY WOMAN A BETTER CAN BE
INCLUDED IN OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THANK C. YOU ALL THE
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AND FOR YOUR- YOUR
TIME SPENT HERE WITH US TODAY.
IT IS IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT BUT IT'S
ALWAYS REALLY. GROUNDING YOUR
FOR ALL OF YOU WHO ARE DOING THE
WORK OUT IN THE FIELD- AND I
KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION WAS VERY
FOCUSED ON- TWENTY K. AND THE
AND I CAN TELL YOU. AS A MEMBER
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. WE HAVE
FOCUSED OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
IT REALLY TRYING TO FOCUS ON
CHILDCARE- AND NOT ONLY
INCREASING SLOTS BUT- WAIVING
FEES AS WELL AS- INCREASING
REIMBURSEMENT WAGES. FOR
WORKERS- THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AT
HAS MADE THAT OUR PRIORITY-
BEFORE I WAS CHAIR WHILE I WAS
CHAIR AND ON THROUGH SO WE- I
THINK I. CAN GUARANTEE YOU THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE A STRONG
FOCUS FOR THE WOMEN'S CAUCUSES
HERE. AS WE REALLY TRY TO MAKE
SURE. I MEAN NO BUT NOBODY CAN
ARGUE WITH THE POINT THAT. WOMEN
WORKFORCE. ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF
COLOR ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES
TO CHILDCARE HAVE BEEN.
OVERWHELMINGLY IMPACTED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AND A CLEARLY- THE
ISSUES THAT YOU STRUGGLE WITH.
YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT AND DON'T
REALLY MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF NOISE
ABOUT A LOT OF TIMES HAS REALLY
COME TO LIGHT FOR ALL OF US. AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK- AND WE
APPRECIATE. DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND
THE DEPARTMENT FOR TAKING ON.
THIS THIS PART- THAT PREVIOUSLY
HAD GONE TO A MORE THE
EDUCATION- SO IT IS A AT ANY
TIME WE HAVE MASSIVE CHANGES OF
COURSE THINGS CAN FALL OFF- BUT
WE THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING YOUR
PERSPECTIVES. AND WE ARE ALL I
THINK VERY DEDICATED TO. TRYING
TO MAKE THIS MAKE THIS RIGHT AND
KEEP THIS RIGHT. DEKABANK
MEETING YOU'D LIKE TO ADD. THANK
YOU AND AGAIN PROCEED TO
PRESENTATIONS- IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ALSO DEPARTMENTS
SOCIAL SERVICES I KNOW THAT-
APPRECIATE YOU PICKING UP- YOU
KNOW IN THE REORGANIZATION.
OVERSEEING THE CHILD CARE SO-
SORRY I DO I RECOGNIZE THAT- THE
TRANSITIONS HAPPENING AND THAT'S
A- GOOD PART OF THE CHALLENGE
BUT- I BELIEVE THAT THROUGH YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS. THAT IT IS
WORKING ON THAT NOW SO AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATIONS
FROM OUR CHILD CARE
STAKEHOLDERS- AND- WHILE NOT A
MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS- US
ONLY SUPPORT EFFORTS OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND TRYING
EXPANSION ON KERRY FACT I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF YOU ARE GOING TO
BE PRESENTING TOMORROW BUT
TOMORROW EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WHICH I ALSO SAID WE WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT. EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION AS WELL SO. THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY SO WE'LL BE TOUCHING ON
THE THINK SOME ISSUES RELATED TO
THAT AS WELL. SO OKAY. OF THAT
AGAIN THANK YOU. OKAY TO THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH AGAIN DIRECTED
JOHNSON THANK YOU FOR YOU AND
ALL OF YOUR YOUR YOUR DIVISION
FOR THE PRESENTATION. AND AGAIN
NOT JUST FOR THE PRESENTATION TO
US TODAY BUT THE WORK THAT YOU
DO EVERY SINGLE DAY TO CARRY
OUT. THE MISSION FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. OKAY WITH THAT I
THINK WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND AGAIN YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE IN WHICH TO MAKE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT INVEST NOT ENOUGH
TIME FOR YOU YOU CAN ALWAYS.
REACH OUT TO THE COMMITTEE AND
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CONTEXT
FOR YOUR COMMENT. BUT AT THIS
POINT I HOPE OUR OPERATORS
THERE. AND AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. OPERATOR EITHER. BUT WE
HAVE TWO PEOPLE HERE IN PERSON
SO WE GONNA START THERE- WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING READY TO ONE OF
THE Q. OPERATOR AND THE FIRST
WITNESS HERE IN THE ROOM. PLEASE
BEGIN. EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO WORK LIVE AND
RAISE THEIR FAMILIES THAT THEY
CAN DIGNITY. ALL OF US DESERVE
THE CHANCE TO REALIZE OUR
POTENTIAL. MY NAME IS KARINA
LEGO WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S INQUIRY INTO
THE GVERNOR'S BUDGET RELATING
TO THE FUNDING OF CHILDCARE
VOUCHERS. FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET YEAR. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE BUDGET
AND ADOPT POLICIES THAT ARE
INDEPENDENT WHICH INCLUDES
INCREASING CHILD CARE SUBSIDY
RATES. WAVING FAMILY FEAST IS
THE TIMBRE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THE PARENTS CAN
AFFORD TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PUBLICLY FUNDED CHILDCARE
PROGRAM. INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF VOUCHERS AND PAYING PROVIDERS
BASED ON A FAMILY CERTIFIED NEED
RATHERTHAN ATTENDANCE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LAURIE FURSTENFELD
ALSO WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER. ADOPTING THE POLICIES
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUE KARINA
WILL BEGIN TO RECTIFY SOME OF
THE HARM FROM POLICIES THAT
EXPECT WOMEN OF COLOR TO HOLD UP
THE SYSTEM WITH LITTLE OR NO PAY
DEPENDS ON MOTHERS REPORT TO
SUBSIDIZE OTHER MOTHERS WERE
POOR IN SEVERELY LIMITS THEIR
CHOICE OF WHERE TO SEND THEIR
KIDS WHILE THEY WORK. ADOPTING
THESE POLICIES WILL ENSURE THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY CALIFORNIA IS
INCLUSIVE OF WOMEN OF COLOR
THESE BUDGET PRIORITIES ARE
OUTLINED IN THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION LETTER AND
THE FAMILY FEE BUDGET REQUEST
LETTER SIGNED BY OVER THREE
HUNDRED SUPPORTERS. MAINLY
PARENTS AND CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME HERE TODAY. OPERATOR ARE
YOU STANDING BY. YES I AM IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END OF THE ROW
AT THE TIME. MANY PEOPLE DO WE
HAVE ANY Q. OPERATOR. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY M.
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OVERFLYING NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
STANDING COLBERN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS THAT THE ASIAN
TODAY COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT WORKS
DIRECTLY WITH FAMILIES HAVE
BEEN. LEFT WITH A LOT OF PAIN
FOR MANY UNFUNDED MANDATE AND
HAVE SHIFTED MANY PARTS OF THE
SERVICES TO PERSONAL SETTINGS
JUST TO ENSURE THAT FAMILIES
WERE SUPPORTED WITH CONSISTENT
ACCESS TO COURT THANK YOU ARE
STRUGGLING WITH A DIMINISHED
WORKFORCE NOW HAPPENED AND
THAT'S EIGHTY AFTER. CO THIS
RELATED DATE. THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC NEARLY THREE. DOZEN
UNFUNDED MAN AND CHANGES IN. IN
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS OF. ALONG
WITH REQUIRED PROJECT IS NEEDED
TO ENSURE CRITICAL WORK IN
VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENTS AND FAMILY.
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
CASE MANAGER AND THAT
REIMBURSEMENT SEAMLESSLY
CONTINUED FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND VENDORS WERE
SECURED. I THINK HEARING LINES
OF CREDIT WE ARE URGING THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION OF A
ONE TIME 15% CAPACITY GRANT
BUILT. BASED ON THE FUNDING
ALLOCATED FOR THE NEW LOTS OR
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND. WHAT'S THAT
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE EXISTING
CAPACITY OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAM. WE ASK THAT THERE BE
CONSIDERATION OF CONTINUING IN
PERPETUITY THE HOLD HARMLESS AND
REIMBURSING FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND CENTERS BASED ON
ENROLLMENT AND NOT IT HASN'T
BEEN A CHILD. THAT IS BACK TO
BANDS THAT ON JUNE THIRTY A
POLICY IN PLACE NOW UNTIL JUNE
THIRTY HAS CREATED PARITY AND
FAIRNESS FOR ALL THAT THAT I
FAMILY. AFFECTS CHILDCARE
SETTINGS THAT THAT THE COURT
THEY NEED FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND
NOT RESTRICTED BASED ON THE
FLUCTUATING WORK SCHEDULES AND
THEIR PARENTS. IT ALLOWED TO
INSPIRE THOUSANDS OF EXISTING
LOW INCOME CHILDREN ABLE CHILD
CARE SETTING ARE FACING
IMMEDIATE DIFFERENT ROMAN TERM
CARE IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND
UNDER TWENTY TWO BETTER. IT'S
THAT TO DESCEND ROLL OVER TWO
HUNDRED CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT ABSORB THE FINANCIAL
INSECURITY FINALLY IT IS
CRITICAL TO SHORE UP THESE NON
AND ESTABLISH COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAM SO SHIFTED FROM FEEDING
NEEDED THE ACT THAT. AS PART OF
THAT YES WITH THE BUILT UPON THE
DIRECT INTERACTION THE NONPROFIT
CATHOLIC PARENTS. IF THE ABOUT
THE FOURTEEN A ONE STOP PLACE
FOR THEIR- ORDINATION OF THEIR
COURTNEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'LL SHARE HOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EIGHT YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT COURT PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
FORTY FIVE PEOPLE. THE NEW
MATTER AND MEMBERS JERRY CALL
WITH NEAREST COMMENTING ON
ISSUES IT COULD BE CARE NEEDS
ONE I LEGISLATURE IN ADVANCE FOR
THEIR ACTION LAST YEAR. SORT OF
EIGHT MILLION FOR MEALS OR IN
CHILD CARE BUT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO BUILD ON THAT AND THAT THE
GLASS YEAR BUT FREE MEALS ALL
KIDS INCREASE AND CARE AT THE
AGE POINT DO ALL KEY. TWELVE
WHAT ADEQUATE FUNDING AND
SUPPORT THE CHILD ADULT CARE.
FROM HAS BEEN TO THE GAP AND ACT
AT TO HEALTH MEALS AND CHILD.
WHAT THE BOY THE PLANE STABILITY
OF THE CARE. OR WITH THE BOARD
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
BROADER LEGISLATE MINUTES TO
ENSURE THAT OUR YOUNGER LEARNERS
EVEN TRACTION NEED ADDED CHAO
CARE FOR. I'M. WASHINGTON
ADVOCATES POLICY INFLUENCERS
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
RESEARCHERS. FACULTY NONPROFIT
LEADERS EARLY EDUCATORS
CAREGIVERS PROVIDERS FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. WE WANT ONE
FAMILY TO HAVE OPTIONS TO CHOOSE
FROM AND DETERMINING WHICH
SETTING WILL WORK BEST FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. WE WANT BLACK CHILDREN
TO RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THEIR COUNTY
TO COUNTY. WHAT BLACK CHILDREN
TO BE ENGAGED IN CULTURALLY
AFFIRMING CARE AND EDUCATION. WE
WANT BLACK FAMILIES WITH VARYING
EXPERIENCES TO BE INTENTIONALLY
INCLUDED AND STATE LEVEL
ENCRYPTION BEINGS AND WORKING
GROUP. WE WANT BLACK ADVISORY
ESTABLISHED IN ADEQUATELY FUNDED
AT THE LOCAL COUNTY AND STATE
LEVEL. WE WANT BASIC UNIVERSAL
INCOME FOR BLACK FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY WOMEN AND MOTHERSWE
WANT LACK EARLY EDUCATORS THREE.
THANK THAN PAYMENT TO ADDRESS
THE RACIAL WAGE GAP. WE WANTED
HIGH BLANCA BLACK EDUCATORS TO
WORK ACROSS SETTINGS THE JOB
WORLD. AND TO PROVIDE BLACK
CHILDREN ACT THAT THE BLACK
CAREGIVERS AND EDUCATORS WANT
STATE GRANTS AND CONTRACTS FOR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
SERVICES TO PRIORITIZE.
INDEPENDENTLY AND BLACK OWNED
EASY EASY PROGRAMS AND FINALLY
HAVE GRADUATION. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
I'M FOR NINE PRESCHOOL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICK WITH
CHILD ON THE ASSOCIATE CONTENT
ACCOUNT BOARD ALTERED PAYMENT
PROGRAM PROVIDER SUPPORTING OVER
SIX THOUSAND FAMILIES WITH
AFFORDABLE FLEXIBLE CHILDCARE
VOUCHERS. BUT WE HAVE SHIFTED
RESOURCES AND ADAPTED TO MEET
THE PANDEMIC COSTS SHIFTED TO
VIRTUAL SUPPORT AND IMPLEMENTED
THE VERY MANY CHANGES COMING
FROM THE STATE AND YET AT THE
SAME TIME WERE CRUSHED BY RISE
IN INFLATION UNFUNDED MANDATE.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDS PROVIDED DID
NOT JUST CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CHILD CARE DOCTORS BUT ALSO TO
EXPAND TO SERVE THE A HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND ADDITIONAL CHILDREN
OF APPROVED IN THE STATE BUDGET.
I'M I'M URGING YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF A ONE TIME
CAPACITY GRANT 50% KEEP OUR
DOORS OPEN AND- ALSO BE ABLE. TO
QUICKLY AND ROLE. THE OF
CHILDREN THAT WE NEED TO ENROLL
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ARE THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET AND ALSO IN
THE FUTURE YEAR THE ADDITIONAL
SPOTS BEING PROPOSED. FINALLY I
ACT THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO
FROM THIS. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GO
AHEAD PLEASE GLAD YES HI MY NAME
IS A YOUNG FERNANDO AND LOCAL-
PROBABLY COMING FISCAL. AND
RIGHT NOW BERMAN THE REPORT IN
THE TIME OF ME AND MY ASKING IS
THE GREEN SUPPORT THE FAMILY
BISTRO OUT THIS NUMBER. TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
LEVINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LEAD
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW WE
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION AND PENALIZE THEM BUT
CHILD WELFARE AND CHILD CARE AND
BACK FO YOU KNOW MY COMMENTS
AREN'T ISSUE THREE THREE BACK.
ACCORDING TO THE MINISTRY
TRAILER BONDING THAT BALK CARE
K. AND DIDN'T. INCOME HUMAN FROM
CONSIDERATION AT INCOME CHILD
CARE AT THE- BUT I WANT TO
ELEVATE THE NEED. FOR THE
MORNING THEM BY IN THE WORD THE
CHILD CARE BRING WITH THE POOR
THE PERFECT PLACE FOR CHILDREN
AND DR. I LOVE BURKE NO MATTER
PENDING THE BRIDGE HAS ROBACH
BENEFITS OF BOTH. OF THEM AND
HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT BRIDGE
BETWEEN THE TEETH BECAUSE THEY
LANGUAGE. BUT I WOULD EMPHASIZE
THE URGENT AND IMMEDIATE NEED
AROUND SHORING UP OUR FRAGILE
CHARACTERS OF THE MEMBER OR TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
EQUALIZATION BUDGET AFTER ROUND.
BREAK WAITED DALY STEVEN
PHANTASMAGORIA DARK PERSONAL AND
GRANT THEY NEED COMPETING AT THE
VATICAN DOCUMENT BANGKOK IN
SUPPORT THAT WE CAN REALLY. I'M
HAPPY THAT NEEDED HERE AS AFTER
ALL THE EXISTING CHANGES AND
SUPPORTING A PROPOSAL. REPORTER
AND I'M READING OUT BUDGET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT COLOR PLEASE
. THANK YOU I THINK FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MARC ENDED
SAN FRANCISCO I A FIVE YEAR OLD
INCREASE TO KILL DISTRICTS AND I
FOR CHIU CARE POLICY TRAFFICKING
I HAVE TO GO UP MY COULD. MY
WHOLE AND WILL BE IT AND ALL TO
MAKE AND I CAN HOW CAN I ALIGNED
A LOT OF BY. NUMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR INCREASE PROVIDER
WAITED BY MAKING THE OVER SB
EMBARKING VERY. PARTY OF THE
RICH 97% OF THE WORKERS ARE
WOMEN. PEOPLE ARE LEFT ON THE
GROUND SHE TREATS. EVERYONE
DISABILITY WAGE AND LASTLY. OUR
GOVERNMENT DOUBLE BOOKED CREATE
THIRTY THOUSAND PLUS I WILL HELP
FAMILIES MINE QUALIFY IN HEALTH
CONTRIBUTE ACTIVE KINDLY BY
GOING BACK WORK THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COLOR. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY CRITICAL HAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM MOLLY BYNUM OF
THE W. LOCAL VERY THIRTY IF YOU
WANT TO GET HIGHLIGHT ECHOED
OUTSTANDING MADE BY THE DEVIL
QUALITY YOU OF ALL OF THOSE MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE KEN ROSENBERGER
YEAH CAN. ONLY TALK ABOUT. ACT
ON THE MANY COMMUNITIES LEADERS
ARE TO BE AS SUCH AND WHILE WE
AGREE. THE BUT REPORTER OF THE
WORK THE SPA. ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL AND WE URGE OF
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE AND
MINISTRY OUR I FURTHER ON THAT
THE REQUIREMENT OKAY AND TAKE
TIME OFF AND THAT FAR. DOWN THE
OF. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLOR. ALL THANK YOU BY
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
JUST HERE THAT STATE OF THAT
SPEAKING TO ISSUE. DETECTIVES
CREATION IN THE REGION SIGNATURE
INVESTOR TO FURTHER SUPPORT
FOSTERS AND YOU AND COUNTY
ACCORDING TO BE STRONG ON THE
SHOULD THE SHERIFF. THAT'S OFTEN
BOARD TO CONTINUE TO SERVICES
PORT BROWN WILL CHALLENGE
WITHOUT MIND THE IT STRONGLY OF
THE TYPICAL THE EVERY DAY BACK
AND NAJAF. I CAN'T MAINTAIN IT
REQUEST APPROVAL PROCESS WITH
THE NEW REQUIRED AFTER ELEVEN
THAT INCREASE COUNTY WORK WILL
NEED TO BE FUNDED THE THUNDER
NINE GENERAL WAS. THIS C. C. R.
WORK AND HOW COUNTY ANY OTHER
CHAO LAW FIRM. AND THEN READING
PAPERS ABOUT MILLION BASS WILL
BE CRITICAL SUPPORT TO RETAIN
FAMILIES CARE FOR CHILDREN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BYE FIFTEEN.
PEOPLE HAVE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES COHERENTLY GLASS- I'M
BECAUSE I'M MY NAME IS YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON- ARE YOUR
NEXT CHILD CARE PROVIDER AND I
WANTED TO- I'M LOOKING FOR- DAY
SHE- FOR PROBABLY I THINK HE'S
VERY- VERY. FOR PEOPLE FAMILIES
- YOU CAN CALL THE EIGHT CARRICO
THEY LOST THEIR JOB IS PRESENT
IN THE LATINO IN A COMMUNITY
WHERE. ARE WORKERS THAT- NEED-
HEY WORK. HE SAID WAY THEY GO
MANY OF LOST THEIR- I THEY ARE
NOT NOT NOT BE ABLE TO PAY DAY
AND DOES SHE- SALT. ASK
CORPORATE BOTH FUNDING NEEDS-
AND I'LL GIVE THEM THE MOVE FROM
- ALL. SENATOR FOR THE CHILDREN
TOGETHER CHILDREN I- ALWAYS THE
DEPEND- CONSEQUENCE. I WANTED
TO- PLEASE SUPPORT CAL IF YOU
TIME. BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY YOU
THINK VERY MUCH. ABOUT WHAT.
THAT THANK YOU FOR FIFTY SEVEN
CALL. SHARE NUMBER OF MY IS JOHN
GRATZ THE RECORD ANYTHING THIS
CALL AND OUR LOVE IN CHAPTER
ACROSS THE STATE. WHAT THEY CALL
BY OUT WHICH INCLUDES OUR
SUPPORT BUT THE THOUSAND BALLOTS
AND GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BY J. SO
THAT MORE. CAN ACCESS CHILD
BASED OFF OF DASH MOVE. OUT MUST
ACCOUNT WITH DELAYED AND
BLEACHING FOR PROVIDE. I NEED TO
PARENTS AND PROVIDERS BEEN
COMMITTED EACH OTHER TOO LONG
OUR SYSTEM. IF THE ARE TO BE.
OWN OF THEIR NEEDS AT THE SAME
TIME SHOULD PARENTS PROVIDERS I
GET CLOSE THE TICKET. MENTION
SHE ALL BY OUT AREN'T CHARGE IN
INTO. THANK YOU THINK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER. AS WELL EASY
FELLAS BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND WITHOUT READING
REMEMBERS AND READ MORE
PROVIDERS ARE AT RISK OF
CLOSING. ADDITIONALLY WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT THE RACIAL AND GENDER
PAY GAP IN CALIFORNIA YET OUR
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE PER
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
INSTITUTIONALIZE IT UNLIVABLE
WAGES REALLY EASY DEAL. 97% OF
THEM ARE WOMEN AND THE MAJORITY
OF THEM ARE WOMEN OF COLOR. IT
IS CRITICAL THAT OUR NEXT BUDGET
RAISES THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR PROVIDERS. WE ALSO WANT TO
SEND THE FAMILY FEE WAIVER UNTIL
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
SO I TWENTY TWENTY ONE FAMILY TO
STAY NEARLY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
SPENT ON FAMILY B. THANKS FOR
THE WAIVER. IT'S TIME WE STOP
SUBSIDIZING THE SYSTEM ON THE
BACK TO WORKING FAMILIES AND BE
WAITING FAMILIES EITHER THE
CRITICAL ANTI POVERTY MEASURES
SIMILAR TO THE EARNED INCOME
AND- CHILD TAX CREDIT. ALL THREE
OF YOU TOGETHER INCREASING SLOTS
RATING REIMBURSE RATING WAITING
FAMILY THESE FUNCTIONS TOGETHER
TO BUILD A MORE. EQUITABLE CHILD
CARE SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M SIXTY ONE HAS. WHY ARE
YOU HEAR ME HELLO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. FIRE HELLO MY NAME IS
MEGAN MARKER AND I LIVE IN
RICHMOND AND I'M A PROUD MEMBER
PARENT VOICES I HAVEN'T EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD AND A THREE YEAR OLD
AND I'M ASKING YOU AS A NEIGHBOR
WELL BY COLLEGES MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER AND MOST IMPORTANT MY
IMPORTANT ROLE CAMANCHE. THAT'S
NOT BEING ABLE TO PUT YOUR BABY
TO SLEEP BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
WORK TONIGHT I WAS OVERREACH
DRIVER JUST TO PAY YOUR BILL AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY PAYER
HEALTHCARE BILL AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT I WAS ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE FAMILY NEED TO BE. A
BAG BUT I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS
GOING TO THREE THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH WE'RE WE'RE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK I
MAXED OUT MY STUDENT LOANS MY
HUSBAND ANOTHER SOCIAL WORKER
HAVE A LONG COMMUTE AND GET
INCOME GOES TO GAS AND RENT WE
HAVE HEY WE HAVE. FIFTEEN GMT
THAT MEASURE COULDN'T MAKE IT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY FIRST FOUR
WEEKS- WE WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
GO AHEAD AND CATCH UP ON OUR
PG&E PG&E AND THAT MEANS SO MUCH
TO ME SO WHAT I'M ASKING IS BACK
WE'RE CALLING ON YOU TO PLEASE
AND THE PRACTICE OF PAYING FOR
HEALTH CARE ON THE BACKS OF OUR
WORKING FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
ALREADY STRETCHED THIN BECAUSE-
MUCH YOU AWFUL CRISIS I'M GONNA.
THANK THANK YOU I TWENTY. PEOPLE
HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MY
NAME IS OF GOOD FOR IN A CERTAIN
THE DIRECTOR PUBLIC POLICY AT
CHILD THREE SIXTY AND WE JOIN
WITH WHAT YOU COLOR INCOME ON
THE LETTER TO RAISE THREE RATES
FOR HER. DOING SO WILL HELP IN
THAT YOU PROFESSIONAL THERE A
FAIR WAGE ADDRESS THE CURRENT SO
. AND WILL BETTER SUPPORT YOU'LL
COME MOST OF WOMEN OF COLOR THAT
HAS BEEN UNDER CALL IN UNDER
RESOURCE FOR FAR TOO LONG WE
APPLAUD THE LEGISLATURE FOR
SECURING CRITICAL RATE INCREASES
THE LAST. YEAR'S BUDGET BUT WE
NEED TO DO MORE. THE LEGISLATORS
AT ALL SERVICE. EXPAND EASY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT
DOLLARS. THE REQUESTED TWENTY.
EIGHT WHEN YOU SEE EACH OTHER
FACING A STAFFING SHORTAGE.
STAFFING SHORTAGE WHICH HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THOUSAND THE TILE
CARE CLOSURES DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND PERPETUATED BY
CHRONICALLY LOW WAGES THESE
WORKFORCE DOLLARS ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT. IT WILL HELP EXPAND
EASY WORKFORCE AND SUPPORT
CURRENT EARLY EDUCATORS IN
ACHIEVING THEIR PROFESSIONAL
ASPIRATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU MIND SIX EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BONNIE OF COMMITTEES AND THE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIRECTOR AT
HEAD START CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING TO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THE FIFTEEN MILLION
EIGHT BUDGET. AND GET BUDGET
FUNDS TO SUPPORT HEAD START
TEACHER SALARY ANSWER PROGRAMS
ARE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED FOR
THEIR HIGH QUALITY CHILD WHOLE
FAMILY SERVICES- YOU JUST HEARD
FOR A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
EARLIER ALL THE FOLKS THAT
CHALLENGES BACKING CHILD CARE
PROGRAM WHEN WE CANNOT PAY
COMPETITIVE WAGES AND BENEFITS.
THE AVERAGE HEAD START TEACHER
IN CALIFORNIA MAKES FORTY ONE
THOUSAND A YEAR WHICH IS TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND LESS THAN THE
AVERAGE KINDERGARTEN TEACHER
FUNDING ALLOCATED TO INCREASE
SALARIES AND STATE SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAMS DOES NOT IMPROVE
COMPENSATION FOR FEDERALLY
FUNDED HEAD START TEACHERS WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZED HEAD START AS A VITAL
PART OF THE MIX OF THE BRAKE
SYSTEM I REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT SO
THAT OUR PROGRAM CAN CONTINUE
RECRUITING AND RETAINING OUR
HIGH QUALITY TEACHERS. AND START
HELPING YOU ALSO LIKE TO
INDICATE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
FULL BUDGET REQUEST AND BE EASY
IN THE BUDGET COALITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICE
COLOR PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY THREE FOUR. THANK YOU HI
MANY IS MY FOREVER NOW AMERICAN
KIDDING GO I DON'T PAST COUPLE
OF HAVE BEEN REALLY HARD ON OUR
FAN THEN YOU CHILDREN AND I.
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
WORKFORCE TO. SO YOU COULD BE ON
I DON'T HAVE HARD BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND WE ACTED DANGLE- WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAD BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH FOR OUR AFTERNOON
IT'S PAST YEAR'S BUDGET. BUT I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
LIFT UP THE VOICES OF PARENTS
AND TEACHERS. THERE ARE PARENTS
AND TEACHERS ARE BURNT OUT
STRESSED AND TRAUMATIZED IF WE
VALUE THE WELL BEING OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES WE NEED TO VALUE
THAT PROFESSIONALS SERVING THEM
DAY IN AND DAY OUT. IF WE DON'T
WE WON'T HAVE AN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION WORK FOR WHICH OUR
ECONOMY DESPERATELY. NEEDS HELP
THINGS ARE EASY WORK WORK AND
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA COME BACK BY
INCREASING THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE AND LEADING. VERY MUCH
COOLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ONE
FIFTIES SIX PRO I. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARIE ROMO I AM THE TALK
RESEARCH CENTER ARE THE LARGEST
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
NONPROFIT IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET REQUEST
FOR BOTH CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND CHILD KERR
DEVELOPMENT AT THE STATE WE NEED
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE AND LEVERAGE
CHILD WELFARE INVESTMENT
INCREASE CONVERSATIONS AND
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I AM SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FROM
THE INTERNET I AM A MOTHER TO
TWO CHILDREN AGES SEVEN AND
BACK. I AM ALSO A RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND I AM A
GOOD CONSTITUENTS AND UNDERSTAND
THIS DISTRICT. BOTH OF MY
CHILDREN WERE INVOLVED IN A
CHILD CARE CENTER THEY ARE NOW
AND BURKE AND KINDERGARTEN AND
THE MOTHER I LOOKED AT THE
QUALITY OF FINDING CHILD CARE
FOR MY CHILDREN WHEN THEY WERE
YOUNGER. AND ALSO HAVE THE PAPER
CARE ACT BE CRITICAL THAT AND I
STRUGGLED I AM HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY THAT PARENTS NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE CHAU BAKER. WAITING
FAMILIES SPEAK WALK WIN VOTER
EXPENSES LIKE HOUSING AND GROUP
IMPORTANTLY INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT GRATEFUL THAT OUR
FUTURE CAN HAVE A LIVABLE WAGE
THERE WERE OTHER CHILDREN EVERY
DAY AND ESPECIALLY DURING COLDER
TIME THEY HAVE BEEN SHOWING UP
EVERY DAY TO WORK AND EXPOSING
THEMSELVES TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
CHILDREN. OUR FAMILIES WORK THEY
NEED TO BE PAID MORE HI I'M
OFFICE BENEFITS INCLUDING YOUR
RETIREMENT PLAN THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT. TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TO
AND RUN HELLO MY NAME MONTANA
REPRESENTING BRADY. A NETWORK OF
THE COMPUTER MOST OF ALL THE
PUBLIC CARS THERE YET CON. OR TO
SUPPORT OUR- COLLEAGUES THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
COALITION BUDGET OUT PRIORITIES
A DIFFICULT BIT LEARNING ABOUT
GREATLY DISRUPTED AND ARE YOU
HAVE DEMONSTRATED A SHARP
DECLINE IN THE MENTAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. AND IN ORDER FOR A
STUDENT OF DR WE NEED ROBUST
INVESTMENT IN THE EARLY
DEVELOPMENT THE DESTRUCTION OF
STUDENT LEARNING OF ALL IMPACTED
OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY THE
SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND RISING COSTS
HAVE RESULTED IN THE ABSENTEEISM
OF WORKING PARENTS ESPECIALLY%
MOMS. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE BY
THE NATION COMMISSION WITH
SURVEY OF SENIOR BUSINESS
LEADERS WHAT WORK FOR COMPANIES
WITH AT LEAST FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL REVENUE 36% OF
EMPLOYERS REPORTED THAT WOMEN
WERE LEAVING THE WORK FORCE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS BUT 38%
OF DEPARTING WORKERS FINDING.
CHILDCARE EVEN FOR THEIR
DEPARTURE. WITH 68% OF EMPLOYERS
PAYING. COVER SUPPORT TECHNIQUE
. AND CHILD CARE WITH.
INCREDIBLY BY. TO RETAIN THEIR-
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THIRTY SIX GO OUT. NINE THREE
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI
DEATHLY AFRAID A LITTLE TROUBLE
GETTING IN MY NAME IS JIM BOB I
WAS JUST LEADER AND I'M BORN
INTO POVERTY AND THE PARENTS AND
CHILDREN AND I'M ALSO A FORMER
PROVIDER. AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THERE'S A COUPLE ADDS THAT
I STRONGLY SUPPORT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THEY MOVE US TOWARDS
HAVING MORE OF EXACTLY CHILD
CARE OR ECONOMIC STABILITY IN
OUR FAMILY AND RATED CAPE
ALREADY AND ALSO NEARLY HALF ARE
CHILDREN I THINK BY HAVING
EXTENDED FAMILY HE WAVERS OR
HELPING PROMOTE ECONOMIC
STABILITY IT IS SO HARD SOMEBODY
SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE. BETWEEN
MAKING AND ERNIE AND HE
CONFIRMED THEIR CHILD- THERE WAS
AN ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT WITH
MEGHAN MARKLE AND SHE SAID NO
FAMILY SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN EARNING A LIVING HAVING
THE FREEDOM TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR CHILDREN I THINK BY
EXTENDING FAMILY B. WAIVERS. WE
ARE BRINGING THAT. YOUR LIFE
WILL BRING THAT TO LIFE WORST.
THAT I. THAT ALSO BY. PROVIDER
WE I KNOW THAT WE IWAS A
PROVIDE I COULD BARELY. AFFORD
MY- AND I BECAME. AND YOU'RE A
LOT OF THINGS THANK YOU VERY.
ALL PLEASE. THANK YOU THIRD FOUR
PLEASE CALL HAS. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MONEY DRYING ZORA'S- I'M THE
OWNER AND DIRECTOR OF ONLY LOVE
CHILDREN PRESCHOOL CENTER WE'VE
BEEN SERVICING OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR CHILDREN FAMILY FOR THIRTY
NINE YEARS NOW AND- THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE'VE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST
WE EVER HAPPENED WE SERVE
PROBABLY TWO HUNDRED FAMILIES
AND IF IT WASN'T FOR THE HELD
HARMLESS- WE WOULDN'T BE IN
BUSINESS SO I AM THANKFUL FOR
THE GOVERNOR AND- AND FOR ALL OF
YOU FOR HELPING US- PRIVATE
LOANS. TO PRIVATE CHILDCARE
OWNERS OUT AND WE ARE YOU SEE S.
P. PROGRAM AND MY HOPE IS THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS LIKE OURS AND CERTAINLY
THE HELD HARMLESS AND WE CAN THE
FAMILY FEES GOES A LONG WAY SO
WE CAN SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY SO
THANK YOU ALL FOR ALL YOUR HELP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
CRITICAL. NUMBER THREE ON A HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION
DURING THE PANDEMIC ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS WERE GIVEN THE
ABILITY TO EXPEDITE THE ROMANCE
OF THE CHILDREN OF THE SOCIAL
WORKERS INTO CHILD CARE FOR
THEIR PARENTS CONSERVE ON THE
FRONT LINE POLICY WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL FOR BUT WE'LL SUNSET ON
JUNE THIRTIETH THIS YEAR MANY OF
THESE ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE
STILL INCOME ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE VOUCHERS.
BUT LET'S GO THROUGH THE MUCH
LONGER EMPLOYMENT PROCESS NOW
PLEASE OUR AGENCIES ALREADY
SHORT STAFFED AND RUNNING ON
VERY THIN MARGINS WITH THE NEW
UNFUNDED WORKLOAD OTHER ROLE IN
THE FAMILY ENDICOTT ON AND
HAVING TO RETURN THOSE MUCH
NEEDED ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
BACK TO THE STATE ANY CLEAR OUR
AGENCIES CAN AND WANT TO ENSURE
THE SOCIAL WORKER GET ENROLLED
INTO STABLE CAPS LOCK BURKE
STRUGGLING WITH STAFFING AND
CAPACITY WE STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED HE ACTION
TO ALLOW AN EXPANDED COVERT
NINETEEN. CENTRAL WORKER FONG
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TURN PAYMENT
PROGRAMS AND ROLL OVER INTO
ACCOUNT CONTRACT BUT ARE YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE FAMILIES
THAT ARE DURING THE DROP IN THE
INDICTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY EIGHT
CRITICAL HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON NAME IS HOPPER
CALLING AND MARK OF ANY FOR
TRYINGTO. READY BY INVESTING
HIS IMAGE RIGHT THAT OUR
MEMBERSHIP OF LEADERS AND
BUSINESS ON BOARD MULLIN NO
COMPANY ABOUT IN OUR TURN A. ON
THE PAPER COMMUNITIES HELP
WORKING AND FAMILY CRIED. WITH
THE BUDGET- REQUESTS FROM THE-
COALITION PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT THE THAT PART TO WORK.
WITHIN AN INVESTOR AND- IN
HEALTH CARE. WAIT INCREASING
ACTOR BADLY FAMILY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND FIVE OUR WORK
FORCE. DEVELOPMENT FACILITY WE
NEED TO ENSURE OUR HOUSE SYSTEM.
TO STRENGTHEN AND EXPAND. AT THE
CONTINUE TO FROM DEVASTATING
IMPACT THE COMPANY PANDEMIC
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU RAIMES
SIXTY TWO CALL I HAVE. WHAT DOES
THE NAME COME THANK YOU THE
DISCUSS ABOUT TO COMMENT ON
COUPLE AYE WELL IF IT'S THE
POINT SEVEN PRO HOME PROVIDER
HAS MILLION AS- THE PHONE AND WE
HAVE. AMPLE THE PROPOSAL FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION BY ANNUALLY ARE
YOU SURE I IN COME BY THE- TO
THE NEAR I'M GOING FUNDING FOR
THE- PROPOSAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MUCH COLOR PLAY. THANK
I'M SO NINE PRETTY GLAD. MANY IS
BERNARD ALL I LIVE IN HERE HAVE
CHARGE AND I COULD CENTER IT.
THANK REMEMBER RATE CREATE THAT
NATURE CARE CAN BE PAID MORE
TONIGHT TO- MIGHT KEEP DEAL OF
MY KIDS AND HEARING HEM. AND
TEACHING THE POINT BY SKILLS AND
NOW THEY STRICT CODE PER COST.
WHAT THAT TEACHERS. HELPED
ENSURE AS WELL THE- HE IS CARE
OF- AS THEIR TAKING CARE OF MY
KIDS ARE DAY. ON I DON'T FEES IT
HARD BECAUSE THE MISSING A LOT
OF WORK THAT MAKE IT THANK WITH
THAT. THE NEW HOGAN PROTOCOL-
AND CHILDCARE HELP MY FAMILY BY
ALLOWING HUSBAND POLITICAL.
ASPECT FOR ME TO WORK. ON THE
CHILD CARE. TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NUMBER
EVERYTHING IN THE COURSE SO THAT
ALL CHILDREN L. A. COUNTY ENTER
KINDERGARTEN READY TO SUCCEED IN
SCHOOL AND LET. WE WILL ALIGN
OUR MESSAGE TO THE LOCAL EASY I
THINK COALITION AND MY FELLOW
PRIORITY INVESTMENT IN CONCORD
PROVIDER WEEKEND IT WILL BE A
FAMILY FEES AND NOTHING LESS
NOTHING SHOCKER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RYAN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL
HAS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SARAH SORIANO I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF YOUNG HORIZONS
CHILDHOOD CANCERS IN LONG BEACH
I WANT TO START BY SAYING THANK
YOU TO EACH ONE OF YOU FOR
BELIEVING IN OUR PROGRAMS AND
THE INVESTMENTS THAT HAPPENED
LAST MARCH THE HOLD HARMLESS HAS
VIRTUALLY SAVED OUR LIVES. WE
HAVE REMAINED OPEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SERVE OUR FAMILIES WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO KEEP OUR STOP WORKING-
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
AND I WOULD PLEAD THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO HOLD HARMLESS. FOR
ANOTHER YEAR THROUGH THE FEDERAL
FISCAL YEAR ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND WADE THE FAMILY
SEES OUR FAMILY IS HAPPENING I
LISTEN TO OTHER OTHER FAMILY AS
THEY GET THEIR TESTIMONY AND IT
HAS BEEN A LIFE CHANGER FOR
THEM- I REALLY URGE YOU TO
CONTINUALLY THE WAIVEROF THE
FAMILY SHE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE. OF WORKERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THIS CALL PLEASE
. HERE MY SEVENTY FIVE PER GO
AHEAD. YEAH HI MY NAME PLEASE
LOOK FOR ORG OKAY POLICE
DEPARTMENT ALL AND I YOU KNOW
MYSELF IN THE WAITING LIST BUT
SHALL CARE- I'M CALLING WARRANT
. EASY AMONG BUT READ YOUR. WE
DON'T HEALTH CARE I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN A TO WORK WITH ME THE
CHILD I WASN'T THE FOR INPUT
CARE FOR TO YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
I HAVE TO MIGHT THANK GOD.
THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY WHEN I
GOT IT OVER MICHAEL A CHILD CARE
BUT NOT THE AND THE POOL THE
BOTH OUR OF CHILD IT LOOKS GREAT
WHO ARE MY CALLED MONTHLY MY
DAUGHTER CAME BACK MORE WHAT
DON'T ORDER JEWEL. SO WE THE
FIVE USED BECAUSE CHEN BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND TO CREATE A COULD
SYSTEM YEAH YOU MUST BE MADE MY
LAST YEAR HE WAS STRANDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. EIGHT I
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN MY REMARKS
WITH THE BUDGET REQUEST OF THE
ECONOMIST. TO INCREASE RATES FOR
ALL PROVIDERS DIRECT CONTRACTING
HOW TO BUY PROGRAM ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM. SHARE THE WAY
FAMILY SPEAKS WITH APART MINUTES
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE ACCESS BY
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED BATES. IN
ADDITION- IN ORDER TO KEEP EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE WE REQUEST
THAT THE CONTINUATION OF THE
HOLD HARMLESS ALL RIGHT PROGRAM.
THE PAST PEOPLE PROGRAMS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE DOWN IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE OR STILL
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE VACCINE.
THEREFORE CONTINUALLY TO FUND
PROGRAMS WITH THE HOLD HARMLESS
CLAUSE WILL ALLOW PROGRAMS TO
TO BE ABLE TO REBUILD PROGRAM.
FOR CHILDREN CALIFORNIA WERE
ALSO REQUESTING THE FULLY
FUNDING OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EXPANSION
PLANS. FOR THE FUTURE RT.
ABSOLUTELY AD THANK YOU THANK
YOU MINE FORTY TWO GO AHEAD. I
DON'T WANT THE LITTLE MISS. SIX
THANK BILLION SO YOU NEED YOU
GET A IN THE LAST THAT IS
MEMBERS CONGRESS OF PEOPLE
FOLLOWING OR YEAR IN THE PROGRAM
AND ITS HAVE A BY ARMS NEW. I DO
WANT TO YOUNG IF I'M END OF
ANYTHING DIRECTOR FROM MIND IT
IS A LOOKING GOOD SO IT OF OUR
AS THEY ACTED IN MY THEY FEEL
COMFORTABLE A LONG OF BILLION
ESPN IF THE NOT ACCESS AT THE
END IS A VERY DAY WE DO CUENTA
ENOUGH AND THEY YEAH THEY CARE
AND PROGRAM AND WITH OTHER NEED
TO IF I WAS THERE CRAZY CURRENT
I DO NOT CREDIT ANNA IT DOES
LOOK AT THE ONLY BALLOT IS BACK
I LOVE FOR OVER HAVE MOST OF MY
BONUS WILL BE. INSTEAD THAT THEY
PUT UP WITH THAT NINA FOR
POSSIBLE SEE ACT ALTHOUGH
MEMBERS THEY CLOSED HOPE OF
BELIEVE YOU I HAVE BEEN ADDED TO
SAY THE BCO ANYTHING FAMILY BOB
DOLE FROM THE LEFT OVER TO
ADDRESS GARCIA GOOD ACTORS ARE
TRAVEL FUND.
YEAH THE PROPOSAL
ALL WORK TOGETHERTO BUILD A
MORE EFFORT ON CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I AVE NO MORE COMMON
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR- AND AGAIN
IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE LINE TODAY WE- WHAT
WE DO WANT TO HEAR YOUR YOUR-
YOUR COMMENTS AND WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO. CONTACT THE COMMITTEE
FOR- FOR FURTHER INPUT AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUDGET SUB THREE
FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
FOR TODAY.